Õpetaja: Võime Screenshare I ka teha.
Õpetaja: Nii, minu esimene Küsimus teile. On selline, et ee.
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti. Kes jõudis vaadata need teemad üle. Mis? Ee, sai üles pandud?
Õpetaja: No see on parem kui mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, Kuidas tundus? Ee, see
Õpetaja: client server back and Server database Ja Flow.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas? Nagu, ee, niiöelda süsteemid omavahel suhtlevad. Kas see nagu enamvähem hakkab vaikselt, nagu et kuidas süsteemid suhtlevad, me Saame sõnumeid, mis seal mängivad rolli. Need urlid ja siis need tegusõnad, mis nüüd sinna lähevad juurde kett ja
Õpetaja: osta mis iganes
Õpetaja: Ee, Jason Ee, seal oli vist siis video. Isegi minu. Mingi vana eestikeelne video ka. Kuidas ee. Tegelikult on? Suht sarnane.
Õpetaja: Ee, jaavalegi. Vaata, on ju ka on sarnased annu tüübid. Võibolla nagu väiksemal määral.
Õpetaja: Massiivid Ee kast, mille sisse saab panna. Niiöelda siis, ee, mingeid ühetaolisi. Asju
Õpetaja: on see String. On see hint Või on see mingi objekt? Vahet pole reaalselt, Nad on ühetaolised.
Õpetaja: Mm. Siis isegi kas seal list oli ka arra? Tavaline list vist ei ole, onju?
Õpetaja: Panen selle järgmiseks korraks.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kohe. Teadmiseks, et see massiividega näiteks tsükeldamine. Ma võtan korra. See vist oli juba liftiga.
Õpetaja: Kuidas?
Õpetaja: Aa, no palun, vaadake. Ei, tahtsin ikka pigem ee normaalseid asju ka. Tõstsid vähe. Proovime
Õpetaja: arvelist, Aga tavaline list või Tegelt see oli arvelist. Ongi list, on ju?
Õpetaja: Jah, ta. Ta nagu seal. Listil on mitmeid listi. Ee, linkedist list.
Õpetaja: Ee, kohe ei tule Midagi veel meelde on veel. Ee, list on siis põhimõtteliselt nagu kõikide nende klasside. Niiöelda nagu pärand
Õpetaja: ja Arra ise on tegelikult seal, siis Taustal toimetab, et ma ütlen, et keegi enam nagu ee, selle nagu klassikalise harra ega midagi. Ei programmeeri väga,
Õpetaja: vaid kasutatakse mugavamaid klasse nagu list ja nii edasi. Sest et seal on sisse ehitatud meetodid, mis teevad midagi.
Õpetaja: Aga. Okei, see selleks siis peaaegu.
Jaroslav: Tead, jah, Aa, siis. Kõige tähtsamad asjad. Aa, if laused.
Jaroslav: Kus ma saan teha, Pool on siin.
Jaroslav: Kellegil on mikrofon sees.
Jaroslav: Vaatame.
Õpetaja: If Lause. Ee, see on nüüd siis kõige põhilisem tööriist. Ja vahet pole, mis Ee, keel või raamistik. If Laused On, Ee, enamus programmeerimiskeeltest. Ee, see on siis tegelikult otsustuspuu,
Õpetaja: et kas läheme ühes suunas või teises suunas. Ee, see on nagu, kõige. Noh, Ütleme, Baastasemel võib sellest asjast niimoodi mõelda, et on mingi teelahk ühtepidi või teistpidi. Ja siis on see tingimus. Ee, see, et, noh, miks, Ühel põhjusel minna ühes suunas või teises suunas, onju?
Õpetaja: Kuidas see siis nagu koodi tasandil avandub, Ongi siis see, et ee, if lausel, siis Kui seal sulgude vahel Ee, mingi. See peab olema mingi asi, mis rehkendub truuks või False iks. See peab olema. Siis mingisugune võrdlus või Võrrand. Ee, See ei saa olla lihtsalt niimoodi, et Ifi sees on väärtus kümme
Õpetaja: noh. See, on see. On väärtus see. Ei ole true Aga kui seal oleks Wi Fi sees, et kas kümme on väiksem kui? Sada siis, on see kohe võrdlus vaata. Et, see peab niiöelda pehkenduma.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja siis ongi see, et. Ee. Kui ta on true, siis lähed koodiblokki.
Õpetaja: Kui ta ei ole truus, siis ei lähe koodipakki.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis Else sinna juurde panna on juba kaks valikut. Vaata onju, et et kui ütleme näiteks If, iga näiteks lause et, ee,
Õpetaja: kasutaja on? Ee, ma ei tea. Siis ta saab kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Ee, saab kandideerida kuhugi. Ma ei tea või
Õpetaja: saab minna niuksele slaidile, näiteks mis on mõeldud siis täiskasvanutele.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, mis saidid Need võiksid olla, aga. Aga ütleme näiteks selline näide, et, ee, see on teepuu
Õpetaja: ja See else siis nagu veel ekstra variant, et saab. Lase kaks varianti. Ja mis juhtub siis, kui see asi on tõene,
Õpetaja: siis on nii Aga kui ei ole, siis tee midagi teistmoodi. Tavaline info. Lihtsalt vaata, et kas sa lähed sinna sisse või ei lähe. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: No Näiteks teeme. Teeme lihtsama näite. Vaata, näiteks on mingi teenus, mis vaatab, et kas sul on mailboxi tulnud? Ee, uus Ee. Email.
Õpetaja: Kui jah, Siis äkki näiteks saadab mul mingi notification. I saadab telefonile, et seal ei ole nagu seda Els I. Vaata, et ära saada
Õpetaja: et seal on ainult. Noh, ainult siis, kui on, siis saada Aga eelse puhul, nagu pole midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on mingisugused olukorrad, kus on siis ikkagi vaja. Üks või teine, Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: No ja siis on niiöelda, mis on siis põhimõtteliselt. Ee, sul saab olla mitu tingimust, et, ee, Kui on ee number niiöelda väiksem kui sada, siis tule siia. Kui ta on suurem kui
Õpetaja: ee suurem kui ma ei tea, kümme, tuhat Mine siin, tee seda. Vaata, et et neid saab olla nagu seal mitmeid tingimusi ka.
Õpetaja: Ee siis, ee. Mis veel Ee, and ee, not,
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes, et meil saab olla nii ühes tingimuses Mitu tingimust
Õpetaja: ja, ee, seal siis nagu käituvad niimoodi, et, ee, ma ei tea, kas keegi on õppinud niisugust asja nagu tööväärtustabel.
Õpetaja: Noh, lähete ülikooli tarkvaraarist õppima, siis seda õpite. See on see sama asi, mis siin sellest materjalist läbi käis, et kuidas käitub änd?
Õpetaja: Änd on ainult tõene. Siis kui mõlemad pooled tema poolel on truud,
Õpetaja: mingi mis iganes, niiöelda Rehkendus. Kui ee. Mõlemad tingimused on truup bändi poolel, siis see asi rehkendub truuks.
Õpetaja: Kui üks pooltest on False, siis ta ei ole enam truup.
Õpetaja: Noh, seda võibolla on koodi tasandil natukene nagu lihtsam ee vaadata. Või siis visualiseerida seda asja vähemalt,
Õpetaja: Noh, mis? Me siin ikka näed, Mis me siin ikka, Jeb? Ime, et ütlen parem siin Chatile, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Tee uus materjal. Ma isegi ei käivita Skill I, vaid Ma lihtsalt ütlen, tee uus materjal. Ta peaks siis selle skill I ava ise nagu ülesse pikkima materjal
Õpetaja: teemal.
Õpetaja: Tõe väärtustabel
Õpetaja: tabel and ja Voor.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, Seda head. Ma ei tahtnud sinna vahele panna, aga. Okei, saab aru küll.
Õpetaja: Seni kaua, kuni ta seda teeb, ma eeldan, et ta käivitab selle Skill I.
Õpetaja: See on erinev tellimus,
Õpetaja: näiteks.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma olen maha pandud, et ma ei taha nüüd telefoni pool, Nagu
Õpetaja: see on telefonipoolne blok, et süsteem ikkagi tegelikult saadab selle välja, et. Et, ee, selles mõttes ükski nagu väline süsteem, ei saa teada, Vaata, et, ee, Mis sul seal telefonis nagu toimub, onju? Et see on see sama tegelikult kui ka panna. Näiteks, ee.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingid slaid Ja teamsid, et saad panna nagu seda. Nagu selles mõttes, et ükski notification läbi ei tule, et see ei tähenda seda, et keegi, pole sul vahepeal kirjutanud midagi onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, et see sõnum läheb ikkagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, teele Muidugi ma selles mõttes. Vot jah pole mobiiliarendust. Ee, ma olen tegelikult mobiiliarendust ülikoolis teinud, aga stiilis neli ritta. Vaata mingi mänge ja muid asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, nad Tegelikult ma üldse eeldan, et ee, Telefon ju käib kontrollimas Küsimas, kas mul on sõnumeid iga teatud intervalli tagant.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee, siis. Ma mõtlen seda, et. Ee, siis, ee. Kas ta äkki siis kuskilt, kus see sõnum talle peab tulema, et kui Notification Id on maha keeratud, et äkki siis ta ei küsigi Ikkagi, et tegelikult ma võin. Ee, ma võin valetada.
Õpetaja: Ja ma muidugi arvan, et ta siin võib olla nagu erinevatel seadmetel ja erinevatel süsteemidel Mingid erinevad lähenemised ka. Et nagu kindlalt ei oska väita.
Õpetaja: Jah, sest et, ee. Jah, sest päeva lõpuks ikkagi. Sa pead ee. Kontrollima. Vist Kas midagi tuleb? Ma ei tea, Kuidas Mobiilside toimib. Nagu selles mõttes, kui telefonikõne tuleb sisse, Kuidas meid,
Õpetaja: See on hea küsimus on ju
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kas tööväärtustabeli kohta tegi siis midagi.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kas ta siia tegi tõeväetustabel. Näete et Taustal on käivitanud. Ee, selle
Õpetaja: ta taustal ilusti käivitas Selle skill I ise.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta seda teadis? Teha? Et seda skill I käivitada, on see, et minul see skill niiöelda, et loo uus Õppematerjal Ee Cloud loeb selle kohe alguse sisse ja ta loeb seda. Description It.
Õpetaja: Selle järgi teades
Õpetaja: siin on üks seadistus. Ee, millega saab seda maha ka keerata, et automaatselt ise ei saaks. Siia saab panna ühe rea juurde.
Õpetaja: Mul ei tule meelde, mis sõna see on ja peab panema, True. Vaata, et nagu. Et ära sina nagu ise Seda, nagu saad öelda Aile. Vaata, et ära sina seda ise käivita, et Mina käivitan sind nagu konkreetselt selle kaldkriips käsuga. Ee, praegu ei löö pähe. Mismoodi see on? Ee, aga vaatame, mis ta siis räägib.
Õpetaja: Tõeväärtustabel And Your algajatele.
Õpetaja: Ee, programmeerimisest tuleb pidevalt teha otsus, et kas näidata kasutajale viga, Kas lubada tal edasi minna? Ja kas kaks tingimust kehtivad Korraga. Selliste otsuste tegemiseks kasutatakse loogika operaatorid. Kõige läbimad on nendest. Ja tegelikult sa saad ju niimoodi Connect Ida väga mitu asja vaadata,
Õpetaja: kui Sina oled täiskasvanud ja sul on juhiluba. Ja sa oled. Ma Ei, tea, sündinud mingisugusel aastal. Siis kolm tingimust kaasa, vaata onju, siis peab midagi juhtuma
Õpetaja: või on? Ee, siis ee, teistmoodi. Vaata, et võil on niimoodi. Et kui üks pooltest on truu, siis tema jaoks on see Juba truu ja Ori puhul on niimoodi. Kuidas Ee, niiöelda siis programm käivitub? Kuidas programm töötab, kui ta koodi jookseb? Nii öelda?
Õpetaja: Et ee, Kui ta läheb kuskile niiöelda, oletame, et ta läheb kuskile If lausesse. Ja Ta näeb, et seal on hool võrrand,
Õpetaja: Kui vasakpoolne pool on juba truu, siis ta tegelikult paremat poolt pea Loor isegi ei vaata.
Õpetaja: Võibolla see omakorda rehkendatakse seal välja. Või mis iganes ta isegi ei Vaata, seda. Sellepärast pole Point I
Õpetaja: kui üks nagu, et, ee, kui üks või pooltest on. Ee, Noh, see on nagu see, et, ee, Kui
Õpetaja: kui. Aa, noh, Toome siis nagu näite. Vaata, et, ee, kui isik, Ee omab juhiluba
Õpetaja: ja siis ta oleks või,
Õpetaja: ja ta on Täi või ta on täiskasvanud. Vaata siis, nagu või tal on. Ma ei tea hoopis Id kaart. Näiteks võtame niimoodi
Õpetaja: Savi ju, vaata, et Kui isik on isikkonna isikul on juhiluba või tal on Id kaart, siis Ma ei tea, kõik on okei.
Õpetaja: Üks nendest saate mõttes aru, Vaata, see ongi nagu täiesti loogiline.
Õpetaja: Jah, ei, noh, midagi Sellega
Õpetaja: ma vaatan, kas ta nagu klassikalisel kujul ka teeb. Vot no seda ma Otsisingi praegu.
Õpetaja: Meil on ee, kaks poolt. Vaata, et me vaatame. And on siin. Vahel, Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui see asi on truu ja see asi On True, et kaks tingimust mõlemad nii öelda on truud. Siis see asi rehkendub selleks, et Jah, nüüd läheme edasi,
Õpetaja: kui üks pool A on True ja B on false. Noh, aga siis on mõlemad pooled. Need peavad olema true, et oleks true Siis järelikult on False vahet poole. Kas a Ee. Vabandust, Kas B on False või? A on Falls? Kui üks nendest pooltest on False
Õpetaja: änd, eeldab seda, et mõlemad Pooled peavad olema true.
Õpetaja: Sellisel juhul see asi rehkendub truuks. Kui me jõuame pärast nagu mingi päris koodimiseni ifideni, siis see jõuab ja kui Mõlemad pooled on mõlemad pooled peavad olema truu. Nii lihtne ongi puhul. Mõlemad. Pooled peavad olema tõesed. Siis see asi rehkendub Truuks.
Õpetaja: No siin On mingid näited ka. Vaata koodinäited. Näed Vanus on ära fikseeritud kahekümnega. Kui kakskümmend on suurem või võrdne kui kaheksateist. No kas kakskümmend on Suurem või võrd? Nagu Kaheksateist on või? See on tõene
Õpetaja: ja on luba võrdub true. Siin on lihtsalt muuta, millel on otseväärtus anda. Luba On True Nii, see on. See on mingi maailma kõige lollakam. See vau, niukest asja ei tahaks. Näha
Õpetaja: Kui javasse jõuame, siis ma näitan. See on Classic. See on Classic. See on Niuke. See On Niuke. Vaata
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et. Ee, see on. See on luba ei ole mõtet, See on lihtsalt näidisvaatajad on teinud. Ei Ole ju mõtet midagi võrrelda, kui see asi ise ongi. True Wei False.
Õpetaja: Noh, katke nagu silme, Pange pöiale ette, vaata et seda üldse ei oleks.
Õpetaja: Mis on, on luba väärtus.
Õpetaja: Järelikult see pool. Kakskümmend on suurem kui kaheksateist on truu Ja on luba on truu. Seega
Õpetaja: kogu see asi on true. Me Kunagi ei võrdle Ee, niiöelda sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: see asi rehkendub, kui kui See on true. Kui on true, siis on true. Kui see on False, on see False. Vaata, nagu, et seda ei ole mõtet võrrelda, Teen seda ise, siis. Ee. Hiljem.
Õpetaja: Kolm Jaavascripto on. See Pange tähele lett.
Õpetaja: Jah, kui jõuame siis kui mulle on näidatud. Ma tegelikult olen alati alati tahtnud teha väikest viktoriini Ise teilt küsida. Aga siis Hea küll, ma siis praegult küsin. Vaata, mis see Miks on Kolm võrdusmärki. Ma võin ütlen ka, et saab ka kaks olla
Õpetaja: Ja aga ühe ühe võrdusmärgiga omistatakse. Jaavas on ju kaks võrdusmärki. Kui võrdled omavahel pooli, Aga miks Javascriptis kolm on?
Õpetaja: Teaduskriptis saab ka kaks olla. Jaoscriptis saab olla kaks Vega võrdus märki, kui võrdled kahte poolt omavahel
Õpetaja: Davai, ma Teen selle kiirelt ise. Ära vaata, oota, ma midagi. Röövin siit. Ma ei viitsi seda kirjutada. Hops,
Õpetaja: on sul see gaas?
Õpetaja: Aa, hops, vana Hea Not. Bad lahti, siuke. Ee, mis ta Niukene Oranz on?
Õpetaja: Tahaks lihtsalt teksti. Mis teema on? Aa, äkki language. On mingi Jason või midagi taolist Ju Vot nii mõistlikum
Õpetaja: ee. Vaadake, mõte, on see et, ee Teeme, hoopis siin lihtsamalt vaata. Et, siin on a Siin. On B.
Õpetaja: Nii Ei, ma panen siia praegult Aa
Õpetaja: Kümme, näiteks, ja. Ütleme et, kui
Õpetaja: a On suurem või võrdnev kui, b
Õpetaja: Nii. See oleks praegu tavaline võrdlus. Niiöelda üks on suurem kui teine onju Teeme natuke teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Kustutan selle üldse ära. See ei ole praegult Andy and I Niiöelda
Õpetaja: nii jaavas oleks võrdlemine niimoodi. Kas kakskümmend ja kümme on võrdsed
Õpetaja: ei? Ole Võrdsed aga, tekitame sellise olukorra et, nad on võrdsed kas. Praegult oleks see, kas kümme võrdub kümme
Õpetaja: true Nii Aga Nüüd on selline küsimus et aga, mis. Siis kui mis, seepärat tähendab
Õpetaja: ta on Texton String, nüüd Javascript. Vana hea läbu ja org ja kõike võib siin teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on niimoodi, et ee, see asi ei läheks Kuidagi katki.
Õpetaja: Jaavas Kompilaator läks. No go.
Õpetaja: Sa ei saa võrrelda kahte erinevat tüüpi omavahel.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Jaovascript on see, et ta siis ma ei Mäleta kumba pidi ta teisendab? Vaata, et ta siis üritab niimoodi teha. Vaata, et Davai, et need on erinevat tüüpi. Ma näen, et need on erinevat tüüpi. Noh, ütleme kood jooksutamise ajal. Interpreteerija näeb seda. Vaata siis ta teeb, et ta üritab seda siis taustal teha võrdseks, nagu, et
Õpetaja: ta teeb kas niimoodi või siis ta taustal teeb ka enda Kas niimoodi, vaata onju Selles võrdluse kohas võrdsustab nad niiöelda teeb Ühe tüübiliseks. Noh, see võrduks praegult true. Vaata, kui juhul kui ta teeb Ee niiöelda Stringi teeb kümnest kümnest siis ta oleks endiselt true
Õpetaja: sellepärast Et ta saab teisendada neid.
Õpetaja: Kui
Õpetaja: sa paned selle kolmanda niiöelda võrdusmärgi juurde, jäävas kriitis. Nüüd siis see võrdlus on tüübikindel. See tähendab, et Ta vaatab seda, et kas mõlemal pool on
Õpetaja: võrdväärsed Väärtused ja tüübid?
Õpetaja: No kas nüüd on mõlemal pool võrdsed?
Õpetaja: Ei ole enam ja see on? Kuidas peaks muidugi loomulikult progema.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see ee variant võiks tekitada igasuguseid anomaaliid ja pugisid,
Õpetaja: et mis, sest et ei ole nagu Selles mõttes tüüpe ei ole. Aga vähemalt kui me võrdleme asju siis me tahame öelda talle, et. Kuule, võrdle ikka niimoodi, et, noh,
Õpetaja: saad seda enam. Vaata, et jaavas. Sa saad ju muutuvasse. Saab tulla. Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Et siis ta vähemalt selles mõttes siis ongi see. Vaata, et Sa tahadki nagu vältida seda, et juhul kui sinna satub. Tegelikult mingisugune nagu teistsugune tüüp, et nad ei ole erinevat tüüpi,
Õpetaja: no sa saad suht kiirelt seda teada Vaata, et sa nagu enda arvates su kood peaks nagu producima siin. True. Vaata, onju? Aga mingil põhjusel sa hakkad Vaatama. See on juhtunud seda, et sa kogemata võrdledki. Võibolla sa oma peas võrdledki numbreid.
Õpetaja: Ühe. Sa said süsteemist, kus tuli numbrina teise, sa Saad näiteks input. Boxis, mis ma olen rääkinud? Input Boxis. Vaata, sa võid panna neid tüüpe Text number email Date Whatever taustal, Tegelikult võetakse Ikkagi, String,
Õpetaja: et kui keegi saab kuskile kirjutada oma vanuse kümme
Õpetaja: sinna boksei ja teine asi on programmeeritud väärtus kümme siis ongi, see et Kui sa selle kahe ee võrdlusmärgiga teeksid, siis ta võrduks truu. Vaata aga, tegelikult sa oled vea teinud. Sa pead igal juhul, kui sa Võtad sealt boksist mingisuguse asja? Kui mis on tegelikult number on String Sa pead ta siis programmis tegema Ka numbriks
Õpetaja: et ta, päriselt oleks võrreldav. Siin on omavahel võrdlemine, Aga meil on suurem, väiksem ja nii edasi Vaata ka igasugused asjad.
Õpetaja: Et Ee, selline lähenemine on vot nii Ee
Õpetaja: ahaa. Kas keegi vaatas ka või jõudis vaadata ka neid?
Õpetaja: Aa, podcast asju. Mitte podcaste. Kas kohe ka neid videosid
Õpetaja: ma täiega soovitan vaadata. Ma siis ise vaatasin. Jah, okei, see esimesel. Me valisime seda, et ta võib teha mingi väga nunnu video. Vaata, on ju tegigi Noh, see üks alumistest või kus, Mis iganes, millega ma iganes proovisime.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult oli päris head kokkuvõtvad videod. Ma siis hommikul korra nagu rongis kiirkorras. Vaatasin neid videosid. No podcastid olid ka isegi. No, nad on pikemad. Siin jäpivad rohkem. Et Võibolla, ee, Niukene asi, et kui sa Eelmine päev midagi õppisid, onju? Ja nüüd see video on nagu saadaval. See on kümne minutilised videod vaadake. Vaadake. Need ära
Õpetaja: ee. Jumal Ilusti, käib üle, toob seal mõned paremaid näiteid ka. Näiteks ma ühe näite. Juba Varastan sealt. Ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal, kus ta rääkis Ee, seda, et Mis asi on jaava klass? Vaata ja ta üritas seda rääkida, et see on nagu mall, aga siis tuua mingisugune analoogia näide. Vaata, ta tõi Jumalast hea analoogia näide. Ta tõi piparkoogivormi Niuke, Tähekujuline piparkoogi vorm.
Õpetaja: Et Ee klass on nagu parem, Nagu et milline see on, milline ta välja nagu näeb.
Õpetaja: Ja selle sama selle sama niiöelda selle malliga siis võib teha nii palju piparkooke, kui tahad, Nad on kõik tegelikult Siis kandja nägu. Need. Noh, sarnased. Vähemalt vormilt on nad samased Samasuguse sisuga. Aga võibolla natuke erinevad ühele paned peale
Õpetaja: Springeldad mingisuguseid kookoshelbeid teisele Paned glasuuri? Vaata, et noh. Andmete mõttes on Sisu on erinev, aga ta on endiselt ee, tähekujuline. Tähekesekujuline. Niiöelda piparkook on ju,
Õpetaja: et ta Esimesel podcastel.
Õpetaja: Hetkel.
Õpetaja: Jah, vaikos.
Õpetaja: Võibolla nad midagi mälestavad seal või midagi. Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Let s take a moment. Nagu
Õpetaja: vaatasin, et ta kirjutas nüüd mingi üheksa. Kümme Minutised olid põhimõtteliselt Need podcast ei. Podcastid, olid pikemad mingi Kakskümmend Min see. Vist oli vä
Õpetaja: jah. Eks, noh. See on see, aga aga selles mõttes tõesti. Ma nagu nägin, et seal on väärtus, et ma ise nagu tajun, et need on kõik Need teemad. Vaata, mida me konkreetsel päeval läbi käisime ja tegime, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on teinud mingid illustratsioonid asjad ja päris selles mõttes, ega ta Ei, pane üks ühele. Vaata, mis Näiteks isegi seal. Mina olen rääkinud või mis? Seal Chat I dokumendis on? Vaata, mis ta pani terve päeva peale kokku, vaid seal. Ta paneb ise ka juurde.
Õpetaja: Ta paneb ise ka juurde. Nagu mingisuguseid näiteid ja mõtteid Asju, et ee, päris Hea on,
Õpetaja: ee. Soovitan vaadata. Kahjuks ma ei saanud nüüd rohkem Trade. Sellepärast, et ee, näete. Siuke piirang on peal et kolm tükki saad Nagu teha ööpäeva jooksul, et sain siis kolm videot Trade ja kolm seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, podcast I. Ja nüüd on siin aeg. Näed hours a Go, ehk siis, ee. Muidugi. Keegi teine saaks võtta selle kõige viimase.
Õpetaja: Ee, no okei, me tegeleme sellega ka mingi hetk, et hakkate ka natukene siin panustama,
Õpetaja: et see trans. See viimase video niiöelda kokkuvõte on olemas.
Õpetaja: Sellest oleks vaja lihtsalt notebook lem I panna ja siis öelda, et tee sellest podcast hea video. Ee, kuidas ma tegin siis selle, et see oleks nagu hästi lihtne lahendus on see, ma tegin siis Lihtsalt, Ee, ühe kausta
Õpetaja: meie Google Drive tegin. Kuhu ma saan siis ka ligipääsu anda? Kus need videod lihtsalt videod ja podcastid elavad. Need on need samad, mis on siin lingitud?
Õpetaja: Ee, neid saab telefonis ka. Avada
Õpetaja: sõid ta koju mingi ühistranspordiga. Noh, pange vaikselt käima, või klapid pähe ja
Õpetaja: kuulake. Vaadake, ma pigem vaataks enne seda videot, onju? Kuidas seda, nagu. Kuidas mina teeksin seda, kui ma oleks ee, kui juhul, Kui on juba olemas. Ja ma pole veel neid materjale videos, nagu päris asju vaadanud, onju? Sellest Päevast ma teekski niimoodi, et ma vaataks Kõigepealt lihtsalt selle video ära. Overview video
Õpetaja: ja siis. Ja siis teeksin nagu Deep Divi niiöelda siia, et okei, et Ee, video rääkis nüüd Ühte asja vaataks Nüüd natukene nagu koodinäiteid ja asju ka. Vaata, onju, et. Noh, mis iganes siin on
Õpetaja: et, ee, päris hä, päris hästi käib. Ee, mingisuguse pildi annab ette, Nii et.
Õpetaja: Ee, minge vaadake. No, ma panin siis need sisuteemad ka siia, et see on see sama Sisukord. Mis on siis selles? Ee, selles ee failis.
Õpetaja: Mis ee, see tegi, et see sama sisukord on põhimõtteliselt siin. Niimoodi Copy paste, et sellest. Ee,
Õpetaja: suht kiirelt. Saad pildi ette, et. Noh, kui sa otsid mingit teemat mis sind huvitab,
Õpetaja: siis sa leiad nad siit ülesse.
Õpetaja: Vaata videosid. Vaata podcast. E, Vaata päris videot. Meie, nagu see minu niiöelda. Ee, Zoomi. Niiöelda Recording, onju? Tal on kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: Saan siia ühe asja veel ruttu juurde panna. Kui ma siin juba olen. Selle video kaks sisukord selle saab Copy Based Ida Ups,
Õpetaja: panna selle siia
Õpetaja: üks video veel olemas. Oleks vaja siia ka neid asju Okei,
Õpetaja: aga lähme siis tänase päeva asjadega edasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Aa, millest võiks alustada, et saaksime Alustada võimalikult. Lihtsalt. Ma teeks niimoodi, et kui teil on mingisugused Ee, harud, enda nimelised, harud
Õpetaja: Ee, Eriti kui see on ee, lihtsalt ilma Igasugu igasuguse taaskinumbrita. Asjadeta. Kustutage see ära. Alustame puhtalt. Võtke õpetaja pealt üks uus haru.
Õpetaja: Ja Tehke sellest Lihtsalt omanimeline haru. Aga ärge pange sinna mingeid vee, ühte ega midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui kellegil on praegult mingisugune omanimeline haru? Aga see on Jumal teab, mis seisus kustutage see lihtsalt ära ja võtke uus
Õpetaja: täiesti puhtalt.
Õpetaja: No,
Õpetaja: lokali pealt saab ära. Jah,
Õpetaja: sest et sa oled selle ka Checkout I teinud vaata ja lokali Tasub see ära kasutada, Tekitab ainult segadust.
Õpetaja: Ei, need sebagaimeline haarus. Sellepärast, et see on teie, et, ee, aga lihtsalt ma, kui teil on Mingist varasemast ajast.
Õpetaja: Ee, teil mingi varasemast ajast näiteks. Ma näen siin Andrus Vaata, onju, et et kui see on mingi ammu tehtud ja Nii edasi. Ma korra kustutaks selle lihtsalt ära ja võtaks puhtalt ühe õpetaja ja pannakse uuesti andrus. Ja ongi kõik
Õpetaja: grupi peal. Noh, kuidas
Õpetaja: Remoodi pealt. Kustutage ära lokalist samamoodi. Minge korraks üldse nagu päris Masteri peale. Tehke niimoodi. Tehke checkout, masteri peal
Õpetaja: ja põhimõtteliselt nüüd Kui teil On nagu mingi haru, mis on lihtsalt teie nimi.
Õpetaja: Siis kustutage see ära. Nii lokalist kui ka remoudist.
Õpetaja: Noh, te ei saa istuda selle haru peal. Mida te tahate kustutada?
Õpetaja: See oli ka seal videos. Kenasti olemas Oligi mingi vend seal puu otsas aega.
Õpetaja: Nii, noh, enda juurde
Õpetaja: Sul on, ee. Sul on praegu selline asi. Vaata, sa üritad minna ühe haruga teise auru peale, aga sul on mingisugused lahtised muudatused. Sellepärast peaks küsima. Vaata, et kuule, et mis saab sellest anda? Laseme selle lihtsalt niimoodi sajana ära.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sa enam ei küsi, kui minna, Näiteks selle peale checkout,
Õpetaja: mis me nüüd teeme? Nagu nende lahtiste muudatustega. Vaata, tal on nagu selle
Õpetaja: siit, siis. Ee, aga sul tegelikult sellest võib ka ära kustutada. Sul ei ole vaja nagu seda enda.
Õpetaja: Jah, väga hea, sest igal juhul siis mis iganes, kas sa siin sul Ei ole, Vot sul on nagu tava sul ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ja ma vaatan korra Kas siin. Lihtsalt siin ei ole,
Õpetaja: nii Okei, siis on Niimoodi, et nüüd, ee, teed Kõigepealt ka sorry ennem kui te võtate õpetaja pealt teete.
Õpetaja: Ma olen vahepeal komited ja push ind midagi
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd, ee. Lihtsalt võtame siin õpetaja ringlusele saate. Aga peamine. Aga peamine on see. Vaata, et sa praegu saaksid võtta,
Õpetaja: et sul ei oleks Just selline, kus ei ole mingit veed ega midagi. Vaata, me hakkame mängima ja siis ma sõin oma maska ja
Õpetaja: ei ole siin enam ei ole, siis ongi lihtsalt. Ee, siit selle õpetaja pealt uue ja panen lihtsalt selleks. Raine, vaata, kui ma tahaks kõik selle korraga ära,
Õpetaja: Isegi kui oleks mingi võimaldaks mitut tükki korraga kustutada, et ta teeb taustal ikka ühe kaupa.
Õpetaja: Nii, No mina võin ka. Läbi. Noh, mina Õpetajat ei taha nüüd ee ära kustutada, Aga mõte oli see, et siis Remote I alt tuleb, Te võtate, teete checkout? Mitte checkout I, Vaid New Branchey.
Õpetaja: Panete oma nime Nii, nüüd. Aa. Nüüd. Kus see on tehtud, siis. Ee. Võtame ette. Järgmise arendustaski.
Õpetaja: Ee, frontend. Is on Ee, maailma kõige lihtsam arendus üldse. Aga see on nagu ongi meelega Step by step. Näe, üks on Done Koduvaade on muudetud. Veb viis on järgmine.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ei õpetajast, aga. Aga sellest remoodi alt. Ja enne seda. Fedge,
Õpetaja: te võite Push Ida ka. Vaata aga peaasi, et te Panete. Lõppeesmärk on see, et teil on täiesti värske haru, mis on võetud minu selle õpetaja pealt ja see on lihtsalt omanimeline ja me Mängime, et see on nüüd Minul on see neli jäänud. Tegelikult Fm. Neli kuulub mulutamiseks. Miks
Õpetaja: see arendus on tehtud? Juba onju, Ma eile Rääkisin sellest, aga ise ei teinud. Kustutan selle ära, et seda pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga me möltsisimegi juba ära ja mina mörtsisin neile ära.
Õpetaja: Ei, Ma ütlesin seda. Toome. Teeme korralikult uuesti kogu protsessi. Ei, ee, praegult te praegult te olete. Kui Te tulete nüüd vaatate enda haru, siis Ta on täpselt sama nagu minul. Ee, mi milles saab nagu veenduda, on see, et kui teete selle tokskausta lahti
Õpetaja: ja vaatad ee, teoori materials. Vabandust, ee. Siis on teil neil nelja video kohta? Materjalid on nii? Teie enda nimelises arvus
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siis põhimõtteliselt see Näitabki seda, et te olete üks ühele minuga samas seisus. Ja nüüd täna saame mängida täiesti puhtalt
Õpetaja: seda, mis on vaja teha
Õpetaja: nii ja Mis meil on vaja teha on see, et meil potsatas dashboard I niiöelda uus task, mida on vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, veebis. Ee, mis siin Räägitakse Description i all. Vaatame ee, loo error lehekülje. Vaade.
Õpetaja: Mis reageerib siis kaldkriips errorile. Loo uus vaatekomponent Error viu aadressil Kaldkriips error Lisa juurde tekst. Midagi läheks valesti. Võib panna mingi uks. Läheks midagi juurde valesti. Lisa juurde. Mingi Gif test. Error vaadet minnes Error aadressile.
Õpetaja: Et See on nüüd selline vaade. See on selline vaade. Mida saab siis mistahes hetkel kasutajale näidata, kui uks midagi läheks. Valesti
Õpetaja: Ee, meil on niukest asja vaja teha. Noh, millest alustame? No kujutame ette. No, ma panen selle Sign to me, et see on niiöelda minu, teha, võtsin selle töösse muudan staatuse in progress.
Õpetaja: Siis tähendab seda, et nüüd hakkan seda arendama.
Õpetaja: Mis on esimene samm? Ee, meil siin projekti juures
Õpetaja: no Frontend käima. Seda võiks teha. Okei, minul ta juba käib.
Õpetaja: Ei Mis asjad?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: jah, vot bingo, Et me ei saa ju see on Praeg praegult Meil naeratab ees nagu Master. Põhimõtteliselt. Ja see on see Master, mis ei saa arendada. Master on meie kõigi nendest saab võtta, Harusid.
Õpetaja: Seda me teemegi.
Õpetaja: Mm, ja põmm.
Õpetaja: Ja põmm.
Õpetaja: No teie tegite seda oma haarustanud, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, te mängite, et ma võtan en võtan Master Ist uue haru panen talle taski. Kui päris elus olekski. Selle task I haru selline, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga me ei saa lihtsalt teha kakskümmend korda. Nagu kõik. Meil peab olema siis natuke pikemalt. See
Õpetaja: päriselus oleks Lihtsalt veb viis.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kus aru on olemas,
Õpetaja: Kus haru on olemas? Ee, siis hakkame vaatama, et on vaja luua uus vaatekomponent Error View.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on põhimõtteliselt see mis Fred ütles, aga võib keegi veel öelda, et mis me nüüd siis teeme?
Õpetaja: Uut vaadet on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ei, no tegime uue haaru.
Õpetaja: Midagi ei ole veel, kui Mitt Ida oled teinud tööd.
Õpetaja: No siis pole vist midagi kommit. Ida ka veel. Ja push Ida Aa Küll saab Push Ida Haru mille just tegime. Kas Teil kõigil on nagu oma nimi Faebois.
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti, kellel ei ole.
Õpetaja: Tere oma omanimelisest haarust.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: sest et me peame nagu kuidagi nagu simuleerima seda, Vaata, et te teete arendusmasteris. Aga me lihtsalt kõike ei saa teha. Me ei saa, me ei saa nagu mängida,
Õpetaja: Me ei saa lõpus lihtsalt seda mängida, et Okei, Mina mörsin oma tehtud töö Masterisse oma töö Masterisse. See on kõik. Sama töö Kõik Esiteks on ju, et me ei saa kõik teha Masterisse. Me peame lihtsalt nagu, ee, mängima nii öelda, et, ee, et teie enda nimi on Master Ja teine haru on lihtsalt arendusharu. Feb viis. Niimoodi. Kujutage ette
Õpetaja: muud midagi.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siis öeldakse et loo uus vaatekomponent Terror View aadressil Error,
Õpetaja: mis me teeme? Aidake mind. Mina esimest päeva arendust Teen, mis ma vajutan, kuhu ma lähen. Mida ma teen,
Õpetaja: vara
Õpetaja: vara sest et Ruuter eeldab seda, et sa viitad seal siis mingisugusele faili komponendile, onju? Aga meil pole veel seda.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin oli vihje, mis me tegema Peame
Õpetaja: Uue komponendi. On ju? Uue View, et siin on nagu seda, et igasugused taaskasutatavad komponendid ja asjad. Me hoiame siin kaustas aga vaated, Mis reageerivad niiöelda urridele. Peaksid olema ainult siin kaustas. Ja kui neid vaateid oleks väga palju, No siis tasuks teha mingit alamkaustu, vaata proovida grupeerida. Kas temaatiliselt või mis iganes
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, mingi admimmi vaated ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, ma korra vaataks enne seda, kui Me teeme uue vaate Vaataks. Korra selle homeview üle. Vaata, tuletame natukene meelde.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis meil on, et meil siis saab olema kaks osa, onju? Meil saab olema template osa ja meil saab olema Script osa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see skript osa praegult tegelikult ei ole päris õige. Ta peaks olema natukene teistsugune. Seal Scripti sees.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle Home View natukene korda. Otsige see home. Või? Noh Otsige Tehke see home view lahti. Selle Template. Te võite siit alt kinni panna, kui see niimoodi silma riivab, See on ka asi. Kasutage sellist võimalust. Teil on mingisugused. Teil Hakkab tekkima palju koodi. Kui nad on niiöelda skoobiga elemendid, siis on võimalik neid niimoodi kokku tõmmata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Saab lausa niimoodi teha, et ee, Parem klõps, näiteks. Ee, on. Tee kõik lahti.
Õpetaja: Teine variant oleks. Ee. Ja,
Õpetaja: noh, näiteks nii. Meid huvitab siia. Me tahame tulla siia skripti sisse Ja me tahame kirjutada siia natukene asju. Nüüd need asjad, mis me kirjutame. Need on nüüd voe asjad.
Õpetaja: Need on voe asjad. Need on seal raamistiku värgid. See me tahame kirjutada niukse lause nagu eksport.
Õpetaja: Default paar tähte ja tab. Ärge kirjutage kõike välja. Ta juba pakub Ee, Paari tähega pole mõtet.
Õpetaja: Eksport Default. Ja nüüd tuleb Skoop. Pakkuge. Kuidas saab Skoopi enamus programmides Ee, niiöelda Defineerida Noh, sümbolitest räägime,
Õpetaja: kuidas? Saab ulatust.
Õpetaja: Loogilised sulud täpselt tulevad loogilised sulud, Loogilised sulud. Ja siin on nüüd mingid voeseadistused ja asjad. Need lähevad siia. Hiljem tulevad Script, Id ja värgid ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin Nüüd käivad. Ee, selles mõttes Property D või propsid? Kuidas iganes neid kutsuda. Ee, me kirjutame siia niukse asja. Nagu Name. Näete, B täht on siin.
Õpetaja: Props
Õpetaja: Name Call on. Ja see nüüd on see, et me tahame voel öelda, et. Hei, siin. Ee. Homeviews on Niukene komponent nagu Home View Ma korra piilun ühte asja. Ee, ma korra kustutan selle ära. Korra, Hästi, Korraks piilun Ee, ruuterist ühte asja. Kas ma näen midagi?
Õpetaja: Ahah, okei. Ei olnud päris nii nagu ma lootsin, aga, okei, ee, et see nimi. Põhimõtteliselt, siis annab sellele raamistikule märku, et siin on selline komponent, nime ka
Õpetaja: ja idee. On isegi see, et siin võiks anda nüüd Mingisuguse muu nime, kui see Home View kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: Aga me loomulikult lihtsalt tahame öelda. Pange need üksikkülakamad.
Õpetaja: Täpselt sama nimi nagu samamoodi, nagu See faili nimi.
Õpetaja: Aga ilma selle laiendita punkt. Oe,
Õpetaja: see oleks viisakas. See peab olema tegelikult, ee, igas voe komponendis.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast et kui me Hakkame pärast selle erinevaid asju erinevast kohast välja kutsuma ja kasutama. Siis nad vajavad seda
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: Davai. Selle vana asja tegime veits korda. Nüüd oleks aeg teha üks uus vaade,
Õpetaja: mida ma vajutan. Mida ma teen?
Õpetaja: Parem klõps, Parem klõps. Kus vihus kausta peal.
Õpetaja: Mis siit?
Õpetaja: Mm, New
Õpetaja: nüüd korra. Teie jääge siia seisma. Vaata, ma korra pulli pärast. Proovin ruttu suvaliselt ära. Kuidas ta. Teeb Composition api
Õpetaja: Ee. Okei, niimoodi Seda ma arvasin. Teen selle ära kohe. Ma vaatan üle.
Õpetaja: Võiks teha ühe asja natukene rohkem minu maitse järgi. Ee, ja kui ma valin Cbi.
Õpetaja: No näed, Option Capi on täpselt selline, mida me soovime. Scripto on üleval. Ma kustutan selle ära. See oli ainult proovimiseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, see Lihtsalt on nagu Ee. Programmeerimise lähenemisviis, mis on toetatud voe voes. Alates voe kolmest tuli üks uus lähenemine juurde, aga me seda ei kasuta seda kindlasti kohe.
Õpetaja: Ee, kasutame seda natukene lihtsamat lähenemist
Õpetaja: valik. Ja ühe korra peate valima. Järgmine kord ta jätab selle nagu meelde, nagu peamise Valikuna Nüüd siia. On vaja nimi panna Taask Lausa ütleb meile ette. Päris taaskis. Ee, eriti ei näe mingeid faili Nimesid ette Öeldakse on ju, et päris taaskis Öeldakse, et error vaade sellise disainiga. Vaata, et see on nagu arendaja. Enda nagu pärusmaa et kuidas ta asja nimetab Ja teeb.
Õpetaja: Kui just ei ole. Nagu siis mingi. Võibolla mingi väiksemas tiimis. Võib ka olla niimoodi, et on juba varasemalt kokku lepitud ja Nii edasi, teie. Kuidas teie oma projekte tiimiprojekte? Teete te juba kohe alguses. Otsustate juba planeerimisfaasis Ära vaata, et kuidas te ühte ja teist vaadata faili nimega, nagu hakkate nimetama.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on. See on ka see nagu hea. Seal on ka see. Hea asi on see, et Te olete selles mõttes ikkagi täiesti igasugused algajad, Et ee, et kui te hakkaksite nagu väga, palju,
Õpetaja: ee niiöelda, siis ee, arenduse käigus neid asju otsustama. Individuaalselt igaüks meeskonnas. Siis teie käekiri. Võibolla läheb ka kuidagi väga lappesse. Ma olen näinud seda küll ja küll, sest et tavaliselt Keegi Ei ole päris täpselt nii teinud, nagu ma olen tahtnud. Nüüd
Õpetaja: tee kursusega. Te kindlasti teete. Ma annan teile need võimalused ja vahendid kõik kätte ja näited. Ja nii edasi, et. Ee, siis on palju parem kui me vaatame niiöelda seda, kui te vaatate oma seda
Õpetaja: mokk Veebi mok veebilehte Kui teil on seal kõik faili nimed juba olemas, siis te saate juba seal nagu ülikergelt ühtlustada, enne kui üldse progemiseks läheb, et. Noh, nimetasime seda niimoodi niimoodi. Tegelikult see on nagu, väga mõnus
Õpetaja: Error View peaks tulema. Niukene, asi küsib, et kas tahad Kit I lisada. Jah, soovime küll.
Õpetaja: Templeid Nutab. Tema sees pole praegult ühtegi. Ee, alamelementi. Siis Lihtsalt praegu tajutaselt. Paneme siia lihtsalt ühe Tv. I
Õpetaja: Ta lihtsalt praat ei nutaks. Selle style komponendi koristame ära. Me hoia. Kui me teeme mingit, siia, saaks diili panna. Cs sätteid saaks panna, mis on seotud ainult selle komponendiga. Aga me pigem ei meeldigi. Niuke lähenemine. Me lihtsalt teeme eraldi Css faili ja paneme kõik asjad ühte kohta. Vaata elama onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, see see on. See on muidu hea asi, et näiteks kui sul on mingid väga erilised komponendid, et sa Tahad ainult seal mingit kindlat stiili hoida? Mitte kuskil mujal. See on Niukene. Võimalus Ee, siin selleks loodud, et saad siin stiili ka ee Niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Okei, see on meil olemas.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd järgmine asi on siis see, et ee lisa juurde siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, Niukene. Ahaa, teeme selle reaktiivsuse ära. Pigem Praegult võib siia korra panna lihtsalt mingi. Tere või mida iganes, et ta lihtsalt midagi ei oleks näha, kui peaks ette ilmuma, Teeme nüüd selle osa ära. Mis priin või? Kes See pakkus siin, et mida on vaja järgmisena teha? Ma ei mäletagi. Enam
Õpetaja: Teeme Ruudi ära. On ju, et meil on siis source kataloogi all router indeksfile,
Õpetaja: kus on kõik niiöelda teekonnad ja komponendid ära defineeritud. Siin siis niukene Lihtlabane trikk, et võtame selle ühe objekti, mis on varem varasemalt ära tehtud. Aga koos reavahetusega näiteks nii
Õpetaja: paned kontroll. T siis tuleb täpselt Koos reavahetusega tuleb üks niuke plöörakas juurde.
Õpetaja: Vaata, lihtsalt võtate Niimoodi Teete siniseks. Siin on nagu jälle teie sõber. Järsku onju. Nüüd on mõnus teha. Control D, Tublike
Õpetaja: või Control Copy ja Control V lisaks ka,
Õpetaja: Aga parem ei tee niimoodi, et siin niimoodi ei töötaks. Control D, tublid.
Õpetaja: Hakkame siis muutma. No mis me siia kirjutame?
Õpetaja: Taask ütleb seda meile ette. On ju nüüd selline asi. Selles mõttes oleks garanteeritult. Ee, Defineeritud ette taaskes.
Õpetaja: Ee, sest see on kokkulepe.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, nüüd Sellel sellel ruudil võiks olla oma nimi. Võiks Ta olla siis ta.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: et seal oli kohe esimeses taaskis. Oli öeldud, et meil on Niuke konventsioon. Sellepärast, et enne ta vaikimisi oli tegelikult üldse niimoodi
Õpetaja: home, aga Ei, home, ruttu. Ee, nüüd Siin see komponent. Selle me kustutame siit ära siis oma võiks jätta,
Õpetaja: nüüd et saaks väga lihtsalt tekitada sellise asja, et tekiks siia import ja kõik muud asjad ka. Me peame nüüd päeva lõpuks kirjutama. Siia Error View, Vaata, onju? Aga mida me Ei, tohi teha on. Ma näitan korra. Vaadake, lihtsalt vaadake. Rida. Rida, kolme, onju? Mina kirjutan error
Õpetaja: viu.
Õpetaja: Kas ülesse tuli midagi?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ei tulnud. Mitte midagi oli see, et, ee. Ma ise kirjutasin selle niiöelda täht tähelt välja.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma teen seda niimoodi, et ma hakkan seda kirjutama, et häbiga valin, Et mida ma mõtlen,
Õpetaja: Error View. No suhte tähtis üldse. Ev. Näiteks on kõige lihtsam. Nüüd Otsin siit ülesse selle Error View.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma panen, tab I. Nüüd vaadake siis seda rida. Tuliimport.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta teab, millest sa räägid, see eelmine, kui seda siin ei ole, siis tal on. Millest sa mees jääbid
Õpetaja: Saab hiljem ka muidugi impordi. Panna. Ta saab aru, et sa kuuled sulle, Unustad importi? Ee, ülesse selle tooks
Õpetaja: Kollane pirnikene.
Õpetaja: Aga räägime pirnidest ka.
Õpetaja: Ma korra kustutasin selle meelega ära.
Õpetaja: No see lausa punane on
Õpetaja: ee. Ta ei taha praegu pirni siia tuua, aga tegelikult tal on siin punane olukord
Õpetaja: ja ta pakub ise nagu siin, et, ee, hiljem näitan Pirnivärki uuesti Ee, pigem nagu. Harjutage enda sisse see harjumus. Ärge trükkige neid sõnu lõpuni.
Õpetaja: Kogu selle tööriista mõte ongi see, et Aitab meil lihtsamini kiiremini koodi kirjutada, et, ee. Jah,
Õpetaja: ei leia sul seda soovitust Kas sa panid suurte tähtedega?
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra, kas ee teistesse ka
Õpetaja: Aitame Nüüd aga natukene spaaride ajale veel
Õpetaja: ja,
Õpetaja: mm, ee, millega?
Õpetaja: Mul on nii kaasa täpselt selline tunne, nagu eelmine kord nagu samamoodi teed, on,
Õpetaja: Ahah, ee tugineb. See süüa vahelt on olemas.
Õpetaja: Esialgu
Õpetaja: ma nagu. Ma ei näe nagu ühtegi põhjust. Vaata, miks sa ei peaks näitama, et Sul on. Komponent. On korrektselt ära vormistatud. Midagi katsi pole.
Õpetaja: Ma teeksin praegu lihtsalt. Ee.
Õpetaja: Täiesti Tavaline tarbija muutub valitsus
Õpetaja: Jah, peale vaadates nagu ei ole üldse põhjust, mis?
Õpetaja: See on, nagu selge, on see, et oleme nii teil sees.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: Valge on. Jah, aga aga vot see on Ootamine.
Õpetaja: Saame. Aru Vaata, ei saa üldse nagu midagi.
Õpetaja: Töötavad. Sul on ju
Õpetaja: hästi korras. Sinu küsida ei ole.
Õpetaja: Mhm,
Õpetaja: jah.
Õpetaja: Mis on veel käjutunud.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: mhm
Õpetaja: aga Noh, aga ta võib olla. Praegu. Sellepärast
Õpetaja: valid siis ta ülesse. Import ei tekita, mis oli kuidagi täitnud kolmas asi oli.
Õpetaja: Sõltub täiesti sõltumata. See meie arvuti. Veidi tehtud. Nagu Et miks? Ka? Nagu sa olema loobuda.
Õpetaja: Nii, proovime. Proovime ära Starti
Õpetaja: väinar Kuidas sul on? Kas sul samamoodi Tule ja mulle. Ma tegin. Jah, aga aga ei, sama lugu.
Õpetaja: Kas sul oli meie arvut Jah, naine, Ee, teie nii.
Õpetaja: Aga Noh, sama et seal pakub süda
Õpetaja: ja komponent väga üldse olnud
Õpetaja: nagu on öelnud.
Õpetaja: Aa, täiesti.
Õpetaja: Tere,
Õpetaja: Ma valmis Vahetan ette, et ei tule. Noh,
Õpetaja: jah,
Õpetaja: vot see kauplemine.
Õpetaja: Aa, aa, on ju, et selles mõttes. Ee, Davai, Proovime Ee, ee, jah, Okei, ee, Ma tahan korra
Õpetaja: korra. Tõstetan selle.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, teeme siis teeme. Siis saame alati kolm korda.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtta selle tausta ära.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ta, valis. Aa, mitte
Õpetaja: kohe. Ma üritan saata, Selge, väga hästi, mina.
Õpetaja: Tsau, Okei, hallo.
Õpetaja: Nii, proovime
Õpetaja: asi mida võtta. Proovida tõesti, No
Õpetaja: jah, õnnistama.
Õpetaja: Issand, Jah,
Õpetaja: osta tegelikult mingisuguse terminalis. Ee, uuesti ülesse selle ära.
Õpetaja: Kuidas, ee, Kolm tundi. Projekt tundub? Täi. See on täielikult Tundub modellisel teema. Vaata, Noh, midagi seda nurga alt
Õpetaja: ja ta näitab seda. Logo oli sealt nagu see.
Õpetaja: Ee, uue logo oli mulle mootoritööda. Logo oli üpris palju Mm, kohas
Õpetaja: jah
Õpetaja: vigu vahendada
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: ei tea.
Õpetaja: Lanter räägitud.
Õpetaja: Kas see probleem üldse nagu läks ära vaadata Nagu teised mured ka nagu,
Õpetaja: palun, Ee, vaatan,
Õpetaja: pakud, aga oota.
Õpetaja: Aga see infot oli enne olemas. Vaata, ma korra võtan selle ära Ongi juurde, et siis nagu,
Õpetaja: okei, valdavõtte Ükski võitma
Õpetaja: leidnud ülesse, onju? Ma juba kaldan arvama. Vaata, et ee. Midagi mulle sinna, kui ei taba. Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: Ikkagi selle valesti
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt Omal ajal, nagu,
Õpetaja: et, noh, sinu küsimus vaatavad, mis? Nagu see sobib. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: See ei sobi
Õpetaja: nii jah, uuesti.
Õpetaja: Kas olen rohkem kasvanud ettevõtud.
Õpetaja: Tundub, et ee.
Õpetaja: Uurime. Tule, onju?
Õpetaja: Vähemalt saame konkreet. Jah, Davai.
Õpetaja: No vot, Kas ee. See, mis teha
Õpetaja: võib olla võib olla, ei tea,
Õpetaja: Siis kui tahad koju minna, siis on nagu. Ja kus võiks. Saab ikka. Ära
Õpetaja: teeme ära. Panen siia ka siia. Ma panen. Ee, üks.
Õpetaja: See on nagu kõige leisim kommentaar, Ever. Aga las ta olla.
Õpetaja: Ma push in selle ära nii käsi püsti, kes kavatseb järgi tulla, Siis ma tean, keda ootan.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: amet. Palun
Õpetaja: tõstale, sobib.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis nii.
Õpetaja: Aa, kaksteist neliteist. Siis vä
Õpetaja: Ei, niimoodi ei saa Davai kaksteist Nelikümmend siis teeme. Sobib küll. Ja muidugi nii.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, lähme siis edasi.
Õpetaja: Loodame, et rohkem tehnilisi mure pole. Ootan kõike järgi, korra. Käsi püsti, kes veel on järgi tulemas ja tulemast.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: No mis see protsess oli? Vaata, Changes alt. Kõik kas või.
Õpetaja: Ja siis õpetaja Feb Viies Seekord siis järgi tulemine.
Õpetaja: Ee, aivar. Kas sul frontence server muidugi käivitas? Seda me ei võinudki proovida Käivitus Siis on Hästi,
Õpetaja: nii Ee, Vaatame siis. Ee, Mul on siin kuskil ka Shortcut. Kas siis nagu midagi tuli ka mingit teksti üldse? Panime Aa, me ei jõudnud tehagi Veel midagi vist või jõudsime. Ahah, et nüüd on niimoodi. Et linki me selle jaoks ei tee. Me ei tee see ülesse. Meil on üldse error, onju? Miks seda keegi peaks? Tegema
Õpetaja: aga Me saame käsitsi proovida. Vaata, et kui. Et selles mõttes, et kui me oleme vaatajale Error, kas tuleb? Ette? Tere, tuleb.
Õpetaja: No siin on juba väike vihje. Juba järgmise asja osas. Ka. Mida? Nagu tuleb mõelda, et mis me Nagu peame tegema
Õpetaja: natukene. Palju asju on siin lahti.
Õpetaja: No taaski järgi. Noh, panin selle just kinni. Jah, tore, Ee,
Õpetaja: tšira tšira.
Õpetaja: Et ee, Michel taaskis. Oli kirjas, et. Ups, midagi läheb valesti. Kas oli midagi veel Ei, tule meelde kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Aa, lihtsalt ongi. Keskel on lihtsalt tekst. Midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Nii kui me läheme siia. Error View Sse. Nüüd me hakkame toimetama selle skripti osa. Võime niimoodi silme eest veits kinni tõmmata. Keskendume siis sellele. Mis mõtted on nüüd siin? Jah,
Õpetaja: Kas teil numbrid üldse on?
Õpetaja: Ma. Ta line numbrid näitab. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et kas vähemalt Sätt neid. Üks, kaks, kuus. Neil need nagu on.
Õpetaja: Kas see küljepaneel on üldse nähtav? See on on ju mõne vastuse? Olgu, praegult Jah,
Õpetaja: aga ma ei oskaks ka peas seda seda öelda. Sellepärast, et seda probleemi pole öelda. Et Neid pole lihtsalt vä
Õpetaja: neid ülesid, selge Veel sama mure. Käsi püsti
Õpetaja: teiste.
Õpetaja: Vaata ühesõnaga, et kui teha mingi koodifail lahti. Näiteks Error View. Vaata, et ma saan, aru, kas see Asi on puudu, just, mis ma praegu
Õpetaja: seda kardionit ei ole siin kõrval. Kas teistel? Kas need nupuks see mis mina vajutan praegu? See on sinul puude?
Õpetaja: No lihtsam on korra tulla siia teha,
Õpetaja: aga sul ei ole Niukene vaadegi. Tuled siia kokku tõmmata ja nii edasi
Õpetaja: parem on see, et on olemas kui mingisugune tugi või mis iganes,
Õpetaja: Nii mis võiks olla esimene mõte, kui me hakkame tegema siin mingisugust asja,
Õpetaja: Paigutuse värki peaks mõtlema, kus. Mis meil paigutusega aitab.
Õpetaja: Boots Trap.
Õpetaja: Ee, te teha üks. Tab lahti. Loodan, et teil on juba tehtud. See Soovitasin teha
Õpetaja: ja kriidi peale kohe ennast kenasti. On teil käsi püsti, kellel ei ole seda Shortcut?
Õpetaja: Noh, kõigil on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, et me Tuleme. Vaata iga kord, kui uut vaadet hakata tegema. Sest paigutusele peab miinimum. Mõtlema, et me tuleme iga kord ja võtame selle sama näite Siit, kus on üks rida ja kolm veergo.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tulete oma töö juurde ja siis lihtsalt
Õpetaja: panebki siia template sisse. Selle Asendame lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nagu see näide, et on kolm kolum.
Õpetaja: Üks rida, kolm kolom, mitut kolme. Meie soovime
Õpetaja: ühte ainsat. No siis me peame vaatama, Et kus on need ülejäänud kaks? Onju, et kui me näeme, et siin on
Õpetaja: kokku, on siin kolm kolumit. Kui niimoodi korra kinni panna,
Õpetaja: Et siis kustutada ära. Aga nüüd kustutamisel kattimisel. Kui üle mitme rea teed, siis pead jälgima et ei juhtu mingeid jamasi. No näiteks, mis juhtuks. Kui ma praegu niimoodi ära kustutaks,
Õpetaja: sündaks läheb katki. Vaata, et siin algab tag. Kui ma kustutan siit ära, siis jääb midagi Puudu On ju. Ee, et niukestel hetkedel, nagu tõmmata natukene hoogu alati maha, kui plaanid midagi niimoodi kustutada, et, noh, mingid üliväiksed vead võivad tekkida, Näiteks võtad niimoodi ära ja pan katki. Onju,
Õpetaja: et ee, jälgida.
Õpetaja: Vahel ma ütlen, ma vahel teen ka niimoodi, kui mul on skoobiga elemendid Ja ma kavatsen midagi ära kustutada. Ongi võibolla lihtsam niimoodi kokku tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Sest kui sa nüüd kustutad need ära siit siis on nii algus, Kui Ka lõppmõlemad lähevad kindlalt nii
Õpetaja: siia pidi kirjutama, siis mida?
Õpetaja: Ee, no pane mingi Ups, midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Väike asi on nüüd see, Et kui seda teksti vaadata, siis ta on kuidagi väga väikene
Õpetaja: Ja üldse tegelikult ei ole väga viisakas niimoodi
Õpetaja: Ee, ilma teksti elementi sisse Kirjutamata, et mis ma võiks teha Siin
Õpetaja: siin on nagu väikene taaskis. On justkui nagu suur. Siis mõtled seinal
Õpetaja: Näiteks H. Üks onju teeb korra siia ülesse ühe elemendi H, üks tab.
Õpetaja: Ja siis lihtsalt tõstab selle.
Õpetaja: Control X ja Control V Ga näiteks siia sisse. Ära seda Natukene parem.
Õpetaja: Ta ei lase mulle tagasi peale seda tagasi minna.
Õpetaja: Mingi Jah, ellu.
Õpetaja: Ta ei teinud oma hästi ära. Musteri võtame kaasa, onju
Õpetaja: üle andnud, et see isegi sobib lihtsalt lõpuni ikka teha. Ma sain üldse Master Faili ära, et see on see lahtine fail oli see, Mis segas seda
Õpetaja: korraldan?
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd keskel.
Õpetaja: Nii, jah, nii uskumatu.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: Aa. Võiksime mingisuguse gif I ka panna.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla browser lahti Ups, midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Mina panen näiteks Explosion.
Õpetaja: Ma panen. Otsin mingid pildid, aga vaatame siit midagi mõnusat.
Õpetaja: Aa, sõnad. Geef võiks ka panna, on ju tasuta. Voh, Vaatame, kuidas see on korralik. Vaatan, kas see on
Õpetaja: ka nende ilusad. On need tuumapommid ja ma peaks ütlema
Õpetaja: ja et See, inetu on võibolla niimoodi mõelda, aga midagi ilusat on ka sellises. Destraction is
Õpetaja: Ee, davai. Mulle see, see sobib. Ma proovin saada Kuidagi seda
Õpetaja: päris nii öelda. Kihvt pilti kätte
Õpetaja: sa ikka.
Õpetaja: Ja sa teietad mind kogu aeg
Õpetaja: jah varsti on niuke. Tunne, et mina olen sinuga ebaviisakas kui mina sind vastu ei teieta. Ee, okei. Kuidagi imukõrjest on seda keeruline kätte. Saada Ma lihtsalt proovin uuesti
Õpetaja: Explosion Gif, ee Pildid see selle. Äkki saab siit kuidagi kätte. Kopi, image adress.
Õpetaja: Mina teen alati sellise triki, et ma lihtsalt teen eraldi. Tab I lahti Ja Siis vaatan, kas see on päriselt pilt või? See on jälle mingi veebileht. Niiöelda
Õpetaja: see tundub olevat ikkagi päris kihv.
Õpetaja: Ma võin korra selle slaki panna Ma pärast kustutan selle ära, sest et see mingit erilist väärtust ei oma.
Õpetaja: Nii läheb minema see sealt Ja siis,
Õpetaja: kuidas saab. Aa, kuidas saab niukest Gif I kuvada, Mis elemente Peame kasutama?
Õpetaja: Image.
Õpetaja: Ja meil Nüüd ei ole vaja teha, niimoodi et vaata, siin on üks ja siin on üks Heeder ja siis, ee, niiöelda teha eraldi road ja kolum Id. Näiteks et, ee. Tõsta see siis nagu Visuaalselt niiöelda teineteise, alla, et H. Üks juba tegelikult lükkabki endast. Mis iganes järgneb Alla Heeder, vaata, on ju pealkiri.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis kui me, Lihtsalt siia kõrvale tuleme Paneme. Img
Õpetaja: ja image tempel. Template Vaatas, et source ild ka noh, paneme siin ee pilt. Tuumapomm plahvatab vaatab
Õpetaja: ma, sulle, et see väga ilus.
Õpetaja: Aa.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui pilt ka. Kui pilt ei renderda, vaata jällegi, siis midagi. Vähemalt midagi, vähemalt kuvatakse, kuidas
Õpetaja: ja Source I Lihtsalt paste.
Õpetaja: No ma võin teha praegu niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, saab koodi. Vaadata
Õpetaja: on siin tuumapomm
Õpetaja: mul oli tagasi lahti voodiga vä.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta mul Nüüd surus lihtsalt need kahele reale. Vaata, et see kõik on üks tag.
Õpetaja: Aga see mõte järgi töötab ka. Ahhaa, Kuulge, ee, Üks tähtis asi, eriti jaavas igal pool. Ee, I love optimizing.
Õpetaja: Ee, oletame, et meil on siin See div on nagu ma teen suuremaks tagasi See Div on paigast ära. No see ei ole viisakas.
Õpetaja: Ee, asi.
Õpetaja: Ühtlasi tegelikult. Vaata, on vahe. Kas on tab või on kaks Tühikut.
Õpetaja: Ee, need võivad olla ka. Need on White Spaced. Neid tegelikult ee, ei näe. Nagu nii Hästi, siis on paar käsku, mis teevad sul koodi päris ilusaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma võibolla kasutan ka ühte teist näidet, enne kui ma klõbistan. Ma lähen korra siia. Näete Neid importe.
Õpetaja: Ma Teen meelega ühest importist. Ee, mingisuguse impordi, mida isegi ei ole vaja. Mingi suvaline asi. See on ainult vaatamise koht.
Õpetaja: Ee, näiteks Ee.
Õpetaja: Import test komponent. From.
Õpetaja: Mis see hall tähendab?
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab ja jäi. See hall
Õpetaja: ei ole kasutusel. Ma siin siin. Teen selle näituse vaatamise koht, Ma lükkan meelega siin mingisuguse jama. Korraldan
Õpetaja: sind. On mingid tühikud? Näiteks selline asi ei oleks ilus, aga ta tehniliselt töötaks,
Õpetaja: nüüd on ee, Mõned nagu käsud niiöelda, mis asuvad seda asja korrastama.
Õpetaja: Control alt.
Õpetaja: I teeb. Ee, ta teeb Mul ei tule see sõna meelde. Idents see, On see, et tabulaarne külgvaiknevus
Õpetaja: Control alt I teeb Selle korda.
Õpetaja: Ee, line Spacing on L Control alt L
Õpetaja: teeb korda ja ebavajalikud impordid Optimise imports on O
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt ta teeb selle koodi visuaalselt korda. Ja mina olen mõelnud niisuguse lihtsa agronoomi. Ilo nagu Control alt Ilo optimising, Ehk Siis kuidas seda teha. Oled kuskil selle faili lehel ja seda võid iga kell teha. Ta Midagi katki ei tee, hoiad peal Control alt.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, ee. Näiteks vasaku käega. Vaid kontrollite. Nüüd hakkate toksima. I l o i love optimising.
Õpetaja: Rõõm Kilo Jah, puhas rõõm. Tehke, Tehke koodilugeja, kes seda loeb rõõmsaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, teate, ma ütlen ausõnana Nagu et, ee, niuksed. Väiksed asjad, niuksed, väiksed asjad, Ee, lihtsalt eriti jaavas,
Õpetaja: Sa oled nagu jaavat nagu niivõrd palju teinud, et nagu mingi üks tühik kuskil.
Õpetaja: Ee, mõjub niimoodi. No see on veel lihtne näide. Noh, Teeme parem midagi paremat. Näiteks siin. Noh,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, mul. Ma Ma tunneks kuidas. Mul hakkaks vist verd silmadest niimoodi voolama? Keegi kraabib
Õpetaja: Ee, frontis Mitte nii väga, aga ma ütlen, et jaavas on nagu see, et kui ma näen, et üks tühik on puudu või ülevaate, Siis mul on niimoodi. Ja
Õpetaja: mida Hea, vabandust.
Õpetaja: Oi, tervist, Ee. See see töötab niimoodi Kui Sul on lihtsalt klikk kuskil, siis ta teeb kogu faili korraga.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on mingisugune selektsioon niiöelda tehtud, siis ta ainult teeb selle osa suhtes. Mul on hästi natukene käpas see et Ma võtan Control A ja siis ta on Il loo. See ei ole tegelikult otseselt vajalik. Siis Võib juhtuda kogemata niimoodi, aga, noh, Control Z loomulikult taastab selle.
Õpetaja: Aga ma nüüd tahan rääkida teile. Miks seda kindlalt teha?
Õpetaja: Ee, Räägime hästi natukene. Code Review St
Õpetaja: Ee Code Review on, ee, tarkvara arendaja kõige lemmikum protsess üldse.
Õpetaja: Vähemalt minul oli. Ja ühel heal arendajal võiks see olla.
Õpetaja: Aa See on siis see, kui Keegi teine vaatab teie koodi üle. Aa, nagu koodipilguga. Ta ei testi seda ta ei hakka seda testima. Ta võib vaadata nendega ülesannet ja Vaata seda ülesehitust ja kõike. Aga ta tegelikult ainult vaatab Koodi
Õpetaja: Kas on ilusti formuleeritud. Kas see on ülesehitusega? Kas Kas jätkusuutlik, Kas. Aga Noh, kas see ka lähenemine on okei? Vaata, on ju siis Code Reviewst oli lihtsalt, ee, Kui midagi nagu ei meeldi, siis kirjutatakse eraldi Ühe Ja teise ja kolmanda rea kohta, näiteks. Noh, siin võiks paremini olla. Ja too võiks paremini olla. Ja
Õpetaja: miks sa nii teed ja Loll oled, vä? Aa, Noh, niimoodi nad ei kirjuta. Aga võibolla vahel, saad aru ka. Vaata, nii mõtled?
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja siis selle Code Review, Miks, Ta on nagu hea? On see,
Õpetaja: et see on siis see koht, kus ee niiöelda. Sa saad. Areneda Keegi targem inimene annab sulle Näpunäited. Vaata, kuidas midagi võiks teha. Paremini.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd siin. Üks asi, mida kohe võiks ära mainida, on see, et Code Review D ei tohi kunagi võtta isiklikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, väga pal. Mul on niukseid õpilasi, kes ma tunnen, nagu. Et. Aga minu poolt töötab ka. Vaata, miks minu variant. Nagu kuidagi halvem on. Vaata, vahel on niimoodi, et isegi keeruline on selgitada. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, lihtsalt ee, See jutt, mis ma räägin, on lihtsalt liiga high level. Ee, aga aga lihtsalt olen tajunud ka, et ongi niuksed. Inimtüübid, kes kuidagi üle isiklikult võtavad, kirjutavad mingi koodi valmis. Keegi tegelikult paneb nende sisse oma aega, et aidata neile nagu selgitada, et, noh,
Õpetaja: siin saaks nagu paremini ja nii edasi, siis, Ee, siis seda tulekski selliselt võtta. See on keegi teine inimene, kes. Noh, okei, Kes Ta on sunnitud olukorras, et ettevõttes on selline poliitika, Vaata, et osa protsessist on ju?
Õpetaja: Aa. Noh, on ka erinevad. Samamoodi nagu analüüsi. Kirjutajad on head analüüsi. Kirjutajad? Noh, Hea task ja on Halb task on ju? On hea. Code Review on halb Code Review.
Õpetaja: Ee, see See Code Review, Kus tegelikult sa näed, et inimene on võtnud vaevaks ka midagi selgitada, et tegelikult sa pead ääretult tänulik olema sest,
Õpetaja: ta üritab leida sinu töös niiöelda puudujääke ja.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma ei tea, mis on.
Õpetaja: No mehhaanikas joonised joonistada peaks. Vaatame, siin See näitab joonise Siis teine vaatab. Läheb
Õpetaja: jah täpselt. Vaatab siis põhimõtteliselt kõik koodi ülevaate, et. Kas see on nagu okei kood.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on niimoodi. Vaata, et vähemalt mina siiamaani olen seda tajunud, et,
Õpetaja: ee, see, kes Kirjutab koodi, üritab kirjutada niivõrd perfektse koodi vahel et ei oleks mitte midagi öelda,
Õpetaja: on teine. Missioon ja siis ta peab leidma kasvõi ühe asja,
Õpetaja: et ee, midagigi. Mis saab seal paremaks teha? Vaata või oleks parem.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast et see on kaine Niukene. Noh, see oleneb. Vaata, Mõned on nagu ma. Ma olen ise ka teinud. Seal võib tekkida kaine niuke, väike, et sa ei viitsi nagu nagu mingit Noh,
Õpetaja: Davai, Ma hakkan nüüd mingit ühikut taga otsima. Aga ma ütlen nüüd nagu seda, et see iseendale kuidagi karjääris mõjub nagu, ee, ülitähtsalt, et sa Ootad seda esimest päeva, et iga. Kord, Kui sa teed ee, mingi koodi ära, lähed, siis sa nagu loodad, et äkki täna on see päev,
Õpetaja: kus ei leiagi ühtegi viga ja lihtsalt paneks see,
Õpetaja: et see on Niukene põnev hetk, mida nagu oodata. Ja sa alguses ei taha väga tulla. Sellepärast Alati on midagi, mida saab paremini teha. Siis sa oled algaja ka. Sa ei oska nii hästi veel, onju? Ee, et Alati on midagi, mida saab paremini teha. Kogenud silmad. Siit teeb kohe need kohad ülesse kus saaks tegelt asju ikkagi paremini teha
Õpetaja: ja ja Siis on niimoodi, et, ee,
Õpetaja: kõige hullem asi on see, kui sa tegelikult üks päev siis teedki. Ee, nagu selles mõttes perfektse koodi, vaata, et see sobib,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult ei ole öelda mitte midagi lähenemise kohta. Ee, nimede kohta. Koodi ülesehituse kohta. Mida iganes Fine töötab, kõik on Väga hästi, aga siis, mis ta teeb, on see. Vaata, tema näeb kõike faile. Vaata, kus sa midagi tegid.
Õpetaja: Temal on väga lihtne võtta Ee, checkout. Sellest sinu sellest harust ja valida kõik need failid.
Õpetaja: Näiteks niimoodi võib. Noh, niimoodi üle projekti. Ta ei tahaks seda teha. Vaata, Aga ta võiks võtta nagu mingid mingid failid Näiteks ma teen meelega näiteks siia. Mingi.
Õpetaja: Ma teen korra ühe kommit. I, minu ma ei saa seda teha. Ma teen ta kõigepealt korda.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin ka ei ole. Ma just teengi. Noh, paneme näiteks siia selle ühe tühika kommitin selle töö ära.
Õpetaja: Nii, Vaatame, et see see Code läks. Code Review Sse Code Review tuleb. Vaatab seda Error View vaadet ja vaatab, et Ee, jah,
Õpetaja: pole midagi öelda.
Õpetaja: Kui lihtne on temal endal panna nagu I Love optimizing. Ja nüüd vaadata Changes alt. Vaata Ou, siin on Mingi asi, mis on.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Tal on siin üks tühike ekstravaate. Nagu, Mis teema on? Nagu. Milleks see siin vajalik on?
Õpetaja: Noh, see võib rohkem neid asju olla, et. Ee, see see tegelikult on väga tobe. Vaata, et kui sa oledki tegelikult jõudnud sinna faasi et koodil midagi Polnudki viga.
Õpetaja: Ja siis Code Reviewutor ütleb, et Näe, sul on siin kaks ebavajalikku tühja rida või või Sul on siin jäänud mingi tühik Või Mingi taane või midagi taolist. See on nagu see, et
Õpetaja: tegelikult täna oli see päev. Aga sa ise nagu kaotasid selle võimaluse sellepärast, Et, ee, sul kood ei olnud normaalsed formaadiga,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, ma ütlen ka, ega? Ja see see tegelikult ei pruugi ka olla, isegi ta tegi Control alt. Ee, mis iganes ta lihtsalt jääb silma, Sul jääb jaamas silma, Kui sul on mingi
Õpetaja: üks nagu tühik seal või üks Tühik on puudu. Kus ta peaks olema see lihtsalt. Kui sa oled teinud päevast päevaga koodi, siis on niimoodi, et tunned nagu mingit teravat pindu silmas nagu et see see jääb sinna, et ei ole mõtet anda neid lihtsaid võite Le. Ei,
Õpetaja: et ee, väga lihtne on niimoodi. Sa võid justkui kogu oma minne võtta terve kausta ja teha I Love Optimizing,
Õpetaja: et teed oma. Kui sa oled oma töö ära teinud, Siis mina käisin kõik oma failid niimoodi alati üle,
Õpetaja: et ma nagu seda ei kinkinud. Kust see tuli. Lõpuks sa lihtsalt õpidki. Teine Asi, Mis ma tegin, oli see ka, et ma olin ikkagi. Ee, üsna püüdlik. Mina näiteks ise hoidsin endale kuskil one notis või kus iganes,
Õpetaja: Iga kord, kui Code Review oli, Ma tegin mingeid screenshot, e pilte ja tekste. Mis iganes. Vaata, et iga kord kui midagi, tuli Code Reviews, siis ma markeerisin selle. Endale Tahavad nagu kuskile Panin märkmed. Ee, kirjeldasin lahti ja siis iga kord, kui ma uut tööd tegin ja Mis Review Sse minema
Õpetaja: siis? Ma vaatasin alati oma märkmed üle, et mul Jumala eest ei oleks mingisugust korduvat niiöelda käitumismustri viga,
Õpetaja: et ma Nagu teengi. Nagu. Sest et see tegelikult ajab väga vihane, kui sa teed Code Review D kellelegi Ee, sa harid teda, õpetad ja räägid mingisugusest asjast. Vaata, mis saaks paremini teha, mida iganes. Ja siis sa vaatad, et ta pidevalt tuleb täp i pealt selle sama asjaga, see On nagu see, et nagu
Õpetaja: seda nagu ei tahaks teha, et see. Noh, kui keegi teine panustab sinusse aega, vaata ja ta annab sulle Ee, hea Code Review ja üritab sind kuidagi harida. Ja seda siis ee tulebki. Eesmärk ongi see, et tema üritab sind õpetada paremaks, See on ka seeniorite ülesanne. See ongi nende ülesanne.
Õpetaja: Nad peavadki tõmbama. Ülejäänud meeskonda ka järjest paremale tasemele. See on nende ülesanne,
Õpetaja: aga, noh, siis Selle juuniori ülesanne on nagu. Et saada paremaks aja jooksul.
Õpetaja: Ja siis selline. Selline. Niiöelda koodikorrastus on kõige lihtsam. No miks mul siin silma Paistab on see ka. Vaata, ega ma ise ju ka kogu aeg. Jäpa, jäpa. Räägin teile. Sellest on ju? Ja siis, kui te hakkate ise nagu seal toimetama oma projektide ja asjadega. Tulen Istun laua taha siis ma vahel vaatan, et. Oh, my God, ma sealt toast välja võtta.
Õpetaja: Plahvatan sa lihtsalt nagu. Noh, kõik on nagu ülisavi pilla valla, nagu, et, Noh, te ei pea isegi käsitsi seda korda, tegema
Õpetaja: Ee, Ma ise kogu aeg kirjutan koodi. Ma. Mul Tegelikult on see käpa sees. Iga Teatud väikse hetke taga on Tegelikult ma ei viitsi, Noh, Kui sa oled sa tähele pannud, kui vajutad kuskilt realt eetrit. Ta lähed õige daamide peale,
Õpetaja: aga see võib ka sassi minna mingil hetkel Vaata koodi kirjutamise hetkel. Siis ma ikka. Aeg ajalt klõbistan seda nuppu et, noh, kirjutasin veits koodi ära ja teen ta nagu ilusaks, sest Ma näen, et ta on nagu veits paigast ära,
Õpetaja: et tehniliselt see kood nagu töötaks. Millega tal viga poleks.
Õpetaja: No saite ka mingi pildi hätta.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: Okei, ee. Nüüd. Mis me järgmisena teeme? No ma teen siis selle kommit I ära. Nüüd on see korras
Õpetaja: või on mingi Viis Complete.
Õpetaja: Tegelt võib korra taaski ka veel vaadata. Kas siin äkki oli või midagi. Või ei olnud.
Õpetaja: Description. Lisasime komponendi. Midagi läks valesti, Lisa juurde mingi kihvt eesti error vaadet minnes vastavale Error aadressile tehtud onju
Õpetaja: kompeet.
Õpetaja: See on ka mitte pluss.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ja nüüd ma tahangi Rääkida sellest protsessist, et Ee, kuidas asjad Masterisse jõuavad?
Õpetaja: Ee, teie oma tiimitöödest. Teil on selline vabadus, et teil Master Haru ei ole, kuidagi Protect,
Õpetaja: et sinna ei saa otse Merchida. Ee, oma niiöelda tiimitöödest. Teil ei ole mõtet seda päris protsessi mängida. Mingi Cold Review ja kuidas? Masterisse. Saate otse Masterisse. Merchida oma arvutis
Õpetaja: saate minna Master Haru peale tõmmata sisse oma tehtud töö. Noh, Masterharu ongi tiimides. Masterharu see on Nüüd, E. Projekt,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ütleme. Jaroslaw teeb tööd Jaroslavi. Haru alt on teinud tööd. Ta läheb Masterharu peale, Ütleb, et Merch Yaroslaf Into Master. Aga päriselus ei Käi see nii.
Õpetaja: Päriselus käib selline asi. Keegi peab selle koodi üle vaatama. Keegi Peab panema tegelikult pöidla, et see on okei. Ja see Merch Imine ei toimu mitte kasutaja arvutis, vaid hoopis
Õpetaja: kõigile. Näha, et sa nagu selles mõttes kõigile näha, mis seal on, siis meie teeme seda ka
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui me tegime. Ta juba pakub Siin ka Great Bull Request.
Õpetaja: Ta nägi, et ee, uus Haru lükati pilve. Noh, mis see harus on? Arvatavasti mingi arenduse haru. Ilmselt me tahaksime nüüd tehtud tööd nagu kuhugi. Ee, siis ee, niiöelda Masterisse tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta pakubki sellist võimalust, et kas paneme ülesse Sellise palve? See on Request. See ei ole, nagu kui seda nuppu vajutaks, aga ärme tee seda siit.
Õpetaja: Lähme teeme seda hoopis Kita Vist lähme. Meie kitar abi.
Õpetaja: Keed saab.
Õpetaja: Ee, kõik. Peaksite nägema. Aa, panga projekti. Mis on siis see? Ma võin korra lingi visata Ka Praegu lihtsuse huvides Pärast kustutan ära.
Õpetaja: Slack I, vaata siin. Ta näitab juba praegu, et neliteist Branch I on.
Õpetaja: Kui selle peale klikkidest on näha, ka need erinevad bränze.
Õpetaja: Sa nüüd eeldad seda, ka et te push isite välja. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui te seda ei teinud, siis pole midagi. Kui te teie niiöelda see. Teil peavad mõlemad olema push itud, teil peab oma nimeline haru olema. Push itud. Ja seda saab teha ka. Seda võib miljon korda teha. Ma lähen näiteks õpetaja peale ja panen,
Õpetaja: kas On mingeid muudatusi ei ole. Okei, aga Push anyway.
Õpetaja: Aa. Kui seda haru ennast ei olnud seal, siis ta push Ib selle ülesse ja Samamoodi peab olema see õpetaja Feb Tema peab olema samamoodi pilves.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma võin neid lihtsalt klõbistada. Ei olnud. Midagi lükata Need olid juba Aga kui teie tahate ka kaasa teha ja proovida neid nuppe klõbistada, siis see eeldab seda, et mõlemad niiöelda harud on pilves, ja jällegi Vaata see teie nimeline haru. Kujutage ette, et see on lihtsalt maskerharu.
Õpetaja: Ja teie see nimeline arenduse haru on lihtsalt siis arendusharu, et et Päriselus oleks meil Master viis. Aga me siis mängime seda.
Õpetaja: Kui ma korra teen. Refresh I Ma vaatan. Kas on mingi juurde tekkinud Siin Vahepeal näed. Juba tuli
Õpetaja: nüüd siin üleval. On Niukene Tab. Nagu ei oleks tegelikult meil ühe klõpsu vajutusel Bull Request ise, nagu teinud siia keskkonda Pilve aga ma. See selline integratsioon on. Ainult Minu meelest ma ei tea, kas Kit lab iga on ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, palju eri on Seal teisi mingeid Bucket ja igast mingeid muid teenusepakkujaid, et Ee, õpime seda ikka nii. Nagu kuidas seda saab teha? Noh, paljud muidugi on ka selle juba tegelikult ära niiöelda automatiseerinud, et sa saad Chiiras vajutada nuppe ja tuleb Request.
Õpetaja: Meie teeme niuksel klassikalisel viisil. Lähme teeme käsitsi, Selle
Õpetaja: saate siia selle Pullrequesti peale. Te peate olema selle panga projektis. Loomulikult olete selle peal.
Õpetaja: See võib olla ka vaatamise koht. By the way.
Õpetaja: Seda Ei pea tingimata harjutama mis. See nuppude vajutamine ikka on on, ju
Õpetaja: ee? Mina, Ütlen new Pull Request
Õpetaja: Ja Nüüd on siis küsimus. Vaata, et. Ee. Kust. Kuhu harusse sa soovid, et see palve läheb ülesse? Näete, seda noolekest onju?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis siin peaks olema päriselus Master ja siin pool peaks olema viis. Aga mina siis mängin, et minu õpetaja on minu master.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb kogu tehtud töö ja see Konkreetne arendusharu. Selle arenduse raames on õpetaja Feb viis.
Õpetaja: Aa.
Õpetaja: Tema näeb kohe. Näeb ära, et seal, õpetaja Feb viie. Aa, viies on mul Kolm komit. I Neli faili on muudetud. Ee, bla blabla. Siin all on väike Niukene Preview ka. Et Mis asjad see on nüüd see Mingi õppefail, Mis ta tegi Ee kohta.
Õpetaja: Siis on meil ee, ruuteri indeksis toimunud Mingid muudatused. Error Views on tekkinud täiesti uus fail. Homeviews on toimunud mingid väiksed muudatused.
Õpetaja: Siin on lihtsalt nagu väike preview. Vaata, mis mis need muudatused on. Tegelikult, Mis muudatused on kui teeks hetkel Ei ole veel mitte midagi. Nagu seda pulbrit. Kui hästi pole Ennast pole veel tehtud
Õpetaja: pange tähele. Mis ta siin ütleb? Üleval, mis ta ütleb.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et praegusel hetkel, kui keegi on või kes või kes iganes testija. Eelkõige, peaks reaalselt protsessist läbi käima, kui kõik on nagu mopöida põhimõtteliselt andnud
Õpetaja: siis saaks vajutada siin serveris nuppu ja Kit Ee. Suudab ise teha, siis selle merge ära. Arenduse tehtud töö
Õpetaja: viiakse Ülemasterisse
Õpetaja: siis, kui seal keegi on vahepeal toimetanud mõnes samas failis, kus ka meie oma arenduses tegime muudatust, siis tuleb konflikt, sellepärast enam Ta ei tea. Vaata, et kuidas. Kui. Kui näiteks
Õpetaja: sina tegid sinna faili, mingid muudatused ja keegi teine tegi ühte faili muudatus, et tema Ise ei saa neid kokku miksida. Et mis see lõpptulemus on? Siis Ta ütleb seda, et sa pead selle asja nagu korda jääma
Õpetaja: ja Senikaua, kuni tuleb siia see roheline nii öelda. Noolekene või? No või see artikl Niiöelda.
Õpetaja: No mina teen Great Bull Request
Õpetaja: nüüd siin. Ma Saaksin siis näiteks? Ee, nüüd ta vist. Ta veel ikka ei ole veel seda päris päris ära teinud, et ma saan veel mingi teksti siia jätta. Ja bla, bla, bla,
Õpetaja: ee. Alles siis ma saan ka ära määrata. Ja,
Õpetaja: noh, on siis kõik need samad inimesed, kes on Kollaboraatorid selles projektis.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis klassikaliselt. Siin oleks siis mingi vanema arendaja nimi, mille sa üles otsid ja paned,
Õpetaja: ei pea olema muidugi vanema arendaja. Sa võid olla mis tahes arendaja, aga tavaliselt on ka üldjuhul. Tavaliselt on nagu alati kokkulepped, et kui sa mingis projektist teed, sa Teed mingi arendus? Küsid nagu, et. Noh, kes sellele
Õpetaja: Eriti kui mingi niukene uus asi, mingi teatuur, mida ehitad, siis on alati ju mingi kokkulepe, et. Okei, ma selle töö ära teen. Siis. Kes kes Code Review teeb, onju? Kes vaatab siis öeldakse. No ei tea, äkki tema Siis vaatab.
Õpetaja: Ee, eks? Pigem on ikka niimoodi kipub olema. Et proovitakse panna neid inimesi. Ainult Lhv S oli niimoodi, kes kõige rohkem seal projektis, nagu neid asju, nagu teavad. Ja on ka niiöelda seda ressurssi, et selles mõttes, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Mingil hetkel oli ka ikkagi seda ka, et, ee, mingi level või teine juunior isegi teeb Code, Peaasi, et keegi üle vaatab oleneb. Ka taaski raskusastmest. Mina saaksin näiteks, öelda Et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, jaroslav. Ee, vaatab selle töö üle. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Aa. Siis saab ka panna seda. Vaata, et kelle käes on hetkel pall. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, alguses ma võiks öelda, et palju on praegult minu käes. Bcs saab,
Õpetaja: aga siis kui võtab selle ette ta saab, või Tähendab, ma saan teha selle ära.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd siis. Ta tekib sinna süsteemi
Õpetaja: ja nüüd. Ma võin öelda, nagu. Et hetkel on pall, Näiteks,
Õpetaja: ee. Saan öelda, et ei. Hei, et tegelikult hoopis nüüd. Ee.
Õpetaja: Sellega tegelebki. Jaroslav.
Õpetaja: Näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ja enda. Võtan siit ära.
Õpetaja: Näiteks nii,
Õpetaja: Noh, Siis on nagu mingi inboxi, tuleb teated ja asjad. Aga ee, tavaliselt ee. Väga hullult. Mina teen niukseid, asju Kunagi näpidki. Paljud asjad olid Kuidagi ka integreeritud. Ja peamine asi oli ikkagi. Tavaliselt kirjutasid Slaki kellelegi, et. Kuule, ma panin sulle Review Sse,
Õpetaja: kui sul on aega saab vaadata kellegil. Väike nats nats.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Aa. Nüüd on hoopis teistsugune vaade. Kui see Request on tehtud Ee mida nüüd siis teeb Ja nüüd Ma mängin, et, ee, ma olen. Ee. Jaroslav. Näiteks onju?
Õpetaja: Ma tulen, Ee. Ma saan vaadata näiteks seda, et kõik failid, mis on, ee, Muutusid selle arendusega.
Õpetaja: Ta võrdleb praegult põhimõtteliselt, et mis on minu arenduses ja mis on nagu masteris, Nagu et mi, mi, mis Nagu muudatused Mina nagu tegin.
Õpetaja: Ja siin need värvid jälle mängivad. Ka mul on muidugi Dark View. Kas Teil on üldse tark või teil on valge
Õpetaja: Alguses Seda saab kuskilt sealt Settings ära panna. Settings? Mitte projekti Setting. See vist käib pigem kuskilt. Siit.
Õpetaja: Parents.
Õpetaja: Minul on valitud tark team. Vist vä.
Õpetaja: No see on minul valitud soft. Dark.
Õpetaja: Ee, valge kuidagi. Mina ei tea. Valge pealt ei tule need värvid nii hästi välja. Mulle selles mõttes ei meeldi Valge, valge pealt ei tule värvid välja nii hästi
Õpetaja: ja siin. Siis Ta saaks vaadata, nagu et näed, siin on täiesti roheline. Uus fail.
Õpetaja: Tõeväärtustabel and Or.
Õpetaja: Siis on. Nüüd Kui ma võtan mingisuguse olemasoleva faili siis on siin ta näitab muudatusi ja
Õpetaja: See vajab natukene kogenud silma, et panna pilti kokku, et mis muudatused toimus? Natuke vajab kogemust.
Õpetaja: Aga mida tegelikult Muidugi, Arendajad tihtipeale teevad, et siin On nagu ära näidatud, et näed, et selle arenduse käigus import Home View kustus ära ja kustus ära Ka mingi sidekriips ja asemele on lihtsalt jäänud homeview ja juurde on tulnud error view.
Õpetaja: Nii, Aga kuidas seda loomulikult saab teha, on see, et sa teed selle intellisest Checkout iga lihtsalt lahti, et sa vaatad seda lõpptulemust. Tavaliselt on pigem nagu, Noh, mina. Kuidagi ma nagu niimoodi ei vaadanud, aga põhiline asi on see, kuidas me suhelda saame. Nüüd on siiski see.
Õpetaja: Näiteks. Ee. No ma otsingi siis midagi ülesse, mis mulle näiteks ee, ei meeldi,
Õpetaja: Aga mitte, mis siin muutus oli tegelikult, see, et olid topelt jutumärgid ja muutusid ühekordseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, no okei, näiteks siin see kommentaar pilt tuuma Pomm plahvatab. Väga ilus. No mulle ei meeldi see, aga päriselus oleks see pigem nagu, et mul mingi koodireaga mingi loogika või nimi ei meeldi on ju? Ma lihtsalt saaksin öelda et. Ee, selle rea peal. On Mul mingisugune biif
Õpetaja: Kirjutaks niimoodi. Kuule, pane mingi normaalsem ee, alt tekst.
Õpetaja: Oled kommend.
Õpetaja: See kommentaar nüüd on niiöelda siin nähtav.
Õpetaja: Siis, ee, seda saab Nüüd siis, Ee. Näete, see tekib kohe Vaata, Niukene Chat I niiöelda logo.
Õpetaja: Ja noh, siis, ta näiteks läheb kuskile. Veel.
Õpetaja: Ee, ütleb näiteks. Ma ei tea
Õpetaja: lähme kuskile mujale, Homeus.
Õpetaja: Jah, noh, ma Mängin, et, noh, mingi üleliigne. Ee, New line.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea komment.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, ee, mingi hetk. Ta saab vajutada ka nupu, mingi mida Iganes sa näed, jälle mingi staatuste teema, et sa tegid iseenesest üldse. Mingi rolli Siin võib vabalt olla ka lihtsalt slack ist, et kuule, Ma jätsin sulle kommentaarid. Mine vaata
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd. See on see, et mina, nüüd saan nagu oma vaatest minna, tulla kohe vaatama neid Ee, on Niukene vist kohe täitsa siin üleval ka. Mugav vaade. Nagu Conversation.
Õpetaja: Kõik vestlused on siin ära toodud. Vaata kus midagi. Midagi mulle öeldi mingi koodilõigu kohta
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Ma saan neid uurida, ja Vaadata see saab koodi Kirjutada Mida iganes. Noh, saad replaise panna ka nagu vastata midagi veel lisaküsida. Mis see nagu parem on, on see, et kui hakkaks lihtsalt läbi slaki või kuskil mujal arutama neid asju, et mis sul valesti on,
Õpetaja: siis sa pead ju hakkama midagi jahuma, et. Kuule, mine vaata seal failis. Kas see rida või see meetod, või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Siin on väga mõnus. Vaata, et see. See kommentaar on kohe selle koodi. Sees toetab ka seda Vähemalt ita abiga, et sealt saad ka veits vaadata neid pulbreidkaste Ee, vaadata ja suhelda omavahel. Aga, noh, idee järgi siis justkui on niimoodi, et sa saad ka ise niiöelda ära Markida. Mis on tehtud, mis? Mitte
Õpetaja: ee. Vist. Ee, on seda parem. Teha. Siit vist oli. Ma ei mäletagi.
Õpetaja: Ee by change reserve Comment
Õpetaja: Seni kaua, kuni, ee. Sa ei ole markkinud seda nagu resolv iks. Ära siis senikaua see kommentaar seal ees istub teine variant, Kuidas See kommentaar sealt nagu ära läheb, on see, et kui sa nüüd teed uue kommit I ja seal. Ee, need ee, need read niiöelda muutuvad.
Õpetaja: See kõnealustead, mis on markeeritud, muutuvad. Siis nad ka enda lähevad peitu ära. No Kuidas mina tavaliselt tegin, on see, et ma siis Lokaalselt tegin oma arvutis kõiki neid muudatusi. Ee, muutusin. Tegin paremaks ja siis alati panin nagu mingi
Õpetaja: tehtud iseendale, panin niiöelda Reply,
Õpetaja: ma Panin, Veel selle ka, et resolve Comment. Vaata, et see on. Noh, see on tehtud Ükshaaval niimoodi. Käid, läbi, vaatad seda ja koodibaasis teed muudatuse, Vaatad seda teed koodibaasis muudatused
Õpetaja: seni kaua, kuni sa oled kõik niiöelda muudatused ära teinud. Need ei pruugi nii lihtsad olla, seal võib olla ka täiesti niimoodi, et. Kuule, palun tee siin see ringi. Tee teistsugune lähenemine. See võib aega võtta ja nii edasi, on ju, Ee, vahel ongi niimoodi, et see vahel on mingid väga lihtsad asjad. Vahel on mingid niuksed asjad, mis nagu nõuavad, siis veel üldse uurimist ja mis iganes, onju.
Õpetaja: Aga see on sinu Koodi Vaadatakse üle ja sulle öeldakse nagu. Mis võiks teha paremini
Õpetaja: Ja siis, kui kõik on läbi,
Õpetaja: ma Panen näiteks. Ee. Saan mingi kommentaid jätta.
Õpetaja: Ee, all Good
Õpetaja: siis lõpus. Kui see on nagu tehtud, siis tuleb see nupp nähtavale nii öelda Merch Pudrequest.
Õpetaja: Ee, et see. See nüüd on tegelikult päris ettevõttes konfitav. Nad konfivad selle täpselt Ära vaata, et kuidas. Kes, mismoodi saab, seda, Ee, et see nupp nagu niisama ei teki. Sellepärast, et see nupp tähendab seda, et kui seda nuppu nüüd vajutada, siis kood läheb Masterisse,
Õpetaja: et see võibki olla igasugused. Noh, ütleme niimoodi, et pangas näiteks oleks väga halb, kui arendaja kuidagi saab võibolla mingisugust koodi kommit ida niimoodi
Õpetaja: Ee, sinna. Reposse. Vaata, et, ee. Keegi isegi ei märka. Vaata, on ju? Ta Kood on alati kood. Muidugi, ta on alati nähtav. Keegi võib selle ka hiljem lihtsalt üles trikkida. Ta näeb koodist midagi imelikku, Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga ka lihtsalt nagu puht printsiibis, Nagu see, et ee, Kogemata ei läheks mingisugune või viga või? Või loogika viga, või mis iganes, et see on protsess, vaata et tavaliselt ikkagi, et enne, kui See nupp nähtavale ikkagi ei tule. Kui on.
Õpetaja: See on nagu. Kuidas see setup? Nagu tavaliselt on. Keegi paneb Approved ära.
Õpetaja: Testi on selle ära testinud. Näiteks paneb, et jah. Tema poolt on kõik fine, et nagu võib minna. Gold Review on ammu tehtud. Ee siis on lihtsalt nupuvajutus. Ja nüüd on vaja aru saada, et see nupu vajutus toimub pilves.
Õpetaja: Ma vajutan selle Merch Pull Request.
Õpetaja: Ma panen korra korra, Ee, Ma tahan näidata neid opsioneid Ka
Õpetaja: Ee, Merch Poor Request vaikimisi. Ta teeb lihtsalt ühe uue komitee juurde. Kui ta Merch Ib, See tähendab, et vanad komitid jäävad alles ja üks tuleb juurde. Aga tegelikult on parem variant. Ee, vaata, see. Minu töö oli kolm komiiti nii selline kirjas. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Ee, tegi. Õpetaja on ju Kolm komiiti tegin. Nüüd on küsimus see. Vaata, ma seda rääkisin korra ka, et kas jääb sinna sellesse. Ee, kit i ajaloosse. Kolm mummut. Näed sinna Masterisse või me squash ime.
Õpetaja: Lükkame kõik kokku ja tuleb ainult üks üle.
Õpetaja: Küsib tavaliselt Vanasti vähemalt Lhv S. Meil oli niimoodi, et me ei kasutanud kunagi seda Squash I. Vaata, ma isegi teadlik selline asi on Tavaliselt oli Nii et kõik need komiitid, mis sina tegid? Tegelikult läksid siis Masterisse ka. Aga see on. Mõne töö puhul võib tähendada mingi kakskümmend pluss komiiti. Näiteks kui oled niuke tihe komiiti ja tegelikult komiitidel tasubki,
Õpetaja: siis sul on neid punkte, kuhu sa saad nagu tagasi minna, juhul kui asjad lõpuks ei arene selles suunas, kuhu vaja. Vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes on nagu alati parem teha nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga selles mõttes Ongi küsimus, et mis seal Masteris nende kahekümne komiitiga teha, Onju, et, ee, selles mõttes nagu mulle meeldib. Pigem see Squashion Merch
Õpetaja: in the Base Branch. Mis on siis see master
Õpetaja: versus Will be added to base Branch Saate Ma üldiselt aru
Õpetaja: jutt käib lihtsalt, nagu, et kuidas hakkab. Kuidas see Master näeb? Välja, kuidas minu õpetaja näeb. Ära vaata, et õpetaja V viis, Kus mul see on, Õpetaja V viis
Õpetaja: need Ee, siin üks, kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Kas need komiitid hakkavad olema nüüd ka õpetajas. Või lihtsalt Tuleb juurde. Üks kommit
Õpetaja: Parem on see squash? See Squash. Minu meelest,
Õpetaja: kui just see tunne kuidagi, et mingil põhjusel oleks hea. Vaata, et need komiitid jäävad sinna. Niimoodi. Mummudena eraldi komiitidena
Õpetaja: ma nagu kert ei näe ärilist Point I.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis siit. Ma valiksin selle. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Mul ei tule kohe meelde. Ma olen seda ise ka mõned korrad kasutanud
Õpetaja: see on nagu. See on nagu niimoodi rebase on Nagu vist niimoodi. Et. Ee,
Õpetaja: see vist oli kuidagi niimoodi, et Sellest harust ei jää nagu justkui nagu jälge. Vaata vaid, ee. See Ei, olnud päris. See
Õpetaja: oli jah, et need kommitid nagu lähevad otse Nagu Masterisse kaile,
Õpetaja: et nad ei ole nagu kuidagi. Kuidagi nii oli. Ma ei ole päris kindel. Seal oli mingi niuke Konksu oli,
Õpetaja: ei Kasuta seda lihtsalt. Ee, peaaegu kunagi.
Õpetaja: Aga jällegi, ee. Kui nagu tahate natuke rohkemat teada. Cloud Code, käivitad uus õppematerjal, mida teeb prebase,
Õpetaja: nii? Aga ma teen selle liigutuse ära. Ee, näete, siin ta veel näitab. Ka. Ei ole konflikte master. Iga Merching Can Before automatically,
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta Pakub mulle võimaluse ka. Kuna ma selle squash in ära, siis ta pakub. Vaata, et nagu jätad nagu need. Vähemalt need kommittide pealkirjad, mis ennem olid. Saan ise kirjutada ümber kui tahan midagi
Õpetaja: midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Come It.
Õpetaja: Nii, Nüüd pange tähele. Ta ütles, et
Õpetaja: kui te vaatate natukene paremile. Mis asja ta pakub meile seal
Õpetaja: Delete. Branch saate aru? Nad on ehitanud selle platvormi siia sisse sellesse protsessi,
Õpetaja: kui sul on see Haru. Juba Niiöelda see töö on juba viidud üle Masterisse. Siis miks peaks see haru enam seal niimoodi virelema? Vedelema Kõigil olema nähtav Ei
Õpetaja: Delive Branch.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd siis on siis selline olukord, kus me saame tegelikult vaadata, et. Ja jällegi, ärge nüüd unustage. Ära vaata seda punast joont.
Õpetaja: Meie praegu tegime niimoodi, et me niiöelda meie Master Liikus edasi pilves.
Õpetaja: Aga meie arvutame selle liikved oma arvutis me tegime ju oma Arendused,
Õpetaja: arenduse töö. Ee, tegime ära, on ju? Ee ja push. Isime pilve Aga Master läks edasi tegelikult pilves meie arvutis. Ta on ikka Endiselt maas. Ehk Kui me praegu teeme ja vaatame, mis on meie nimelise Haruga. Toimub. Mis seal peaks olema?
Õpetaja: Mis? Peaks juhtuma, kui ma Vajutan nüüd siin.
Õpetaja: Mis peaks juhtuma. Aa, selle haruga. Minul õpetaja, teil Kuidas
Õpetaja: noolake peaks tulema? Sellepärast, et nüüd ju tekkis üks ekstra kommit, Tekkis pilve, mida siin pole, onju? Näed, siin on mul õpetaja. Mul lõpeb ära. Siin. Lisasin veel mõned videod, aga tegelikult veebi tegi siin Kolm tööd,
Õpetaja: kolm komitee. Aga nüüd peaks olema seal pilves. Selles masteris peaks olema üks commit.
Õpetaja: No kui ma teen
Õpetaja: tuline olek vä.
Õpetaja: Noh, Ja nüüd ongi see, et kui sa näed mingi nooleke eest Action It
Õpetaja: kui see noor, mis tuleb alla, see tähendab, et meil on Working Copy enda lokalis sellest asjast. Ee, siis vii see samale joonele. Ehk siis tuleb siin antud juhul öelda. Update.
Õpetaja: Kui on roheline nool, välja, siis on vaja. Push Ida. Minu arvutis on pilves. Pole.
Õpetaja: No Bushi kohta veel leiab mingisuguseid selgitusi. Aga teate, mida ma vihkan, On see. Vaata, kui ma. Kui ma näen, ma tulen teile appi. Vaata mingi asjadega ja siis ma näen. Teil on mingi rämedalt mingeid noorekesi Ja asju siis ma nagu alati. See, nagu. Miks sa lihtsalt ei Action I nägid.
Õpetaja: Sa näed noot. Siis ta üritab anda, sest ühel Hetkel Rainule. Mul on üks probleem. See probleem on Kuule, vaata, mul on siin kaks noot, et üks näitab nol alla ja teine näitab ülesse. Vaata, see on samal ajal, et mis ma tegema pean.
Õpetaja: See on nagu see. Noh, aga kui sa oleksid kogu aeg neid nool ja Action innud, siis ei saaks sellist olukorda tekkida, et. Noh, alustame. Sellest on ju, et kui pilves läheks Master edasi, mis peaks olema põhjus, et te tahate hoida endal. Ee, vana masterit. Teised on tööd teinud
Õpetaja: asju. Võibolla mingi rämedalt ringi tõstetud. Te ju ise oma lokaali Pealt ei tahaks võtta nagu uut haru, mis on vana, et vältida seda probleemi, siis saad update I.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sa ütled, Aa ma selle haruga üldse ei toimeta. No miks ta sul üldse lokali all on? Kus ta ära vaatab? Sellega ei tee midagi,
Õpetaja: aga kui sul On seal mingid nooled ja asjad. Siis on küsimus Nagu miks? Nagu seal ei ole ühtegi peenemat põhjust miks? Nagu mitte nagu Action ida neid,
Õpetaja: et ikka tasub kohe kõik ee ära teha, Et ta oleks niimoodi ilus ja puhas.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on muidugi mõned asjad. Vaata, et Okei, ee, kui mina. Kui ma teen nüüd Fetch I, vaatan, kas ma leian niiöelda remote i alt Ee leian. Õpetaja Feb viis
Õpetaja: Ei, ole. On ainult õpetaja Feb Neli, mis on kuidagi rippuma jäänud.
Õpetaja: Miks ma ei leia seda? Sealt kustutati ära, on nii? Ta ju kustutas selle tegevuse käigus ära, et kui ta mergis, Ta küsis seda nuppu, Vaata, et kas sa tahad Delitida ma vaid, see on jah,
Õpetaja: siis On Nagu küsimus on see, et. Aga mul ju siin Lokalis on ikka ta alles.
Õpetaja: Mis ma sellega teen? Mul ei ole sellega midagi ära teha.
Õpetaja: Pole midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Lähen oma selle õpetaja peale ära ja ma kasutan kõik ebavajaliku staffi ära, et lõpptulemus peaks olema see, et, Noh, mul on kogemata jäänud. See õpetaja Feb neli siia. Seda ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Kustutan selle pilvest ära.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan koera. Kas mul juhuslikult on õpetaja Feb. Neli siin ka ei ole. Ee, Okei, kustutan selle ära.
Õpetaja: Siit ka. Kustutan kõik asjad ära, mida mul ei ole vaja. Siin Tegin mingisuguse haru Mingisuguse asja jaoks. Kustutan ära
Õpetaja: korrastust. Seda ma hoian alles Ee. Õpetaja. Viis lokal. Kustutan ära. Mul pole vaja seda
Õpetaja: Selle Ma jätan selle. Ma jätan selle, Ma jätan rohkem. Ma ei jäta nii. Master liikus edasi.
Õpetaja: Õpetaja liikus. Edasi.
Õpetaja: Siin vaatan ka, kas On veel midagi ebavajalikku? On ainult see üks minu oma.
Õpetaja: Fine.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see, mida me praegu tegime, see protsess. See on siis päriselt kuidas satuvad
Õpetaja: need. Ei, ei, me ei tee seda oma arvutist. Ee, kuidas teie oma projektidega toimetate? On väga okei. Kui te teete otse oma arvutis. Teil ei ole mõtet teha nagu seda
Õpetaja: nuppe klõbistada. Vaata, see ei anna teile praegu midagi. Noh, võite alguses korra mängida, asja ei ole näidanud, et lihtsalt tempo on peal. Vaata, kõik tahavad midagi teha. Vaata, selleks ei ole aega ja seal ei ole ka väga palju väärtust. Te saate seda niikuinii teha. Töö juures küll ja küll
Õpetaja: Ja ise. Ei pea eriti seal mingit nuppe väga hullult klõbistama, sest et Enamus keskkondades on kuidagi ära tehtud siirasse, või mis iganes, et
Õpetaja: ma ei teinud kunagi ühtegi läbi. Ee läbi arvuti
Õpetaja: siiras, Mingi nupp oli tehtud. Sul on haru.
Õpetaja: Tal oli nagu muinaks ära tehtud. See,
Õpetaja: Ee, Aga kui ka peab, siis midagi keerulist pole.
Õpetaja: Okei, no nii, mis Siis Järgmiseks.
Õpetaja: Mis siis ikka järgmiseks? Kui võtame, siis järgmise
Õpetaja: ja ikka.
Õpetaja: Oo,
Õpetaja: palun, toimub.
Õpetaja: Kui sa saad nagu seda
Õpetaja: küsimuse osalt, ära, siis Ma sain aru kuule alustama.
Õpetaja: Võibolla kuskilt jätkab nagu oma.
Õpetaja: Ei, selles mõttes, et päris tööprotsessis ongi. Selles mõttes, et vaata, kõik on üritatud teha niimoodi, et iseseisvalt, et mis on võimalik teha, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja et, ee, üks. Üks konkreetne arendusülesanne. Üks konkreetne.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kui sa nüüd selle ära vaatad, siis on niimoodi see, et see tiket pannakse kinni. Mida mul on ka vaja, teha on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, et see tiket niiöelda Minul. Ta oli in progress.
Õpetaja: Kas mul see on siin ees või ei ole?
Õpetaja: Panin ee, kogemata juba kinni jälle,
Õpetaja: et ee, et see on siis niimoodi, et sa teed selle taski. Ära. Sa paned selle haru, kustutad ära, taski paned ja sellisesse staatusesse, mis vaja, ehk siis Näiteks antud juhul on ta. Ee, on ju. Ja siis sa lihtsalt alustad järgmise arendusülesannega, kus on juba uus ticket.
Õpetaja: Vaata, see kaine nägu jäi vahele. Ära vaata. Aga Ütleme niimoodi, et ee, mingi hetk oleks siis vähemalt selle järgi selle protsessi järgi. Ta oleks pidanud olema interview
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui ta, ee. Keegi vaatas üle, mürtsisime selle ära. Siis ta on Done.
Õpetaja: Need need protsessi sammud on siis nagu Custom Custom Niiöelda seadistatud vastavalt siis sellele ettevõttele, kuidas nemad asju teevad
Õpetaja: ja päriselus ongi, Siis lihtsalt. Noh, ma panen järgmise asja enda nimele Näiteks proovime, ma Ei tea, kas ma kuskilt üles leian. Ee, võtan järgmise
Õpetaja: Ee asja ette.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis peaks olema siis? Ee, login.
Õpetaja: Ma korra lähen. Ee, Teisesse vaatesse on meist lihtsam. Mul ei ole nad seal. Board il ma. Kuna ma pidin taastama kõik need. Ee, nad ei ole päris Õiges järjekorras. Ee, aga järgmine asi peaks olema koos rolliga. Näete, ei ole, niimoodi. Et teil numbrid tulevad. Ee nagu päriselus. Seal järjest.
Õpetaja: Numbrid On niikuinii juba mingi sadades. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee. Niimoodi, et taas. Kuidas taasted tekivad?
Õpetaja: Noh, on siis nii öelda Analüütikud, näiteks kes siis Mingeid uusi asju teevad, aga ka arendajad ise saavad taas ka teha Näiteks seda. Vaata, et ee. Kuskil põrkasid kokku mingisuguse fugiga või mingi Klient kuskil kirjutas midagi, onju? Keegi uurib Natuke seda. Asja, et mis teema on, on ju.
Õpetaja: On vaja teha Nagu näiteks pugif taas kohata, Siis arendaja ise teeb ka, et siin mingi jama. Vaata, see on vaja korda teha praegult seda Mina ei tee praegult seda, Keegi ei tee, onju? Ja see läheb. Tiket on seal süsteemis olemas. Ta on rekorditud. Ta seal kuskil pikas nimekirjas on on ju mingil hetkel siis Keegi lihtsalt ohistab meid.
Õpetaja: Noh, kes teeb ja nii edasi? Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee, et taaske selles mõttes, ja et ei ole ainult, nagu, Noh, kui on struktuur, et analüütik kirjutab nagu taaske Aga taaske, kirjutavad ka arendaja.
Õpetaja: No näiteks, see Lhv S oligi Lhv Sai meil Niukene. Oi, see oli väga juba.
Õpetaja: See oli siis rotatsiooni korras. Niiöelda kõikide arendajate vahel oli siis niimoodi, et kui sina, olid ee, kui Sinu nädal tulid, siis sa olid nädal aega Niuke, põrgataja ja põrgataja roll tähendas seda, et meil, oli üks Niukene Ee, kindel, niiöelda email, Kuhu Kelle emaili boks? Kuhu kõigil oli ligipääs.
Õpetaja: Ja siis kui Aa. Kas me support inimestel või mingid otsepöördumised ka vahel? Igasugused probleemid asjad endas ühte postkainstein
Õpetaja: Ülesanne oli Siis see asi ülesse tikkida, Vaadata Sinna sisse, saada aru. Vaata, mis süsteemiga see üldse On Ee, kas on Mingi mobiilivärk. Kas on mingi front? I värk? Kas see on mingi payments? Mingi rakendus. Mingi makserakenduse teema seal nagu variant oli, kuhu see Võis kuuluda. Vaata,
Õpetaja: siis oli vaja aru saada, et kas see on Niuke asi, mida mina ise oskan. Nagu ära diagnoosida ja korda teha, On See mingi niukene asi, mis kuulub kellegi teise pädevusse. Vaata, et on vaja Nagu Suunata onju kellelegi. Ee, seda ee, nagu töö töölõiku
Õpetaja: kunagi Ei olnud see asi nii lihtne ka. Vaata, sest et, ee, igasugused ee, Igasugused toredad asjad nagu ligipääs andmebaasile oli üsna nagu limiteeritud Ee eriliste inimeste vahel. Ee, ei soovi keegi pangas, et absoluutselt kõik saavad minna ja vaadata
Õpetaja: pangasüsteemis andmebaasi andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis ee minul näiteks Ja põhimõtteliselt ka enamus teistel ei olnud üldse niukest võimalust, et saab jooksutada andmebaasi päris live andmebaasi osta
Õpetaja: Noh, muidu, ma hakkaks kohe Vaatama, et. Aa, kuidas ma eksin läheb? On ju, et. Ee. On ju, et seda asja nagu vältida. Vaata, on ju, et ee, siis, ee, Sa pidid neid asju niimoodi diagnoosima, et sul olid nagu oli see, et sa ei saanud andmebaasilegi ligi
Õpetaja: Väga rõve. Mingi logifail jookseb mingeid Sessiooni Id Dega. See oli see. Oli. Niimoodi mõtled? Vaata, sa nägid, et rotatsioon oli keskeltläbi. Kuskil kolmkümmend kuud võttis aega, kuni sa jõudis Sinuni sa juba seal lõpus juba hakkad vaatama. Oh, my God. Neli nädalat veel.
Õpetaja: Ee, see ei ole üldse lõbus. Lõbus roll.
Õpetaja: Ja see oligi niimoodi. Vaata, siis oli see, et sa pidid. Meil oli üks eraldi kanal. Vaata, kus sa võisid. Siis põhimõtteliselt lausa niiöelda, Ma ütlen, Kujuta ette sul probleem. Võibolla mis iganes
Õpetaja: pangas ei ole ainult makse, et seal on mingi rämedalt asju nagu rämedalt, on ju igasuguseid, asju et See võib tulla mis tahes nurga pealt. Noh, see minu domeeni üldse ei puuduta. Ja see on nagu see.
Õpetaja: Palun uurige ise, onju, Aga vahel oli. Vahel olid siuksed ka nagu niuksed, hallid alad, Nagu, et. Noh, see võid selle kellegile ära põrgatada, aga kind see teine pool. Võiks öelda, et sa võid seda isu uurida. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga siis oli niuke kanal, kuhu said panna Scr päringuid ja öelda et Kuule, palun, kas keegi ee, annaks? Noh, siis oli nagu mingi kontroll. Vähemalt et
Õpetaja: seal ei olnud mingi, et keegi, ei tule mingi insertlausega, Vaata, et pane endale papi juurde. Aa, by the way see. Oli nii uhke tunne kui, ma lhv s Alustasin ma. Olin ise lhv klient. Vaata, et kui äge oli lokaalselt jooksutada seda internetipanka enda arvutis ja siis on see, et
Õpetaja: paneks endale mingi veel ühe miljardi, korda Et selles mõttes, et Screenshot i said jagada ilma eriti. Noh, eriti. Vaata, et näed, mul on päris palju raha, Vaata, et naisele saatsin, et. Aga, noh, me lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: niimoodi visuaalselt on nagu Lhv. Kuradi internetilehekülg. Täpselt nii nagu näeksid seda Online ainult numbrid on jah, ja Ei, ma arvan. Ee. Seal natuke teistmoodi käivad need andmed, mida vahetatakse. Aga võibolla jah, miks mitte,
Õpetaja: eks? Alates on fakeida.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, loogingus Rolliga on siis meie järgmine Niiöelda präänik. Jah,
Õpetaja: ma vaatasin. Tiinal on ee, käsi püsti, aga ta hoopis sügav oma juukse eest Ei, ole, Noh,
Õpetaja: mhmh endasse.
Õpetaja: Jah, täpselt. Et Jah, Sest et praegult ei teinud seda ma Nüüd ma täiesti ruttu teen. Vaata uuesti, onju Ma teen õpetajast New Branch, et te saaksite vaadata. Ütleme, et see on siis
Õpetaja: ee. Viis oli, onju see viimane error vaade. No ma teen mingi Mõttetu muudatuse.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuskil. Ee, Panen lihtsalt mingi ühe tühiku või mida iganes teen siit lihtsalt ühe uue
Õpetaja: B viis Complete. Ee, Noh, isegi pole tegelikult Bush ide otseselt vaja. Merging ju nüüd enda arvutis
Õpetaja: miinimum. Ära tegema ehk siis, kuidas teie saate oma tehtud töö? Nüüd sinna. Ja kuidas te nüüd hakkate tiimitöödena tegema? Ja nüüd kujutage ette, et teie nimi on. Noh, teie nimi on teie tiimi, Master, Ee, kõik on. Ära Commit itud. Ee, siis mis te teete? Teete. Te lähete Masteri peale? Checkout.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, mitte Masteri peale Näed. Juba läks, Õpetaja. Ja teie ärge tulge. Õpetaja, Ärge tehke John Smith i värki. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, minge oma haru peale. Ja nüüd on niimoodi, et Siis te lähete, otsite oma arenduse haaru sealt lokali pealt ülesse
Õpetaja: ja panete Merch. Ja see on see koht kus tõmbate pidurit ja loete selle, et. Kas see Does It make? Sense Merch. Õpetaja Feb Into õpetaja. Noh, päriselus. Merch Faeb. Viis into, master,
Õpetaja: aga päriselus Masters ei Saa Aga teie oma tiimi projektides hakkate seda tegema.
Õpetaja: Nii et aitad, et okei.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta peaks ütlema, et kõik läks. Pange tähele, Mis ta, Intelly siia nüüd soovitab? Ta ütleb siin all, et ta mööl siis selle arenduse aru Masterisse ära, mis ta pakub
Õpetaja: ja et Kustuta oma lokaalne haru. Ära vaata ma. Hästi, Ruttu. Korra. Push in. Siin taustal välja.
Õpetaja: Ma push in taustal välja selle ee vie, et oleks pilves ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea, kas ma saan seda siit seda veel näidet võtta. Nii see sama kastikene, mis eest ära läks, On ju, et ta Niipea, kui sa kustutasid lokaalse ära vaata. Ee, siis, kui ma vajutan, et kustuta ära see lokaalne haru
Õpetaja: ta kustutab selle ära. Ja nüüd, mida ta paremal pool pakub.
Õpetaja: No, see oli siin vasakul. Pool on ju paremal pool. Ta pakub delete
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et See kõik see töö on ära merchitud. Tähendab, tema mõte on pigem praegu see, et sa kustutasid lokaalse haaru ära, Aga kas sul siis On seda vaja või mitte? Ei, ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kustutan ära, et näete, kuidas isegi see tööriista on Tegelikult see hügieen Ee sisse niiöelda protsessi pandud.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole vaja neid. Ee, neid lahtiseid harusid. Ee, nendega ei ole enam midagi teha,
Õpetaja: kui sul midagi on tõesti vaja, nüüd Iss Ise avastad järsku, et. Oi, tegelikult juba Kõik läks Masterisse. Ära Ise avastasin, et mingi väike pugi või asi, onju?
Õpetaja: Võta uus haru, Pane uuesti see sama taaski number, et ta. Ma ei oska just uus aru
Õpetaja: on ju Tee see väike puugi ja Fix, ära
Õpetaja: samamoodi testi, siis lähed, võtad testi alla, Näed, vaata siin puugi sees. Vaata, on ju mida iganes bla, blabla. Code Beauty vaatab üle. Keegi vaja Lihtsalt teed selle protsessi uuesti. Ära On ju, et Ei ole. Ühtegi põhjust, miks meil on vaja neid harusid. Nendega ei ole midagi teha,
Õpetaja: ei ole midagi teha. Nad tekitavad ainult segadust ja varem või hiljem mingisuguseid probleeme.
Õpetaja: Aga taas
Õpetaja: peaks ikka olema see sama task, või siis Sa võid panna. Sa võid ka midagi juurde kirjutada, kui tahad. Vaata, et arvad, et sa soovid näiteks seda kuidagi eristada. Jah,
Õpetaja: ei oleks Ka selles mõttes ta saab olla ka täpselt sama. Vaata sellepärast, et see vanane on ära kustutatud. Ei, see ei ole kedagi, vaata millega nagu onju. Ma ilmselt paneks ka midagi nihukest. Vaata, kui juhtub. No
Õpetaja: mul eriti niukest asja ei juhtunud. Aa ja, noh, kui juba hiljem avastatakse. Kui asjad on juba live läinud. Vaata, et, ee, niiöelda asjad on Live I läinud ja tuleb mingi pugi, siis lihtsalt tehakse niikuinii eraldi taas
Õpetaja: et. Noh, et avastasime vea, seda ei saa vaja korda teha. Kellegile määratakse, pannakse seal üks asi, mida ma siin ei ole rääkinud. On, See, et seal siiras on juurde juures ka tegelikult Level Id nagu Critical.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea, mis need teised on mingi väike viga. Vaata, et neid asju üritatakse ka niimoodi nagu jälgida. Ja. Ja siis ta. Noh, näiteks oli ka meil näiteks pugi mingi kriitiliste Pugif, mis nagu peab väga kiirelt jõudma, Olid ka võibolla mingid natuke teistsugused protsessid Vaata, kuidas see kiirelt live jõuab, Onju, et ta ei olnud mingi
Õpetaja: ee. Tavapärane flow, onju? No see on jälle ka vastavalt ettevõtte kultuuriga. Ja nagu protsessidega, on võib olla nagu erinev.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea, kas teeme siis väikse pausi. Aa, ja siis hakkame pärast selle uue asjaga. Ja Siis mis kellani me pidime kütma kas. Oli Kaksteist nelikümmend viis.
Õpetaja: Aa, kaksteist, nelikümmend. Okei,
Õpetaja: või valida näiteks. Ja siis ta annab valikusse menüüsse. Need, Ee, erinevad ja nii edasi, et ee, Mis seal vahed on?
Õpetaja: Üks on merge ja siis on oluline Intu.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui sa mõtled näiteks, et. No mul ei ole ühtegi, mul ei ole seda haru. Praegu Õpetaja ühiskond.
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole enam selles. Ma kustutasin ära Selle
Õpetaja: ma võtan Mistahes arust Sa tahad küsida küsimusi, Lihtsalt onju?
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd võtame näiteks õpetaja või siis
Õpetaja: pean ma ütlema, et ma ei ole kunagi neid kasutanud. Ma ei tea, mis Nad teevad,
Õpetaja: Kas seal taustal on sama protsess. Põhimõtteliselt mu vastus on endiselt see, sama, et Ma ei tea, ma ei ole kunagi neid kasutanud.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, et ma ei tea nagu, Sest et siin ma ütlen, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, kurat, ma ei tea, Ma ei tea Tõesti, ma.
Õpetaja: Siin on ilmas.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: No teeme, teeme siis. Ma vastan su küsimusele. Aga ma vastan su küsimusele väga Modernselt. Teeme niimoodi väike Screenshot.
Õpetaja: Väike screenshot. Ja see siin.
Õpetaja: Nüüd korra. Paint. Teeme pain I ka lahti. Ee, paint paint, pain, paint, Paint Nii,
Õpetaja: Nii, ma panen korra suurele ekraanile.
Õpetaja: Paint Crop Kastikesed.
Õpetaja: Ee, need siin on ju versus see vä.
Õpetaja: Oota, võtame siis. Ee, Võtame siis konkreetselt. Merch, I vaata, Onju, niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Võtame selle pildi, Nii siis võtame tagasi. Cloud Code.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaja üks väikene trikk vaja teada. Vaata et Control V. Vaata, Ma Just, Coop Isin pildi. Control V ei tööta. Kui tahad pilti copida. Kas see Cloudis või või Kodexis, siis on alt V.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, ma kü võin. Küsidays
Õpetaja: Mis, On nende kahe valiku vahe altre
Õpetaja: Noh. Alt, v noh.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ta, näitab et, pilt läks kaasa
Õpetaja: midagi Pea peast või ei Pea, Ma ei ole kokku puutunud. Vaata,
Õpetaja: see on ilmselt sellise kontekst, kus sina parasjagu õpetaja haru peal tšekkavad parem Klõpsu. See ütleb otse sõnu, et too karu muudatused sisse praeguse opeta arusse. See on üks konkreetne Merch Operation täpselt nende kahe haru vahel, Mille peal sa parema klõpsu tegid?
Õpetaja: Pull into, õpetaja. Using Merch. See on üldisem käsk, Fetch, Praeguse räägi maalähedaselt.
Õpetaja: Selge Kitsamad
Õpetaja: veel lihtsamalt vähem, Jeppi vist.
Õpetaja: Tere,
Õpetaja: nii, Vot. Nüüd juba vaata. Merge toob Karli töö. Sinu harusse. See teine variant uuendab sinu enda. Haru Karliga pole pistmist. Tahad Karli tööd? Tahad Karli tööd? Vali esimene, palun. Väga. Üks ei ei ole Mersi, mitte mingil mu kujul, vaid lihtsalt uuendab
Õpetaja: seda haru Mis iganes pilves on, uuendab sinu selles
Õpetaja: Local Director is. Niimoodi sain mina aru.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: jah.
Õpetaja: Ta on nii hea. Konkreetne. Jah,
Õpetaja: tegelt ma Tahtsin Kohe seda, aga ta ei saanud aru. Vaata,
Õpetaja: nüüd teen selle. Merch, I, ära vaata. Ei, ära hakka jamama. Ta teeks minu eest seda ka. Kuulge, teeme nüüd siis selle reklaamitud pausi ja tuleme tagasi. Ma panen nüüd recording u ka siis pausile.
Õpetaja: Ee, et see ei Ununeks Jah,
Õpetaja: ee. Paneme Screenshare i ka peale. Lähme siis ikkagi. Feb kuuega. See on nii väike samm ja teeme siis selles järjekorras, kus ma kunagi. Teda nagu ette nagu enamvähem Nägin.
Õpetaja: Ee, veb. Kuus on nüüd maailma kõige lihtsam Staff. Jälle. Pangaautomaatide vaade.
Õpetaja: Ee, peab reageerima Atm S. Ee, niiöelda Urlile.
Õpetaja: Komponendi nimi on Atms View.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on natukene midagi uut ka. Löö loomenüüsse ka vastav link nimega Pangaautomaadid. Mis Siis läheb sellele aadressile Lisa juurde pangaautomaadid.
Õpetaja: Noh, niuke, väga lihtne. Taas saame siin natukene kordu korduvalt harjutada neid samu võtteid, millest alustame?
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah, Võtame enda nimest uue Brunchi.
Õpetaja: Mis balanssi nimeks läheb?
Õpetaja: Jääb koos Teeme selle,
Õpetaja: kui vaadata neid samme loo. Uus vaatekomponent Noh, mm, läheme Lihtsalt Frontis.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt teeme parema klõpsu ja uue komponent
Õpetaja: nimeks. Läheb. Mis ta siin kirjas oli?
Õpetaja: Ee, see nüüd ka üldse pole sellest rääkinud, Aga näete, vaata faili nimesse. Paneme mingi ekstra sõna juurde.
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, see on ka Niukene. Ee, niiöelda siis ee, kontseptsioon et ee,
Õpetaja: et Mõningates kohtades on hea panna neid mingeid ekstra sõna juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis siis kuidagi defineerivad mingisugust gruppi.
Õpetaja: Nii ad
Õpetaja: selle template bloki sisse, No Tegelikult jätame ta tühjaks. Kohe tuleb siia niikuinii midagi muud. Aga seda Style. Saadame pensionile,
Õpetaja: kui me vaatame seda, et meil on vaja teha Ee, sellist. Ee. Headerit. Niimoodi sellisel kujul
Õpetaja: ja ka garanteerida, et meil on mingi meie enda soovitud paigutus. Siis esimene mõte on.
Õpetaja: Noh, võtke ta endale kuskil lahti. Kui ta Tabiga juba on lahti või vajutage seda favorites. I,
Õpetaja: mis läheb siis sinna?
Õpetaja: Vana, hea copy. Lihtsalt copy.
Õpetaja: Panemegi lihtsalt selle template sisse meelde. Tuletuseks jälle. Vaata, template on siis selle lehe nähtav osa,
Õpetaja: et ainult siin selles ee sektsioonis me saame seda mõjutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, skripti osa on siis kogu ülejäänud muu Ee funktsionaalsuse Kogu see teema.
Õpetaja: No siin, me võime ka samamoodi teha, et need Kaks kolumnit. Saadame kohe pensionile.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd selle kolumi Sisse Ee, selle kolumi enda. Kustutame ära lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ja siis oli, et siia peaks tulema Niukene pealkiri, pangaautomaadid, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Aeg näiteks H. Üks. Ja siis kirjutab siia panga automaadid.
Õpetaja: Eile aasta Noh, Ei, viitsi ma seda isegi Vaadata Pealt ei olegi midagi vaadata.
Õpetaja: Miks ei ole praegu midagi vaadata, kui ma tahaks vaadata, et. Oo, kas ma nüüd näen seda pangaautomaadi,
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole seda raudtee. Jah, et me peame tegema teekonna.
Õpetaja: Peame tegema teekonna sellelt urlilt sellele komponendile, et tuleme siia router indeksisse, Jällegi Võtame siit alt niimoodi
Õpetaja: suht mugavalt. Selekteerime selle viimase bloki ja paneme Control D.
Õpetaja: Siin vist oli öeldud siis, et ee, kaldkriips Htms peaks olema see, mille peale ta reageerib.
Õpetaja: Nii siis selle ruudi nimeks võiks öelda, et ta on
Õpetaja: selle Error View Niimoodi kustutame siin ära
Õpetaja: noh, Mis võiks olla need kaks suurt tähte?
Õpetaja: Av Atms View. Loodame, et aivaril ka ikka pakub. Seda pakub väga hea
Õpetaja: tabiga. Valime, miks valime, Selle Tab iga siit niimoodi. Miks me ei taha kirjutada lihtsalt seda välja?
Õpetaja: Import, onju? Kui ma Scrollin siia ülesse poole, vaatan rida neli, Vaid ta on Tab.
Õpetaja: Põlliimport.
Õpetaja: Roheline tähendab uut tipp. Habis
Õpetaja: tuli uus osa. Näed, et siin sai tellid? See ka Aitab Trackida meile, et Mis meil siin toimub?
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siis öeldakse seda, et ee, loomenüüsse ka vastav link nimega pangaautomaadid.
Õpetaja: Kellegil on meeles, et kuhu faili me Nüüd siis peame minema. Et kus me toimetame?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult me räägime praegu ka enda. Nagu nendest oranžidest kaantest. Vaata, et igal lehel on see Navigatsiooni menüü nähtav vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kus File S. Peaks toimetama?
Õpetaja: Poe, Vaata see fail Aga lihtsalt väike meeldetuletus, et et tegelikult taustal. Vaata, nagu Nagu mingi. Mingi osa kaantest. Niiöelda põhiosa kaantest tuleb indeks. Atml ist
Õpetaja: on ju kogu see osa ja ülejäänud osa siin. All aga näete, Vaata, vahepealne osa. Selle Võtame Id äpp. See on nüüd siis on. See on nüüd selle raamistiku enda niiöelda mingi Coinfi seadistus, mis põhimõtteliselt Ütleb, et ülejäänud osa tuleb siit.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ongi meil need asjad.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin navigatsiooni menüü. Noh, kui ma tõmban siit selle realt Kaks kokku näed, on navigatsiooni menüü ja ülejäänud osa tuleb lihtsalt vastavalt Urlile Ruuterview.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis meil on navigatsioonimäe menüü ja ülejäänud osa tuleb Ee, juba sellest
Õpetaja: vastavalt vaatajale, et kui on kodu või mis iganes. Ja nüüd plaan ongi see, et hetkel on siin kaks linki, on Siin see kodulink mis on nagu Niukene pank
Õpetaja: kodu. Need on tegelikult viivad ühte samasse Goota, aga siia kõrvale tahame tehta ühte uut linki.
Õpetaja: Ma kujutan see navigatsiooni menüü lahti.
Õpetaja: Näete seda osa siin? Routerlink. Kodu, mis me siin tahame teha?
Õpetaja: Tublike saab. Tubli, Käid ja Control D, Mis me siin muudame
Õpetaja: ja Et kuhu, kuhu see link peab viima? Meil oli siin taskis öeldus, et vaata. Ems
Õpetaja: nimi oli, mis meil Taskis oli öeldud pangaautomaadid
Õpetaja: Kuidas seda selektida Niimoodi, et ma ei peaks niimoodi siin hakkama? Mingi kustutama
Õpetaja: ei Näe Mõtlesite seda sama Contra? Kaks Isv panga, automaadid.
Õpetaja: Nii, noh, nüüd justkui nagu võiks olla nagu kõik klotsid paigas, et peaks olema meil. See menüü tuli Pangaautomaadid
Õpetaja: tuli, kui Klikib peale, läheb sinna vaatesse.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ütlengi. Ega siin teadlikult oligi. Niimoodi. Väikestel tükkidel on disainitud, et Noh, midagi siin ei olnud, onju, Aga et lihtsalt. Me saaksime natukene korduvalt harjutada. Vaata neid võtteid, et uus vaade ja nii edasi. Lähme sinna vaatesse endasse, ka, onju? Vaatame, korra. Kas korra vaataks üle, on ju?
Õpetaja: Jah, ee, on kenasti. Selle konteineri sees saab siin Paigutust teha pole põhimõtteliselt siin enam ööd ega mütsi teha, et
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt selle taskiga, siis võib öelda. Oh in progress vä. Kas ma jõudsin tõesti panna? Isegi
Õpetaja: ta ise Sai sellest aru, Praegu, et pane interview.
Õpetaja: Vaatame üle, Töötab, testime Ise töötab.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis vist. Ee, Võib ära commitida. Te
Õpetaja: mis ma siia nüüd on See Jälle ka, et te saate tegelikult kommitimise hetkel ise valida, Mida kommititakse. Vahel ongi nii. Sa teed mingisugust portsu tööd. Vaata aga, sa tahad nad eraldi ära commitida, Et mingid asjad on Võibolla veidi poolikud. Võibolla või mis? Iganes
Õpetaja: Ee, et sa Või on sul mingi ekstra fail siin. Mida sa ei taha üldse Nagu kaasa, panna et see komitee kuulub selle haru kohta, mille peal oled. Ja need failid, mis on Selected siin. Soovime loomulikult kõiki neid faile.
Õpetaja: Siis võiks siin kirjutada Feb kuus Compliit. Mingisugune viisakas sõnum ka
Õpetaja: nüüd, mis puudutab üldse sõnumitesse. No Ma teen selle kom. Ee. Siin Panen käima samal ajal kui ma.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Need sõnumid võiksid olla nagu enamvähem niuksed, ikka päris Päriselus nagu Meaningfall. Ma siin vahepeal, kui teen, järjest ka mitte. Ja selle jaoks, et keegi saaks järgi tulla, ma lihtsalt teen Work in Progress, üks ja kaks ja kolm.
Õpetaja: No Kui ikkagi lisad mingi konkreetse funktsionaalsuse või teed mingisuguse osa Ära vaata, siis Tegelikult on mõistlik ikkagi panna sinna mingi kasvõi paar sõna vaatama, mis enam vähem annavad. Aimu, et mis selles komitees toimus,
Õpetaja: ei ole mõtet mingit kirjutada ja detail kirjutada. Vaata, et kirjutasin, sinna. Et Kui on If sees mingisugune see väärtus või. Ja siis siis oleks mõtet. See on nagu mõttetu aeg,
Õpetaja: Pealegi, ega eriti ei viitsigi komite teha. Mina teen kogu aeg Nüüd juba ammu. Ilma Cloud. Iga Cloud Il olen nagu instrueerinud. Vaata, et Palun lihtsalt vaata. Ee, selle sisu pealt, et proovi Niukene Eestikeelne tekst. Meaningfall. Bla, blabla. Võta nagu ise. Pane ise sealt nagu need sõnumid, Ma ei viitsi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Pole vaja
Õpetaja: Aga päriselus siis Jah, nagu see oli ka. Ma nägin nagu töökeskkondades, nagu kahte koolkonda olid üldiselt need, Kes olid mingi ülihoolsad? Olid need, kellel ülikama? Nagu et panedki mingi asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja ma mäletan, ah Noorena ma õudsalt kartsin, seda ka, mul oli niimoodi, et kui ma bussisin, panin mingi imeliku sõna. Või Kood oli poolikas ja niimoodi. Oh, my god, Oh, my God, Keegi nüüd näeb. Vaata, et ma midagi tegin seal. Vaata, et kõik keegi käib ja vaatab minuga, mitte et mis ma teinud olen,
Õpetaja: kellelgi ei ole sellist aega töökeskkonnas, et lihtsalt minna ja isegi ülemusel või mida iganes,
Õpetaja: keegi ei käi neid vaatamas nagu sellisel mõjul, huvitab ta ainult see hetk. Vaata, kui asi läheb Code Reviews, onju,
Õpetaja: siis hakkab alles teistel. Huvi tekkima selles osas, sest et sa ütled et nüüd, see on valmis, et ma tegin ka seda, et ma ei tahtnud Push Ida väga nagu pilve. Vaata, kui pilti see rämedalt, kui mitte enda arvutis Aga neid pilve. Keegi näeb, et ma tegelikult Jumala hullult. Mingi pimeduses kompan seal. Üritan leida Mingid toimivad lahendused,
Õpetaja: et ma nagu, ei, et ma kumpan ja ma teen siin mingi koledaid asju. Võibolla onju, et mis nagu, ei ole see lõpptulemus.
Õpetaja: Nobody Cash.
Õpetaja: Ee, see nüüd sai tehtud Aga nüüd on see, et ta on ju meie enda harus. Aga peaks jõudma.
Õpetaja: Kuidas nüüd see protsess välja näeb? Mis me Teeme merge. Vahetame haru. Ütles Fred.
Õpetaja: Läheme siis selle Masteri peale? Checkout
Õpetaja: siin Tähtis. Asi on nüüd päris tiimitöödes on teha. Fetch,
Õpetaja: miks, Sest et Kuidas te teate, et kas see on midagi vahepeal juurde tulnud või mitte?
Õpetaja: Te hakkate kohe kohe Merch Ima midagi. Vaata, see. See On väga vastik, kui seal. Tegelikult sa ei ole teadlik, et seal taustal on mingid muudatused, et sinu masin hakkab tegema justkui kommit I Vaata, on ju Aga seal tegelikult on keegi teine mingit tööd teinud. Ja võibolla mingid failid või vaid alati on parem olla teadlik. Vaata, Et et kas
Õpetaja: kui sa näed, et seal ühtegi kommitti ei ole, ei ole juurde tulnud, et ta ei näita, et midagi juurde tulnud, Siis sa, tead et sinu. See Merch läheb nagu ilma probleemideta kindlalt läbi. Miks? Sest algseis on endiselt see sama, et ei saa tulla mingit konflikti. No tead, sa võid rahulikult seda vajutada. Seda nuppu on ju,
Õpetaja: et, Ee ei ole üldse. Siin saab mingid autofetši ka peale panna, aga ma ei tea, kuidas ta käitub. Nagu et mis hetkel ta nagu seda teeb.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta ei, tee minu meelest seda nagu Mingi iga mingi viie sekundi tagant. Vaid võibolla siis, kui sa mingi nupa vajutad, ta teeb taustal. Ma täpselt ei tea,
Õpetaja: kus seda üldse peale saab panna, võiks panna tegelikult peale. Ja Settings.
Õpetaja: Ee, auto. Fedge krüptoglal. Fetch.
Õpetaja: See Kit I all võiks olla. Kuskil. On ju automatically?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea täpselt, mida see, millal ta seda teeb. Aga tundub suht mõistlik asi mida, peale panna
Õpetaja: ma pakun et, on ikkagi see et Kui sa teed näiteks, mingi, siis ta teeb äkki kuidagi nendel hetkedel, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma arvan,
Õpetaja: Miks saab silma peal hoida ee siis olen selle haru peal. See on jällegi see värk. Vaata, et kogu kogu tööde nii öelda. Liigutamine toimub alati full suunas, et me ei saa lükata asju
Õpetaja: kuhugi teise arusse, et me saame tõmmata teisest arust tööd enda arusse
Õpetaja: ja alati, kui tulete selle Merch I peale, siis see On see koht, kus korra Nagu siis vaadake. Jälle. Vaata, kas see kõnetab Mind Veeb seitse. Into Master Kuus. Vabandust, jah, soovin. Soovin
Õpetaja: Merch Match Match.
Õpetaja: Mis ta vasakul pakub?
Õpetaja: Kustuta ära arenduse. See aru tahab, et remote ist ka ära kustutada. Davai Lets Go
Õpetaja: Näete küsib üle, Miks ta üle küsib? Punane Joon ohtlik.
Õpetaja: Kas sa oled kindel? Jah, olen küll kindel
Õpetaja: Mm, üks asi, mida nüüd otsa ei teinud,
Õpetaja: Mida, Mis on, mis sammu on veel vaja teha
Õpetaja: Masteris Ee. Mingi omatehtud töö. Kõik läks ilusti läbi. Kustutasid vanad harud ära.
Õpetaja: Aga mis on veel, Push? Ida. On vaja ta seda automaatselt ei tee. Miks, miks ta ei tee automaatselt Push I, Sul on veel võimalus
Õpetaja: teha lokaalselt asju korda kui midagi läheks valesti. Ma ütlesin siit mingi valaharu. Või Mida iganes tegin, midagi vokaalselt on üli tšillipilli seal, nagu asju, teha
Õpetaja: seda ta ise automaatselt ei tee. Aga tiimiliikmed ju Ei, saa seda ju kuidagi endale ka.
Õpetaja: Mida nüüd tiimiliikmed praegu teeksid?
Õpetaja: Tiimiliikmed teeksid nüüd Vastupidise protsessi. Ütleme, et te push ite välja Ma korra mängin seda korra, mängin seda,
Õpetaja: panen. Ee ma teen korra. Päris Masteris. Teen ühe Niiöelda tempo. Aro,
Õpetaja: ma ütlen korra, Ma t Usa aru, ajutine.
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette, et minu tiimiliige. Vaata, temal on oma haru, Tema on nüüd ju maas, onju? Õpetaja on kõvasti edasi läinud. Master on ju kogu aeg paigal olnud. Mina võtsin Masterdit ka et uue haru
Õpetaja: nüüd kui Minul on näiteks oma tööharu. Ma teen. Ma toimetan mingisuguse asja kallal. Ma teen oma mingit arendust, aga mu tiimi liige Push, Is midagi Masterisse. Päeva lõpuks pean mina niikuinii oma töö Push Ima. Niiöelda sinna Masterisse. Ma teenin mingit asja, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nii Aga nüüd on niimoodi. Vaata, et nüüd võib olla juhus. Vaata, et et siis, kui ma hakkaksin seda liigutust tegema, tuleb konflikt
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kui mina võtsin ee Masteris seisu, siis mingi fail oli muutumata. Aga nüüd on see muutunud.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on point. On see. Vaata, mida peaks. Nüüd tegema on See, vaata, et tiimi liige peaks nüüd hoopis enda arendusharusse. Et Las siis olla kõik, mis on Masteris ka minu arus,
Õpetaja: ja kui nüüd on mingisugune konflikt. Vaata sellel liigutusel. Vaata, et ma tahan võtta kõik, mis on Masteris ka endale, on ju
Õpetaja: siis see konfliktub kohe välja, ma Saan kohe sellega tegeleda.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis mina hoian, nagu ma teen oma arendust. Aga ma üritan hoida ennast Masteriga samal joonel,
Õpetaja: sest et Kui ma teen seda, et ütleme niimoodi. See vahe ongi see. Vaata, kujutame ette. Vaata, kui. Kui ma ei tee seda liigutust, ma muudkui kütan Edasi mul. Läheb aega ma. Mingi rabelen mingisuguse ülesandega ja nii edasi on. Ju
Õpetaja: et, vahepeal mörsib üks inimene sinna midagi teine. Inimene Kolmas, mida iganes on ju Mersivad mörsivad. Vaata, onju siis ühel hetkel. Noh, tiimiliikmed, et ühel hetkel, kui ma tahan enda tööd sinna push Ida on neid konflikte lihtsalt juba niivõrd palju.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on nagu natukene ka keerulisem. Võibolla nagu aru saada, et mis, ma pean tegema, Kuigi ma ütlen, siin on üks ülilollikindlussüsteem, mida tuleb jälgida. Ja Merch konflikti lahendamine on Ee, lapse mäng
Õpetaja: mooles.
Õpetaja: Aga see aitaks praegult. Noh, Ee, siin on väga suur. Ja see teadmine on ka mõnus. Vaata, nagu et kui konflikte ei tule, et me samades failides ei toimeta, Kui ma nüüd praegu. Lähen. Näiteks, et ma tegin selle Masteri pealt, Tegin ajutise. See on ju õpetajast maas. Mina toimetan nagu selles arus.
Õpetaja: Mina lihtsalt lähen. Nüüd võtan Masterilt Ad juurde. Hetkel peaks ka kõik automaatselt toimima, Sest mingit konflikte ei saa olla. Ma üksinda toimetan,
Õpetaja: see Nagu Praegu ei ole teil väga meeningfall. Siis kui te hakkate tööd tegema. Ma juhendan teid niikuinii uuesti. Vaata, Ee, et seda teeksite aga Põhiline asi on hästi lihtne. Kui keegi tiimi liikmetest teeb mingisuguse arenduse, mis ta loeb, et ta on valmis ja ta lükkab selle masterisse, Siis Teised, kes teevad tööd oma projekti kallal teevad korraks ära endale ühe
Õpetaja: ja lihtsalt võtavad selle uue asja ka enda alusse,
Õpetaja: et et Siis on sama seis. Kõik on samal lehel. Kui tulevad mingid konfliktid, siis sa lahendad selle konflikti. Niiöelda seal enda arvutis ära,
Õpetaja: saad need uuendused sisse. Ja nüüd, kui nii öelda tahad enda tööd tagasi Fush Ida sinna Masterisse, onju või möö seda Masterisse, siis siis ei ole Nagu seda seisu. Vaata, et Masteris on mingis failis Mingid muudatused, mida sinul pole. Sest sa just tõmbasid need sisse, Seda on praegu keeruline aru saada Kui ma lihtsalt jäpin siin.
Õpetaja: Kui te jõuate tiimitöödeni, siis see muutub natukene rohkem Meening for iks. Me saame seda harjutada ja Mingi hetk me võtame ette ka aa konfliktide lahendamise. Me tekitame mingeid konflikte ja ma õpetan, kuidas asju teha, aga me teeme seda jaavas. Ma ei taha seda teha. Frondis. Mulle ei meeldib Frondis seda teha.
Õpetaja: See on. Teil on ka keeruline javas. On ee, asi nagu palju Lihtsam Frontis Siin Selles voes on meil nii palju liikuvaid osi. Ee, palju palju nagu kirjuma on. Kogu see Staff
Õpetaja: Aa java on nagu Selles mõttes siin ongi see, et. Ee, siin täna võib olla nagu mingid inimesed, kes mõtlevad Oo, nii. Tore on see front? Vaata, näed Mingeid kastikesi ja asju ja tšillipilli, et nagu lahe on, Ma olen kindel. Mulle meeldib front rohkem kui
Õpetaja: Lähete Backendi saate aru alguses seal Ei ole nagu, väga midagi näha, nagu kogu aeg. Ee, kahjuks. Ee, aga seal on, niimoodi et Seal on tegelikult palju suurem Niukene, konkreetne Struktuur ja ülesehitus. Hästi konkreetne.
Õpetaja: Ee, et austajad tekivad siis ka kohe.
Õpetaja: Ma lõpus. Ikka alati. Küsin niikuinii temade päeval ka kõige käest, et nagu, Noh, kuidas tunne on siis? Kas nagu Front way Back või mõlemad et, kuidas nagu meeldib
Õpetaja: ee? Et, tulevad oma seda isegi siin Nagu progemise käigus. Juba näed ka vaikselt, et. Ee. Ühel alguses tundub See back. Võibolla väga keeruline ja segane, aga siis, kui lõpuks hakkad läbi hammustama, siis saad aru, et tegelikult see on päris äge.
Õpetaja: Nii, lähme tagasi Checkout. Õpetaja, mina vä.
Õpetaja: No jaa, ma olen Ter. Noh, Hea, Mul on alati backmed. Ma pole frontiarendust teinud. Ei Mina viitsiks mingeid kastikesi paika loksutada. Et Mingid pikslid on paigast ära ja ei saa aru.
Õpetaja: Ei, jaa, ei, tähendab, noh, mul on ikka õpetamise käigus. Sa hakkad meeldima ja mul nagu üle vaadata. Niimoodi mulle meeldib Fronti teha. Vaata ka, et front on ka tegelikult äge,
Õpetaja: aga. Aga ma ise ei ole Productionis kunagi töötanud, siis mul võibolla nagu nii suurt Armastust ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teine asi on see, et mul ei ole seda ilumeelt. Näiteks kui ma pean mingeid veebilehted olema, siis mul tulevad Niuksed nagu niuksed. Funktsionaalsed. Ütleme niimoodi, et nad töötavad. Kõik on Tip Top olemas, aga mingit silmailu nagu minu nagu nendelt lehtedelt ei leia, On ju, et
Õpetaja: mul ei ole nagu seda kunsti meelt nüüd käest.
Õpetaja: Vot see on ka oskus. Tegelikult nagu igast värvid ja asjad ja asetused ja üldse nagu mõtlemine, Et kuidas võiks olla, et see on ka Niukene? Ee, põnev asi, mida tahaks osata, Ilmselt on seda võimalik ka mingil kujul õppida.
Õpetaja: Aga Jah, ta natukene niukse kunstilise ee, kalduvusega Ole Ja selle ajutise. Ma kustutan ära selle ma saadan pensionile,
Õpetaja: lähme edasi. Ee, selle ma panen inreuse. Panen. Dun i.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, lähen Vaatan, Korda siis frontend pangast. Lähen vaatan Boardi, Mis on järgmine? Mul ei ole järjekorda niikuinii pandud, aga see ee, numbrite järgi tuleb siis kontrolliga.
Õpetaja: See. Mul on kogemata läinud in progress.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ma tahtsin seda tõsta. Vaatame see. Nüüd on esimene nagu Niukene Rohkem Meaningfall. Ee, taas Ka siin on veits rohkem lugemist.
Õpetaja: Esimene kord, kus ee mainitakse üldse Andmebaasi mudelit. Login koos rolliga andmebaasi. Mudel siin taskis, mängivad rolli, tabelid user ja role Ee, kes on selliste diagrammidega tuttav käsi püsti.
Õpetaja: Noh, Kaks, kolm on on ju. Vaatame seda ka. Kohe.
Õpetaja: Ee, loo sisse. Logimise vaade, kaldkriips, login.
Õpetaja: Siuke vaade.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis meil räägitakse? Loos. Vaatekomponent, Login View aadressil. Login lisamenüüsse ka. Vastav link, nimega. Sisselogimine. Sisse logimine. Login. Selline vaade.
Õpetaja: Andmete päring. Back and serverilt. Bloki sissevajutamisel kontrollitakse, et Kas kõik väljad on täidetud? Kui kumbki välja on jäänud täitmata, siis väljastatakse veateade. Täida kõik väljad.
Õpetaja: Täida kõik väljad.
Õpetaja: Kui Üks nendest see on Fronti pool Okei?
Õpetaja: No selle jaoks eraldi komponent. Aa, see siin,
Õpetaja: mis võtab sisse message, mis võtab mingi sisu sisu, võib muutuda, Disain on sama,
Õpetaja: kui message on tühi Strings is alerti ei kuvata. See on see konkreetse komponendi kirjeldus.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, päris taaskis seda ei oleks. See on arendaja enne nagu välja mõelda. Kuidas ta seda asja teeb?
Õpetaja: Ee, see on hästi spetsiifiline. Juba
Õpetaja: mingi käitumine. Kuidas mingi konkreetne komponent Käitub nagu. Okei. Ee. Kui message on tühis drink, siis seal eriti ei kuvata. Kui on mingi sisu, siis kuvatakse seal, eriti
Õpetaja: kui kõik Vajalikud väljad on täidetud. Siis saadetakse Back end ile. Sõnum aadressile. Postupi Log in koos Request Bodyga Username Ee Password String String
Õpetaja: Näidissõnum ee sellest ee, sõnumist, mis läheb niiöelda siis teele.
Õpetaja: Ahhaa, mm.
Õpetaja: Tead, Seda ma tahaks muuta, et. Ee, miks ta. Ma taas lõin need taskid? Vaata, Mulle ei meeldi, et on kõik ühel real seal, kus sa oled.
Õpetaja: Mm, see asi. Näidissõnumi tahaks ikkagi teha. Cold Blokis,
Õpetaja: Goods nibed.
Õpetaja: Nii, ja võtame selle sisu.
Õpetaja: Paneme siia, Jason. Ee, formaatimine. Ma teen kuskil. Kasutan korraks. Ee, praegult siit Ee, s niimoodi. Vot nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, Niimoodi oleks parem seda asja sinna. Hops,
Õpetaja: Nii, palun tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ehk siis, ee. Kui kasutaja vajutab loogil nupu ja kõik väljed on täidetud Siis backhand Ile peab minema. Siukene sõnum koos Jasoniga.
Õpetaja: No Jasonit. Nüüd videot vaatasite?
Õpetaja: Enamvähem selge võti. Väärtus võti, väärtus, Ee, läheb niuksele aadressile Postsõnum lisa lisaandmeid.
Õpetaja: Back end tagastab sellele päringule Jasoni alljärgnevas formaadis.
Õpetaja: Ehk meie saadame sellest kastist Saadud. Username ja väärtused. Admin üks, kaks, kolm, Näiteks Ja tema vastab meile. User Id Üks
Õpetaja: või näiteks User Id Kaks customer
Õpetaja: Ee, eraldi viga, mis on backhand i poolt niiöelda defineeritud et võib tulla.
Õpetaja: Ee, Staatus on nelisada. Kolm Hdp staatustest. Räägime kaine bit Saate niukse sõnumi vastu, et, ee, message Ee, vale kasutajanimi või Parool. Noh, see on see
Õpetaja: onju
Õpetaja: Kaks käitumist. Seda teab front. Vaata, kui sul on midagi täitmata jäetud, seda saab programmiliselt kontrollida, aga seda et ee. Kasutaja on pannud siin mingisugused sisselogimisandmed, millele vastet ei leita. Või? Noh, ei ole. Siis. Kas läks valesti või polegi sellist asja? Sellist kasutanime parooli pole.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuskil Ma Nägin mingit niukest miini. Vaata, et ee, et umbes niimoodi, et uue konto Ee, regamisel vaata on Ju Ee, öeldakse, et üritad nagu teha endale uut kontot.
Õpetaja: Ja, siis. Ee, paned sinna mingi parooli Ja siis, ee, teatab, et et selline Parool on juba sellise Kasutaja. Nimega see kasutaja Kasutatud. Et
Õpetaja: et see ei ole see sõnum, mida me tahame edastada et meil on Niukene Hästi, nagu veig. Vaata, vale kasutajamine või parool. Aa, noh, see sõnum. Võibolla erinev Kui mõte on sama sisse, sa ei saa
Õpetaja: ja siis Tuleb nihukene error, Kood incore, mis näeb välja nagu Niukene enumilaadne tegelane.
Õpetaja: Mis Case see on?
Õpetaja: Mis konventsioonis on? See kirevi sõnad on eraldatud
Õpetaja: Kui niimoodi. Hästi, täpselt alla. Edukas päring. Status kakssada. Kohe Räägime Http staatusest. Siin oli mainitud Ee. Nagu nelisada. Kolm ja
Õpetaja: nelisada, Neli Ikka Olete näinud nelisada? Neli page. Not found. No nelisada. Neli ongi Not found.
Õpetaja: Ee, ressurssi pole edukas Päring Ee on siis kakssada vastuses. Saadud User Id väärtus salvestatakse session stores faili võtmega. User Id vastuses saadud role Name väärtus. Salvestatakse session Storage. Faili. Võtmega Role Name
Õpetaja: menüüs peidetakse Ära sisse onlogimine, Link, et kui sisselogimisel on see link näha, Kui on edukas päring No siis said sisse. Ju pole seda nuppu vaja, See nupp niiöelda toobki selle vaate nähtavale,
Õpetaja: siis see logimine viib vaatajale. Login selline vaade, et kui said edukalt, sisse, siis menüüs, peidetakse see link ära. Ja hoopis ilmub. Selle asemel, et see link logi välja.
Õpetaja: Peale edukat sisselogimist suunatakse kasutaja pangaautomaatide asukohta Vaatadele. Mäletad? Just tegime pangaautomaadid, Vaade,
Õpetaja: mis veel ee Vea vastusega Nelisada kolm. Kui vastus Staatus on nelisada kolm ja Jason sõnumi välja. Error kood välja. Error kood väärtus on Siis Kuvada message peateade vale kasutajanimi või parool.
Õpetaja: No siin see Lause Kui error kood on?
Õpetaja: Kui me mõtleme nendele asjadele, mida te Täna õppisite? Vabandust, eile õppisite? Kus on siin see tööriist, mis Meid, Aitab,
Õpetaja: If.
Õpetaja: Kui
Õpetaja: aga siin on Vaat siin on ju lausa, mis On see teine tööriist, mis ta aitab? Sest siin öeldakse, kaks asja on ju? Siin. Öeldakse, et kui kus see nüüd on see
Õpetaja: kui Staatus on nelisada. Kolm ja error kood. Väärtus
Õpetaja: bänd. Operaator, onju, et see on kaks tingimust. Noh, oli hea, et vaatasite seda ära ja Saite selgeks.
Õpetaja: On lihtsam. Ma ei tea koguaeg. Me jõuame täna. Proovime.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui siis on selline olukord, siis kuvada seda teadet, mis siin kirjas on. Mitte. Me ei kirjuta fronti sisse. Vaata, et visatakse vale kasutajanimi juba rool vaid sellest sõnumist endast. Äkki meil on mitmekeelsus,
Õpetaja: näiteks Selle mitmekeelsus
Õpetaja: või? Ee, täna on see. Ee. Võibolla see. Võibolla see tuleb kuskilt andmebaasist. Võibolla see tuleb backhand koodist, aga vahet pole, vaata, Et, ee, see selles mõttes me ei dubleeri nagu tööd. Et backhand ju tegelikult vastabki, et vale kasutajanimi Bürool on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui Me tahaksime seda sõnumit muuta. Näiteks on mingi Taipo Või tahame kuidagi ee, teistmoodi seda selgitust sinna panna, et siis me muudame selle backendis ära. Ja Front Times kuvatakse ka õiget asja,
Õpetaja: et see sisu tuleb. Teade tuleb sellest sõnumist endast. Niuke setup.
Õpetaja: Ee, kõikide teiste vigade puhul. Noh, näed, vaata, vigu võib tulla ju veel ee suunata kasutaja vaatele error, et konkreetselt selle teenuse puhul, mis me Backendilt saadame. Ta üks on ära deklareeritud olukord,
Õpetaja: aga võib ju midagi katki olla. Progemises on katki. Andmebaas on maas.
Õpetaja: Ise on maas. Mida iganes, siis tuleb selles mõttes, et kui ikkagi vastust ei tule ka üldse. Näiteks, et meie süsteem meie Brauser saadab sõnumi nagu. Anna mulle mingi andmeid vaata ja See vastab nagu, et kuule.
Õpetaja: Ei ole kedagi kuulda. Ei leidnudki niukest serverit või mis iganes. Vaata, midagi kukub maha. Vaata siis. Ee, Browser Saab ikkagi mingi error teate vaata timeout. Ja mis iganes, vaata, on ju? Noh, aga siis ongi küsimus, Kas kasutaja jääbki nägema lihtsalt seda vaadet. Nagu, et logi sisse klõpsib. Seda nuppu.
Õpetaja: Midagi ei toimu.
Õpetaja: Ups, midagi läks valesti. Noh, sorry, Whatever
Õpetaja: ta. Ta peab ta peab saama Nagu aru, et midagi ei läks ukse aga. Kahjuks ei tea mis, laptop see see Olukord on nagu ära fikseeritud onju, et, vale kasutajamine Bürool seda seal me programmeerime, et niukest asja näeks Kasutaja sel samal lehel
Õpetaja: liikumine vaatele. Atm, S. Ee.
Õpetaja: Pilt on küll see vale praegult. Ee, ma pean selle pildi ära parandama. Ee, tegelikult on siin niimoodi, et. Ee, Ma parandan selle pildi, ära et siin peaks olema, et
Õpetaja: Katke siia. Vasakpool kastist kinni. Praegu mõtega saabud siia lehele. Ee, suunatakse kasutaja pangaautomaadid lehele. Kus siis näidatakse? Lihtsalt proof of user, Id ja
Õpetaja: selle pildi. Ma vahetan varsti välja,
Õpetaja: et lehele saabudes peab kätte saama session Storesis olevad väärtused ning kuvama seda alertis saate aru, mõte on Selles, et me läheme ühelt vaatelt teisele.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal on nüüd niimoodi et kõik, mis me eelmisel vaatajal nägime, kõik andmed ja asjad, mis Iganes on, need kaovad kuhugi mutiauku ära. Muidu standardina.
Õpetaja: Kui me läheme uuele vaatele, siis on meil mõningaid andmeid siiski vaja.
Õpetaja: Ja meil ongi vaja neid andmeid, Et kes sa olid? Kes sa sisse logisid? Kes sa oled selline, et, ee, kes sa oled, nagu it mõttes on ju. Ja kes sa oled? Rolli mõttes. Sest vastavalt sellele, me peame programmeerima. Vaata, et kuhu ta üldse maandub. Ega ta üldse seal näeb?
Õpetaja: Ee, ja kui ta. Kui on mingisugused tegevused, kus tema saab mingeid lisada andmeid asju. Võibolla me tahame siis ka jäädvustada seda, et kes Need andmed lisas. Kui see on näiteks mingi veebialbumi Portaal on ju. Ma tahan lisada pilte, kellega need järgnevad pildid on seotud.
Õpetaja: Noh, konkreetse User. Iga user on Id.
Õpetaja: Ee, Davaika. Jõudsime lõppu. Ee, olete veel päris lõppu jõudnud. Kui kasutaja on sisse logitud, ee, siis sisse. Logimine Nuppu ei kuvata. Selle asemel kuvatakse logi välja nuppu. See on hästi näidakas Siin dubleeritud see info. Aga põhimõtteliselt on see sama
Õpetaja: relatsioonilised andmebaasid Käsi püsti. Kes teab, millega on tegu?
Õpetaja: Väga hea, Triin, Räägi, mis asi on ee relatsioonide andmebaasis. Mis See, mõte? Mis peamine kontseptsioon on,
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt need on nagu andmete siuksed. Mm tabelid, mis igas tabelis on. Põhimõtteliselt nagu ühe ühe,
Õpetaja: ühe, siis asja raames. Nagu informatsioon, et ei Oleks kõik erinev. Info nagu M Tabelis koos. Aga samas need erinevad tabelid on omavahel seotud.
Õpetaja: Triin ütles kõik ära, põhimõtteliselt ee, mis on, Mis oli vaja. Kohe vaatame seda natuke visuaalselt. Ka Tegemist on siis sellise lahendusega, kus on erinevad tabelid?
Õpetaja: Tabelid on siis niiöelda ka enda Nagu Valdkonniti või temaatilised, Kui niimoodi? Hästi, lihtsalt öelda, et. Ee. Meil on mingi tabel. Kus on kõik linnad?
Õpetaja: Meil on tabel. Kus on Kõik treeningutüübid.
Õpetaja: Meil on ühe tabeli, kus on kõik erinevad Location Id
Õpetaja: ja need seosed omavahel. Meil on tabelid.
Õpetaja: Kus need asjad on? Omavahel? Nende rea Ütleme Kainda nagu Rea numbritega omavahel pühendatud
Õpetaja: sama andmeid omavaheliselt. See on see, mõte,
Õpetaja: mis on selle asja nagu peamine idee, on See, et ükskõik. Ee, põhimõtteliselt olete näinud niukseid Excelid. Kus on sada kuuskümmend
Õpetaja: ikka on? Ju
Õpetaja: Aa, Siis sellistel lahendustel võib ka juhtuda seda, et ühes veeru ühes veerus. Lihtsalt näiteks andmed korduvat.
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette aadress.
Õpetaja: Võta maadaks. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Mm. Kui mina ühes teeksin, ühes tabelis aadressi Aa, Minu aadress on valiku külas. Elan, on ju? Ee, keegi. Ee, ütleme. Okei, toome mingi muu näite, et öelge mul üks Tallinna aadress, oota
Õpetaja: Meil on aia. Tänav on ju? Aia Tänav on? Ütleme, me tahame Excelis teha lihtsalt tabelit, kus me kaardistame. Niiöelda siis aadressi Paneme. Aia seitse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd oleks sinna vaja juurde, Et mis linn ta on? On ju siis meil saaks. Olla Vastab Tõele Mis me sinna kirjutaksime?
Õpetaja: Tallinn, Mitu tähte on Tallinnas?
Õpetaja: Seitse seitse tähemärki.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lisaksin sinna veel mingisuguse aadressi. Noh, mina ei tea, mis siin on mingi viru viru Tänav, näiteks. See on Ka Tallinn, onju?
Õpetaja: Siis ma määraksin ära, et ta on kus kohas ta on, Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Siis ma peaksin kirjutama sinna veel, kui ka seitse tähenevärki Tallinn vastutajale
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd, mis puudutab reaktsioonile andmebaaside, Seal on kolm nihukest aa hästi tähtsat printsiipi üks, on siis Andmete Liigastus. See on, asi, mida me soovime vältida, et kui meil on nüüd tuhat Tallinna aadressi, siis tuhat korda seitse. See on seitse Tuhat tähemärki juba
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kui me tahaksime andmeid otsida ka või peale kauba, kuidas andmeid otsida, otsime mulle kõik tallinna Ee, aadressi,
Õpetaja: siis põhimõtteliselt Andmebaasi mõttes peaks käima läbi terve tabeli võtma. Niiöelda otsitav parameeter,
Õpetaja: seitse tähemärki ja nüüd iga rea pealt peaks andmebaas vaatama konkreetsesse ja võrdlema Iga rea kohta. Kas ma näen siit A L, i N.
Õpetaja: Jah, see Mida meile käärida?
Õpetaja: See ei ole väga, väga kiire tegevus, see on päris. Noh, okei. Ta on kiire. Või ongi mingi paar tuhat rida? Vaata aga, Tegelikult andmebaasid väga, väga kiire. Ta on miljoni parem Mingi Excel ja muud asjad on ju? Aga. Aga kui me läheme juba siin nagu mingi kümnetesse tuhandetesse andmetesse Sada Tuhandetesse siis, on juba See päris Ats. See on ikka väga Aeglane tegevus Vaadata
Õpetaja: tähe kaupa, ühe rea andmed ja praegu mingi lihtne seista täheline läheb pigemaks
Õpetaja: seal on printsiibid, mis? Nagu ütleme, ei tööta väga hästi. Kui meil on selline lahendus, et meil on ee, üks tabel, kus on hästi palju andmeid. Vaata, on ju Aga seal mingid asjad muudkui ka korduvad. Tänu sellele, et. Noh, meil on kõik ühes tabelis relatsioonilise andmebaasi, Ma ütlen Hoopis see sul on üks tabel.
Õpetaja: Kus sul on? Lihtsalt, ee, ühe korra ära öeldud. Tallinn Tartu viljandi, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ja nendel on reanumbrid. Ee, Tegelikult need Id D, aga mõtlema rea numbrid. Sest ka enne nii on. Hakkad ühes pilti ja läheb üles poole
Õpetaja: Nüüd, selle asemel, et Ee, tuhat korda panna sinna. Seda Tallinnat on meil süsteemis. Tegelikult Tallinnat ühe ainsa korra
Õpetaja: ja ta taga on üks number.
Õpetaja: No ütleme, et on? Siis ma ei tea Kolmteist Kolmeteistkümnes. Kui keegi seestas selle sinu tabelisse.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, kus meil on aadress, nagu aia seitse ja viru kümme. Mis, Iganes seal on üks, veel vaata.
Õpetaja: Seal nende juures selle. Asemel et, oleks tallinntallinn On lihtsalt kolmteist ja kolmteist
Õpetaja: ja kolmteist kui, on veel näinud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on, niimoodi, et meil on hoopis tähtede asemel number, et numbri tuvastamine otsimine süsteemist on miljon korda kiire, pluss andmete mahus. Kui meil on tuhat aadressi, Meil oleks tulnud seitse tuhat tähtaja. Aga nüüd on meil tuli ainult seitse tähtaja. Meil on Tallinn ühe Korra kirjutab välja ühe korra
Õpetaja: et see on nagu, ee. Selle andmete otsimise mõttes on ülikiire ja ülilihtne andmebaasil leida ülesse vajalikud read nende numbritega Väga Väga kiire,
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Loomulikult. Ee, võitjaid Meil ei ole vaja nüüd see sama niiöelda. Asi, mis mul on siin,
Õpetaja: ee, on mul Ka olemas kuskil materjalides siin visuaalselt Ee Excelis. Sest meil kõigile meeldib Excel
Õpetaja: teeme ei ole koguduse. Tabeli struktuur on osaliselt aga polegi Päris vajad, ei ole see äkki see. Mul oli alles misasja. Ma oleks kohe teada
Õpetaja: See sama tabel. Ee, esiteks, need siin on tabeli nimed.
Õpetaja: Need võivad olla mitmuses, aga minu soovitus on pigem hoida neid ainsuses.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldiks, kui on ainsus.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole mitmeses vaimsuses, te peaksite siis igal juhul jätma selle süsteemi, et kuidas iganes valite siis kõikides tabelites, on
Õpetaja: nüüd täpselt nii, nagu Triin ütles. Vaata, ühes tabelis on Kaido nagu ühe. Noh, ma ei mäleta, mis sõna sa kasutasid?
Õpetaja: Ee, ühe ühesugused asjad või ühe mingi konkreetse osa. Asjad Vaata, siin on City Tabel City tabel.
Õpetaja: Nüüd need siin all ei ole read.
Õpetaja: Need on hoopis representatsioon veergudest City tabelis on meil Id ja
Õpetaja: Aa tegelt Võtame hoopis need. Need siin. Need kaks, mida ongi vaja. User ja role
Õpetaja: roll tabelis. Meil on Id ja Name siia. Name I alla Käib admin customer moderaator
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mis iganes roll
Õpetaja: olenevalt sellele äri Case, Ile ka, mis? Meil on User tabelis, Meil on username Password Staatus.
Õpetaja: Aga on ka olemas. Role Id
Õpetaja: ja see role Id on nüüd selline asi. Vaata, kus sisse tuleb trükkida number,
Õpetaja: aga see Number peab vastama siis konkreetselt. Rollitabeli Idle.
Õpetaja: Okei, palju äppimist vähe. Kasu on ju?
Õpetaja: Teeme niimoodi, et ma kustutan siit natukene asju Ära
Õpetaja: nii. Ee, ma võtan need ülejäänud asjad peidan praegult siit hetkel ära, et ee, lihtsalt, oleks silmal vähem Staffi,
Õpetaja: nii on meil user. Tabel on meil roll tabel
Õpetaja: ja meil on taustal siukene asi nagu ee järjest loeb.
Õpetaja: Ee, Keegi on niukse programmeerimises, mida te pluss pluss lisab lisab
Õpetaja: Ühe See on Niukene funktsionaalsus, Mis koodis, kui sa paned Pluss pluss I pluss pluss kui koodirida läheb seal üle on, see, et mis Iganes muutuja. Nüüd on muutuja. Väärtus on näiteks ee null. Siis niipea. Kui sealt üle läheb, siis automaatselt Selle Muutuja. Väärtus läheb ühe võrra suuremaks.
Õpetaja: See on ikka kirjaviis. Ee, nüüd, ee. Mängime siis. Ee, nüüd ise natukene, et andmebaasil tekivad andmed andmed, et kõigepealt roll tabelisse tekib Üks uus roll.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina ütlen, et ma tahan, et oleks Admin.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see asi nüüd töötab? On see, et kõik väljad peavad olema Täidetud või mis? Iganes. Kuidas see nõue seal on ülesse pandud. Nüüd Temal on vaja ühte Ee. Temal on vaja järgmist vabat. Id D,
Õpetaja: Siis kuidas tema läheb? Tema läheb juurde, teeb pluss pluss null muutub. Milleks
Õpetaja: üheks? Ja see väärtus tuleb siia. Üks.
Õpetaja: See asi nüüd töötabki Niimoodi, et iga Jumala kord kui tekib uus rida juurde,
Õpetaja: suurendatakse ühe võõra, võetakse see väärtus.
Õpetaja: See garanteerib seda. Vaata, et iga Id kogu Selle lifetime. Sellel tabelil saab olla ainult unikaalsed väärtused,
Õpetaja: et ei saa juhtuda niimoodi siia. Et järgmine roll, mida me tahaks, et oleks customer,
Õpetaja: Ärge tehke seda värki. On ju?
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Seda ei ole.
Õpetaja: See süsteem on sama. Ei saa olla, niimoodi. Et ta tuleb, Võtab siit näiteks Ühe või või? Ta võtab null. Näiteks või midagi taolist. Ta ei saa või? Miinus üks
Õpetaja: ei saa olla, vaid tuleb siia. See läheb ühe võrra suuremaks. Ja see väärtus siia tuleb
Õpetaja: garanteeritult. Unikaalne, kui näiteks. Ma teen korra selle rea juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma visuaalselt korraks teen juurde,
Õpetaja: Oletame, et keegi kustutab selle customer i kahe ära,
Õpetaja: on ju? Ta tahab mingit uut rolli panna?
Õpetaja: Kas kui tegelikult, uuesti tahab panna customer sisestada.
Õpetaja: Protsess on endiselt sama.
Õpetaja: Siia pannakse üks juurde.
Õpetaja: See on kolm, et kui vahepeal keegi kustutab midagi ära, See ei ole mingit optimeerimist, et vot siin on mõned vabad Id D ei ole siin. On vaja järjekindlust. Garanteeritud järjekindlust.
Õpetaja: See on nii hea süsteem. Ma, Ei tea Kes see realisoonilised andmebaasid on? Mingi Mina ei tea viiekümnendatest või kuuekümnendatest tulid
Õpetaja: ja see Staff endiselt töötab Hästi, noh, tehtud parendusi, mõned asju Ja neid mootoreid on erinevaid tootjaid ja tooteid on nii palju, on ju? Ja on ka Noh, uusi. Lahendusi, mis ei ole täpselt sellise lahendusega. Aga see on pagan. Oma töökindel. See on Jumalast hea lahendus. Nagu andmetel. Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Nobeli Price peaks olema sellel inimesel, kes selle tegi ära. Igal juhul ma ei tea.
Õpetaja: Mina annaks talle isiklikult selle üle. Nii, nüüd kui mina soovin seal mingit kasutajat luua,
Õpetaja: nüüd Siin on nõutud, et see see tabel on tehniliselt seotud. Kui sealt andmebaasis need tabelid on loodud, siis kripto on selliselt tehtud, et on öeldud, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: siin on üks veerg nimega Role Id.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, siin Role. Id.
Õpetaja: Siia sisse saab käia number, aga see peab olema mingi number, mis siin selles Role tabeli. Näete, ma teen selle kahe kaheks. See kon See sün. See nimekonventsioon on ka Täpselt sama. See viitab Tabelile vastab tõele role tabelile.
Õpetaja: Ja see osa viitab sellele ühele konkreetsele veerule. Seal tabelis, Mis veerule ta viitab Id le
Õpetaja: ma teen sellest Ee, asjast. Ee, siin. Ma teen selle tabeli. Ma Teen oranžiks selle. Aa, selle ma teen siniseks. Need on värvid pärast.
Õpetaja: Siin on eriline Asi Siin ei saa olla väärtus null. Siin ei saa väärtus olla kümme miks. Ei saa neid väärtusi olla
Õpetaja: sest? Et, neid pole siin olemas.
Õpetaja: Mäletan, ma rääkisin, et on mitmed printsiibid, mis on relatsioonis andmebaasis, mis teevad neist nagu niukse? Noh, asja, mis on
Õpetaja: andmete terviklikkus.
Õpetaja: Sa ei saa viidata siin millelegi,
Õpetaja: mida pole enam olemas. See süsteem ei võimalda.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad. Kui näiteks niuksed asjad on ka vaata kohe Vaatame seda. Asja. On ju, et kui mina tahaksin praegu. Nüüd on ka see mõte. Siis relatsioonilisus ka, et kui mina teen siia konto, Mille Nimeks ma panen Admin?
Õpetaja: Üks, kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et tema staatus on see, et ta on active a nagu active, näiteks onju, Kui mina tahaksin, et ta päriselt saaks endale rolli. Ee, admin.
Õpetaja: Ma tegelt teen teistmoodi. Me teeme hoopis Rain,
Õpetaja: mina. Rain on täiesti tavaline Klient, mis ma siia kirjutan, ostame.
Õpetaja: Ei, kirjuta. Customer.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: see kirjutan kaks Sellepärast Tema viitab rollitabelil kahele ehk customer, kui mina tahan mingit rolli juurde teha. Minul on selline süsteem, kus Lihtsalt kirjuta üks roll juurde. Vaata ja tekib üks uus roll ja uus oma Id, onju, See Siin on Role Id.
Õpetaja: Need numbrid, Need Id D. Need genereeritakse automaatselt. See siin on täidetav informatsioon, mida ma ise pean täitma. Või Noh, programm. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: see peab tulema kaks. Kui ma tahan raini.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mis tema saab? Enda Id ks See sabaidiks.
Õpetaja: No peast juba teaks selle ära, aga ta saab. Selle Istkel on see null. Pluss pluss teeb tast ühe. Järelikult tema Id tuleb. Üks on nii
Õpetaja: kui Ma Nüüd tahan siia teha admin
Õpetaja: kuidagi meelega, et sellist teises järjekorras, et kogu aeg ei tuleks. Üks, kaks, üks, kaks, on ju,
Õpetaja: kui Mina teen siia uue konto. Ütleme, username on admin. Parool on üks, kaks, kolm. A on et see, et ta on aktiivne, kui mina Tahan teda nüüd ära määratleda, et tema on admin. Siis ma kirjutan siia
Õpetaja: üks ja siia tuleb. Mis number?
Õpetaja: Miks tuleb kaks Sellepärast Seconds Counterist. Järgmine number on kaks
Õpetaja: nii relatsiooniline andmebaas. Abc näoga.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: Taltechis. Ma ei tea, kas see on ikka andmebaaside alusel priita raspel Ee, Vanakooli vend, Ee Circa. Kolmkümmend pluss aastat inimesel reaalsete andmebaasidega kogemust. Ee,
Õpetaja: kuue Eap ne promovaits neile, et vabakuulajana saab ka võtta koolitust, et Kui keegi andmebaasidest asjadest huvitab, siis ma soovitan. Ta rääkis kõik selgeks.
Õpetaja: Ta tõesti tal tema õpetusmeetod on selline Vaata et ta, õpetab need kontseptsioonid selgeks. Siis ta hakkab rääkima.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta on vaja teha niuksed. Kokkuvõistlik kursuse vältel. Kas kolm või neli tööd oli vaja teha
Õpetaja: Ee Tööd olid sellised, et meil on kanala.
Õpetaja: See on kanal. Siin kanalas on mingi niuksed asjad toimumas siin kanalas. Mingid niuksed, tegevused, ta. Lihtsalt, See on lihtsalt tekstiformaadis. Lihtsalt jutt kanalast
Õpetaja: Ja siis, tema nagu ütleb, vaata teie Ülesanne on nüüd disainida, nagu siis andmebaas,
Õpetaja: mis võimaldaks monitoorida Ja taasesitada ja hoida kõikide tegevuste kohta andmeid.
Õpetaja: Aga mitte lihtsalt, vaid jälgides absoluutselt kõike neid reegleid.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on ee, mis normatiivid, kuidas hoida andmebaas võimalikult korrektselt. Selles mõttes, et seal ei ole andmete liiasust
Õpetaja: Seal on tagatud Aa käideldavus. Terviklikkus.
Õpetaja: Ee, need normatiivid on ee kas Olid kolm N või N kolm. Ma pean kogu aeg vaatama. Seda. Kunagi ei ole peas
Õpetaja: Tv.
Õpetaja: Kolm, n meaning Ee, Okei, proovime niimoodi Andmebaas Kolm N ee. On need baas
Õpetaja: Noormatiivid.
Õpetaja: Ahah, niimoodi. Üks Nf. Vaata, Ee, see on niimoodi. Vaata, et, ee. Sa pead viima normaal kujul. See tähendab seda, et siin on teatud Aa nii öelda. Printsiibid. Ee, ja mida Peab nagu proovima on nagu kolme, F, nagu see On nagu kõige parem ee. Kui andmebaas on normaliseeritud kõige to Them X, Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: esimene Ee, üks Nf. Esimene normaalkuju. Tabeli lahtrid sisaldavad ainult Automaatseid jagamatuid, väärtusi ja igal veerul on unikaalne nimi
Õpetaja: teine normaal kuju. On See, et on see esimene ja kõik mitte võt,
Õpetaja: Me Veeru Veerud sõltuvad täielikult primaarvõtmest.
Õpetaja: Ma ei, ma ei mõtle. Ma ei soovi isegi Bradsada siin lahti rääkida. Ma ei oska seda isegi nii hästi rääkida, kui Priit raspel. Aga seal see, et oleks andmebaas. Tegelikult perfektne. Seal on päris palju vaja vaadata ja mõelda andmebaasi Mudel on tegelikult Asi, mida peab väga läbi mõtlema, kui ise teeb projekti.
Õpetaja: Ee, miks Sellepärast, et kui sa juba teed selle mudeli valmis, võtad selle kasutusele Ja asud progema. Ja siis saad aru, et tegelikult see mudel ei toeta sinu tegevust. Sinu, sinu andmebaas. Ei tege ei toeta seda kanalat
Õpetaja: nii öelda. Kanala värki või hobusetallid ja piirivalve. Ja mis seal kõik oli?
Õpetaja: Aa, kuidas siis temal oli? Siis sa pididki joonistama samasuguseid skeeme Nagu me siin pildil. Ee, näeme. Aga nüüd kujutage ette, et oli tükk tegemist, et nad mahuks A kolmele ära. A kolm on siis See suurem on ju.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas temaga oli? Siis Tulid siis esitama oma tööd? See punane pastakas. No tegelt oli sinine pastakas ka oli valmis ja ta oli.
Õpetaja: Ta vaatas sul seda Vaata, kui ta midagi ei meeldi, siis tõmbasin ülesse kriipsu.
Õpetaja: Sa. Sa kõrval vaatasid samal ajal Sa rääkis ka sõbrad.
Õpetaja: Teine taasesitlus. Kolmas, palun.
Õpetaja: Ja siis oli nagu. See. Vaata, et vahel oli tal niimoodi, et, noh, ta tegi lihtsalt Kaks kriipsu vaatas peale
Õpetaja: Ja, ee, ütleme niimoodi, et mul ei õnnestunud küll mitte ühegi tööga. Seda, et ühtegi kriipsu ei saa masendav.
Õpetaja: Paned Mingi hullult tunde sisse ja mõtled nagu. Nagu läbi, Aga ikkagi. Vaata on midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, Priit raspelt. Aa, tema
Õpetaja: Üks lause, mis ma veel Pärast hiljem. Too mängu ka. Ütlen. Vaata, see oli ta kogu aeg. Ta ütles pidevalt.
Õpetaja: Igal Asjal on oma algus ja lõpp.
Õpetaja: Nii oli ka Nõukogude Liidul. See on huvitav, kas ta tänapäeval siiamaani ütleb? Tahaks teada?
Õpetaja: Ee, jõuame selleni ka. Vaata, see kandja on siin praegult Ee, mis? Ee, Seda sümboliseerib,
Õpetaja: Aga räägin hiljem. Relatsiooniline andmebaas. Ja nüüd mõte ongi nagu. See. Vaata, et, ee, Kui meil kasutaja niiöelda logib sisse,
Õpetaja: Siis Aa, kuskilt Ta tegelikult peab juba meil olemas olema.
Õpetaja: Näed see siin.
Õpetaja: Kui ta logib sisse, siis meil on vaja teada ja See ongi see sama Id, kes sa oled.
Õpetaja: Sest et kui me programmeerides midagi toimetame, teeme ega me seal enam kuskile ei hakka, mingeid Raini ja mingeid asju nagu sõnumites saatma. See pole vajalik
Õpetaja: rollidega tegelikult. Noh, see on natukene valikuline värk. Vaata, et kas ta kuvab, näitab, et kas on Id või on name? Mida iganes meil hiljem tuleb sind see pilt, mis on kogemata vale. Tallinn Tartu pärnu.
Õpetaja: No, need tulevad ju City tabelist.
Õpetaja: Näete, on nii,
Õpetaja: et Cityl on omad niiöelda numbrid ja asukohtadel on ka omad niiöelda numbrid. Aga selle asukoha tabelis määratakse ära. Mis linnaga on tegemist seal? Kas see sikupilliprisma on Tartus pärnus või Tallinnas, kus ta on, onju?
Õpetaja: Pärast Hiljem ongi see. Et Tahaks Ripp. Menüüd. Kus on linnad? Nad tulevad andmebaasist nimega City. Näeme visuaalselt neid lableid. Taustal on City Id,
Õpetaja: Sest kui keegi midagi valib, Näed, siin. Selles näites on juba City Id on kaks, näiteks. Noh, see on Pilt on veits. Vale
Õpetaja: valest kohast.
Õpetaja: Tallinnas onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, on relatsioonilise andmebaasi kohta Mingeid küsimusi või Suures pildis saate aru, Nagu mis? Elukas see relatsiooni andmebaas on? Meil on erinevad tabelid
Õpetaja: ja meil on Ee, erinevad. Ee, tabelid omavahel seotud läbi nende numbrite seal, kus vaja
Õpetaja: tabel on Ee, kuskil backhand serveri lähedal. Kui nii võib öelda
Õpetaja: andmebaas on üldse. Kui ma ei tea, kas seda pilti mul kuskil käepärast on nüüd võtta.
Õpetaja: Kas see vaade väga ei meeldi? Paneme dites?
Õpetaja: Kui Ee, kui vaadata. Aa, võibolla siin Samas on juba olemas see pilt.
Õpetaja: Need tabelid on eraldi andmebaasis.
Õpetaja: Me teeme lihtsalt visuaalselt, et oleks see Kast. Aga otseselt ei ole ju kohta, kuhu andmeid kogutakse. Neid ebatendeid.
Õpetaja: Jah, väga hea. Ei, ei, ei, ma vaatan, kas mul. Aa, jah, Kohe räägin sellest ka.
Õpetaja: See ongi see, miks. Ee. Miks klassikaliselt alati alustatakse õpetamisega? See probleem on ju
Õpetaja: nagu. Mida sa Frontis teed? Kui pole.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme siis kohe selle otse lahti. Vaata, kui ee. Põnevust. Ärme hoia siis kauem.
Õpetaja: Ee, Stoplight.
Õpetaja: Tegemist on ühe platvormiga.
Õpetaja: Eelkõige see Platvorm on mõeldud selle jaoks, et sa saad disainida veebiteenuseid.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen praegu siia panga alla.
Õpetaja: Mul on, ee, Näiteks Niukene teenus Get Cities.
Õpetaja: Kui sina lähed rajale get mitte rajale, siis mida ta peaks tagastama?
Õpetaja: Ta peaks tagastama. Vaatan, kas seal sponsor saab kuidagi teistmoodi ka Vaadata Vaatesse minema. Ee, natukene parem siin seda toimetada.
Õpetaja: See on koht, kus saab tegelikult disainida. Niiöelda siis Backend süsteemi Veebi veebiteenuseid,
Õpetaja: Et Ee, Mis sõnumeid saab? Back end ile saata On kind of name of the game.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on niimoodi. Lähme formaatesse, et minul on tehtud Niimoodi, et ee. Kui on get. Ee get cities
Õpetaja: toimetanud. Ee, kus ma s a siia Pean vajutama. Vot nii, kui meile tuleb. Ee, Kett. Ee, Kaldkriips City S siis. Ee. Mina olen nagu disaininud. Seda nagu ütleme siis ee. Arendajana, et on kaks varianti. Kuidas saab vastata?
Õpetaja: Üks on, see, et. Ee, kõik on hästi. Teine on see, et on mingisugune viga. Tegelikult on. Ee, jah, midagi puudu. Ja siis mina saan öelda. Vaata, et ee.
Õpetaja: Ta tagastab umbes sellist. Jasonid City, Id, Kaks Tallinn City, Id, Kolm Tartu City Id. Üks pärnu,
Õpetaja: see keskkond on mõeldud eelkõige selleks, et sa saad kokku leppida See on contract.
Õpetaja: See on nagu leping niiöelda Frontend I ja Backendi vahel. Vaata, et, Ee, millised veebiteenused on? Kuhu tuleb sõõm saata? Millise sisendi sina pead mulle andma? Mida mina sulle vastu annan,
Õpetaja: aga Stoplight on läinud loomulikult sammu kaugemale. Nad on siis teinud, et kuidagi saaks asju kohe proovida. Ka
Õpetaja: Siis saab teha niimoodi et sa saad talle saata sõnumeid,
Õpetaja: Tema vastab sulle kogu aeg, siis vastava näitega, mis sina oled siia sisse juurde lisanud. Ehk siis, kui ma lähen siia. Ee, Preview vaatesse tagasi. Näiteks see sama Get Cities.
Õpetaja: Mina saan proovida siin seda teenust.
Õpetaja: Request. Ee, ma korra muudaks selle ära. Ee, C, Hull iks. Võibolla näete C Hull Siin Aa,
Õpetaja: get Cities See on Stoplight I enda server.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt siit, kuni Kainda selle on nende serveri aadress, aga tegelikult ei, Ole Tegelt on see nende rakendus. Lihtsalt mis siis õpib? Nagu vastama, nii nagu vaja.
Õpetaja: Mina saan öelda nagu et ole hea, et kui Keegi saadab selle sõnumi sellele urlile. Siis palun Lihtsalt vastu niukse, Jason, iga. No annan teile endale ka seda proovida. Panen Brauserisse
Õpetaja: kõik sõnumid, Mis Lähevad siit aadressi? Realt on ketpäringud. Browserist. Siit saab minna ainult kettpäringud. Kui Mina ütlen, nagu panen selle urli, siis läheb sõnum teele
Õpetaja: Mingisugune Id Appi Citys. Kui ma vajutan entrit, siis tuleb. Noh, tegelikult ta tuleb niimoodi. Noh, Proovige teiegi
Õpetaja: nagu brauserist Teen ju see ju, See nagu tuleb kõigile samamoodi. Aga lihtsalt proovige,
Õpetaja: mis juhtub, kui seda linki vajutada
Õpetaja: peaks? Avanema leht, kus tuleb Jason, Okei, teil Ei ole niukest pluginat, mis selle ilusaks teeb. Aga midagi taolist peaks Tulema tuleb
Õpetaja: palun väga.
Õpetaja: Teas Your backhand.
Õpetaja: Mina siis leidsingi Ma teadsin, et ma Tahan seda saavutada. Siis ma hakkasin otsima. Vaata, et ma saan lihtsalt teha nagu fake serveri, kes vastaks mulle kogu aeg. Midagi
Õpetaja: ei vastaks Nii nagu mina tahan. Nagu selles mõttes. Ma saan mingeid erinevaid asju proovida.
Õpetaja: Ee toimib. Avastasin stoplite meid, Uurisin, puurisin meid aega, õppisin seda Kuidas seal Nagu ülesse asju seada?
Õpetaja: Nüüd juba lõpus. Kui ma tegin Recovery Mul Ma ütlen, et kõik süüa taaskid läksid kaduma, ma pidin neid ee hakkama kuidagi taastama mis oli üks paras peavalu ja mul oli tegelikult ammu plaanis teha ka nendest
Õpetaja: materjalides muudatusi teenustesse, mis moodi mida kutsutakse. Mis sõnumeid? Ja nii edasi. Andsin talle taustal. Ma Nüüd näitan ka. Ma nüüd räägin seda. Ära vaatad, kuidas see asi taustal toimub.
Õpetaja: Ega see asi siin ei ole? Stoplight I leiutatud. Kui ma lähen editvaatesse, siis ma saan korra vaadata, mis siin, taustal tegelikult toimetab, See siin. On visuaalne vaade
Õpetaja: taustal. Tegelikult toimetab üks Jason ja mitte mingi suvaline Jason, vaid standardil Baseeruv, kokkulepitud. Jason, mis kirjeldab veebisüsteemi
Õpetaja: See Jayse on siin.
Õpetaja: Võin selle Jasoni siit võtta. Näiteks
Õpetaja: võtan selle Jason I Lähen näiteks ee. Väge reditorisse, kus ee saab vaadata Open app I teenuseid.
Õpetaja: Kahjuks on siin juba. Ma lähen korra Incognitos, teen seda.
Õpetaja: Ma pole varem siin kunagi käinud. Ee, Sväger
Õpetaja: editor. Noh, mingi näide peaks tulema, kui pole midagi uut vahepeal tulnud.
Õpetaja: Low Cookies.
Õpetaja: Issand, kui kole see välja näeb, ma ei saa mitte midagi aru, see on Visuaal on ka muutunud.
Õpetaja: Mm, mida kuradat loodakse? Apple Pet star Noh, parem
Õpetaja: nii. Ee, saate aru. See on Niukene see võib olla siin ka On Jason varianti ka. Convertu Jason Trial. Okei, Pole
Õpetaja: Ee, saate aru. See on nagu põhimõtteliselt ee selline, Niiöelda standard, millega on võimalik siis kirjeldada ära, et mis teenused saavad niiöelda sinu pakendi vastu minna.
Õpetaja: Aga tegelikult see on nagu planeerimise faasis. Juba mingi arhitekt võib mõelda, et teeme niimoodi. See on Pet Shop. Mis on loomaaia? Pood on ju. Vaatame, mis siin teha saab. Postbed ad new bet to the Store.
Õpetaja: Kuidas seda saab teha? Sa pead saatma rajale Pet sõnumi, postsõnumi.
Õpetaja: Ja sa pead panema kaasa niukse Jasoni. Kus on Ee Id name Category. Category Season Id Name Saate aru. See on nagu sõnum mis saab saata. On veel variant, et sa saad kohe sõnumit saata ka Ja proovida.
Õpetaja: See on kokkulepe. See on kokkulepe, See on. See on leping, mis teenused on olemas. Kuidas nende poole pöörduda, mis? Sa pead talle sisse andma. Mis ta sulle vastu annab?
Õpetaja: See on dokumentatsioon.
Õpetaja: See on dokumentatsioon, mis kirjeldab põhimõtteliselt infosüsteemi Ja
Õpetaja: miks on see muidugi hea Asi on see, et, ee, umbes selline vaade, nagu me siin praegult näeme.
Õpetaja: Siukse asja saab põhimõtteliselt genereerida koodibaasi enda peal. Me kirjutame rakendust, Kus on veebiteenused?
Õpetaja: Me saame siin seal natukene, nendele veebiteenustele isegi lisada. Siis ütleme ka enda nagu kommentaarid.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sina käivitad oma serveri Siis tema genereerib su koodibaasi pealt kogu dokumentatsiooni, et. Hei, kuidas siia? Pet Story saab? Uut,
Õpetaja: Ee, Pet i Lisada milliseid pet E status,
Õpetaja: Kuidas sa saad mingid vastused? Mis vead, seal on?
Õpetaja: Jaadi, jaadi jaadi. Ja.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mina näiteks panen selle sama asja siia korra sellesse asemele. Panen selle sama. Jason I mis on minu poolt niiöelda tehtud pank. Nelikümmend üks
Õpetaja: pangaautomaatide asukohtade haldus
Õpetaja: kett appi Atm Locations, mis tema teeb, tagastab loetelu linnades koos City Id ja City name I väärtustega.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, mis meid nüüd huvitab. Post, login sisselogimine tagastab user, Id ja Role I süsteemist otsitakse username ja abil kasutajat, Kelle konto on ka aktiivne. Kui vastet ei leita, visatakse viga error koodiga Incoreals.
Õpetaja: Okei, Vaatame Request Body, mida sa pead kaasa andma? Sa pead kaasa andma Niukse. Jason. I.
Õpetaja: Mida ta vastab sulle, Kui kõik läheb hästi, siis ta vastab sellise sisuga,
Õpetaja: kui läheb halvasti. Ta vastab siukse staatusega ja sihukese sisuga.
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: Mina olen nagu kogu seda kama sinna sisse ära pannud. Ja selline asi tuleb ka lõpuks teie rakendusest, onju nii öelda, kui genereerib ja hea asi ongi, lihtsalt see, nagu te nägite, et kui Saate sõnum Stoplight I konkreetsele Urlile,
Õpetaja: Siis ta vastab lihtsalt sõnumiga vastu. Me praegu Mokime
Õpetaja: back end Id. Meil ei ole back end server It. Me teeme kogu oma rakenduse Suures osas. Teeme Frontend is. Arendame valmis
Õpetaja: teenuste kaupa õppima neid fronti asju õppima üldist progemist
Õpetaja: ja kui Me jõuame otsapidi Backendi. Siis me hakkame täpselt samast kohast pihta. On esimene teenus. Ennem oli. Me teeme nagu lihtsalt seadistustest konfivahetused. Konf on, Praegu, Kui te võtate lahti projekti
Õpetaja: ja vaatate Aa Frondi alt,
Õpetaja: vaatate Frontend I alt niukest asja. Nagu konfig, mitte konfig.
Õpetaja: Siis siin on Hetkel öeldud, et kõik sõnumid, mis algavad apiga. Siis tulevad kõik sõnumid, mis tulevad front endile aga Url algab apiga nagu esimene osa, siis Palun suuna see
Õpetaja: Stop Light I all on praegu välja kommenteeritud. Local Host Kaheksakümmend, kaheksakümmend. Mis see Local Host on?
Õpetaja: Kohalik meie sinu enda Isiklikus arvutis käiv server. Me arendame kõik valmis seni kaua, Kuni meil Back and serverid pole, lähevad sõnumid Stop Light, I kuid saabub see, Uhke päev, Kus on kõik Frontis? Enamvähem ära tehtud. Siis kommenteerime siis selle rea välja ja teise rea sisse. Kuhu nüüd, sõnumid lähevad?
Õpetaja: Meie loodavasse backendi. Nüüd me saame arendada Backendi teenuseid ükshaaval ja saame kohe Frontend Is testida Töötab, Ei, tööta.
Õpetaja: Vot selline lahendus on selles mõttes See on olnud täielik nagu, ee, selles kvaliteedis,
Õpetaja: Nii neli minutit on Jäänud aega. Ee, Selles mõttes, et ee. Enam väga midagi ei jõua teha. Ee, rääkisime sellest andmebaasi mudelist, et hakkame siis vaatama. Korra Veel natukene ennem. Kui läheme pausile, et mis me tegema hakkame?
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja siis teha. Ee, uus vaade.
Õpetaja: Kus on sellised kastid?
Õpetaja: Ei ole vaja teha niimoodi. Et kui vajutad nuppe, siis toimub sisselogimine Ee vastusest saadud info, kes sa oled.
Õpetaja: Mis on sinu roll Selle Me salvestame Brauserisse.
Õpetaja: Browseris on Niukene salajane koht, kus saab asju Noh, salajane kõik teavad
Õpetaja: Brauserist. Noh, ütleme tavakasutaja. Ei tea. No, kui te võtate näiteks ma teen ruttu lahti. Siin Ma ei tea, Kino,
Õpetaja: Ma Apollo kino, Ma teen inspektiga Selle lahti.
Õpetaja: Siin on Niukene Tab nagu Application.
Õpetaja: Seda ikka oled näinud? Accept Cookies. Cookies. Cookies kukis. Näete, Browser is on Mingi koht, kus hoitakse küpsiseid
Õpetaja: aga. Siin on niukene Asi nagu. Local Storage Session Storage.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, Mission Store Siis on
Õpetaja: see apollo Kino on minu brauserisse salvestanud. Ee, mingisuguseid sellised asju, et input Mouse what intent mouse. Mul ei ole õrna aimu, mida need teevad, aga mis on Nüüd point on see, et senikaua, kuni mina olen selles samas sessioonis. Ma võin liikuda siin erinevate vaadete vahel ja mida iganes
Õpetaja: temal on Lihtsalt ligipääs Võti väärtus infole. See on nagu kirjafail. Ma saan siia teha uue võtme, user Id
Õpetaja: Ja panna siia ühe väärtuse kümme see. On minu Brauseris. See on. Noh, see on isiklikus Brauseris.
Õpetaja: Siia on võimalik ajutiselt salvestada informatsiooni
Õpetaja: ajutiselt selles mõttes, et see on session storage Iga Kui ma panen selle sama, panin siia User Id. See on ju siin praegu. Sessioon on praegult mul siin üleval. Ma tulin siia lehele, Kui ma panen nüüd selle siit ristist kinni.
Õpetaja: Põmm.
Õpetaja: Lähen uuesti. Apollo Agen Ee, Tasuta päästmed pole kordagi veel saanud nende käest ainult Mitte
Õpetaja: ee. Olen ikka siis, kui saad soti ära kulutad. Saad Ikka
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen uuesti selle lahti Inspect ja Panen Application ja vaatan siit. Application Storage. Need asjad. Jälle. Vaata, Brauser või see. Vabandust, see nende. See veebilehekülg lisas Aga minu See user? Id läks kaduma.
Õpetaja: Siin On olemas selline asi nagu Local Storage
Õpetaja: on siis see, et selline staff säilib Siin Forever Kui ma panen siia user Id
Õpetaja: panen näiteks Mingi Kümme mis. Iganes ma. Tulen panen, selle kinni tulen. Apollo Kinosse tagasi ten. Inspect
Õpetaja: Panen. On application Pane. Ee Application, Ja panen local Storage Scrollin siia alla. User. Id on alles
Õpetaja: see, on de Brauseris olev koht, kuhu saab Staffi panna, siin on veel igasuguseid asju, kuhu
Õpetaja: Aga loomulikult me käsitsi seda ei tee, vaid me programmeerime,
Õpetaja: kui sa logid kasutajana sisse Sellel sellel hetkel, kui Back end vastab, sinu user Id on üks ja sa oled admin. Sellel hetkel on see info teada A. Niipea kui me kuskile mujale läheme ära ja paneme oma mingi asjad ristidest kinni, See on kõik.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kes sa oled. Siis ongi see, et salvestame sinna Sessions Store sisse või Local Story sisse. Vahet pole, salvestame selle info sinna ära.
Õpetaja: Kui sina nüüd liigud uuele lehele
Õpetaja: uuele vaatele, siis sa saad samamoodi, nagu saad programmid programmiliselt panna sinna väärtuseid. Saad sa siis nende võtmete abil ka ülesse leida ja võtta
Õpetaja: programmeerid, et otsi sealt Session Storesist User Ready. Aga Mis see väärtus paned? Kuhu selle väärtuse,
Õpetaja: Kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab midagi, teeb Sa nagu ütled kett, nagu ma Ei tea, see välju selle Id abil. Siis sa.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: ja Jaroslav ei saa veel. Teil ei ole see hetk, kus ee kellestki saab Palvepüüdja Davai. Ta oli väike diaser. Ee, viis minutit. Teeme veel tundi.
Õpetaja: Mis kell siis tagasi? Minu kalkulaator seda peast ei võta.
Õpetaja: Kakskümmend viis Bye, teeme nii.
Õpetaja: Kuidas muidu praegu? See tundus Siin Saite midagi aru ka aega võtab.
Õpetaja: Võtab siis. Aa, Okei,
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlesin, et seletame. Noh, Võtab alati setimist. On vaja. No võibolla mitte. Me oleme alati äppinud Ainult sellest. Me pole midagi praktilist teinud, onju, et? Aga see on Juba hea, kui te midagi vaikselt.
Õpetaja: Ma panen nüüd stopi ka. Aidke meeles Hoida Stopi siia. Ära.